THANK YOU MUCH
FOR BEING PATIENT. PRACTICES.
RECOGNIZE YOU TAKE OFF YOUR MASK
WHEN YOU'RE OUTDOORS ALONG IS
THAT YOU ARE SAFE- BUT WE ARE-
ASKING FOLKS TO PLEASE KEEP IN
MIND WHEN YOU'RE INDOORS FOR ALL
FIFTY REASONS. WE HAVE STARTED
THE SECOND HOW WAS THE- WARNING
SHOT THANK YOU.
AND IT LOOKS
LIKE- WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND-
GET STARTED I WANT TO WELCOME-
EVERYBODY WAS COME HERE TODAY-
INCLUDES SEVERAL OF OUR
COLLEAGUES MR- JONES SAWYER-
MISTRAL DONALD AND MR BLOOM WHO
WILL BE IN SHORTLY- WE ALSO AT.
WE ALSO ARE GRATEFUL FOR THE
UPRISING SILVA- LARA CITY
CONTROLLER WHO IS HERE AS WELL
AND HE'LL BE ABLE TO SPEAK IN A
SECOND- BEFORE I GET STARTED I
WANT TO GO AHEAD AND OPEN IT UP
TO ANY COMMITTEE MEMBER
CERTAINLY YEAH. I CAN GO BUT I
FEEL THAT THE- THE DRIVEN AS FAR
THAT I WOULD. GO HEAD TO MAYBE
START OFF WITH SOME OF THE
COMMENTS FROM MARA. FOR MORE
SOME OF THE MEMBERS WHO HAVE
SHOWED UP IF YOU WANNA GO NOW GO
LATER AND TALKING WITH ME- HE
JUST PRESS IT ONCE. MISTER
MISTER JONES SAWYER GOES IT GOES
TO LIKE A NEON FROM GREEN. HEAR
ME THERE WE GO ALL RIGHT- LET'S
LET'S. WRITTEN IT MIGHT BE BEST
TO GET THE POLITICIANS GOT AWAY
SO WE COULD ACTUALLY HEAR PEOPLE
WHO REALLY DO THE WORK- MY NAME
IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER REGGIE JONES
SAWYER. A REPRESENTS SOUTH LOS
ANGELES AND IN FACT. THIS YOU'RE
ONLY TEN MINUTES AWAY FROM MY
ACTUAL HOME. AND SO THIS WAS NOT
A DRIVE FOR ME AND I DRIVE
THROUGH HERE QUITE FREQUENTLY ON
SEVERAL ERRANDS AND IACTUALLY
KNOW. FIRST HAND WHAT IT'S LIKE
WHOA WHAT IS LIKE- FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE IN IN IN THIS THIS
CONDITION HOMELESSNESS
CONDITION. AND O- I'M HERE.
BECAUSE MY CONSTITUENCY. REALLY
WANT TO SEE SOMETHING HAPPEN-
THERE'S A- I USED TO WORK FOR
MAYOR RICHARD J. RIORDAN-
RESTORE FOR RICH WHITE
REPUBLICAN MAYOR. AND USED TO
TALK ABOUT ANALYSIS PARALYSIS-
WE GOTTA STOP ANALYZING WE'VE
ANALYZE THIS TO DEATH. AND I'M
TIRED OF TALKING ABOUT IT. WE
NEED TO START. DOING SOMETHING
AND A PUBLIC. IF THEY HAVEN'T
ALREADY STARTED TO DEMAND THAT
WE HAVE RESULTS. WE DON'T HAVE
RESULTS PRETTY SOON- YOU MAY SEE
A DIFFERENT SET OF PEOPLE
SITTING UP HERE AS ELECTED
OFFICIALS SO. I'M HERE TO PUSH
VERY HARD TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE RESULTS POSITIVE RESULTS
THAT HELP PEOPLE WHO ARE ON THE
STREET BECAUSE IN MANY WAYS IT'S
A PUBLIC HEALTH. DISASTER BUT A
PUBLIC HEALTH PRIORITY AND WE
NEED TO EFFECTIVELY- BEGIN TO DO
THE THINGS WE NEED TO DO. TO
HELP THE LEAST AMOUNT OF. THANK. ONE MICHAEL SURE WELL- YEAH
I'D BETTER GO DOWN HERE STATE
ASSEMBLY- SO MANY DISTRICTS
SEVENTY LONG BEACH ZERO HULL
SAMPEDRO AND CATALINA ISLAND I
PROBABLY DROVE THE FURTHEST HERE
TODAY- BUT THIS ISSUE IS NEAR TO
MY DISTRICT AS WELL AS WE KNOW
THIS IS A CALIFORNIA NATIONAL
PROBLEM THAT WE NEED TO DEAL
WITH- AND I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS OF MR JONES SAWYER THAT
THE DALLAS IS BY PARALYSIS OF
ROUSES ROUNDHOUSE IS WHATEVER IT
MAY BE IT'S HAPPENING WE'RE
LOCKED IN IT RIGHT NOW SO I'M
NOT HERE TO TALK I'M HERE TO
LISTEN TO FOLKS. BUT I WELL I DO
WANT TO COMMEND THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES AND ONE THING THEY HAVE
A PLAN THAT YOU CAN TOUCH ITS ON
PAPER AND MANY COMMUNITIES WHO
ARE RECEIVING A LOTS OF MONEY
ACROSS THE STATE DO NOT HAVE A
PLAN THEY CANNOT GIVE YOU A
PIECE OF PAPER UPON WHICH THEIR
PLAN- YOU CAN REACH I LONG BEACH
IS A GREAT EXAMPLE I LIVE IN
LONG BEACH WE CALL THE CITY
MANAGER'S OFFICE AND MY OFFICE
COLOR IT CAN WE GET THE PLAN FOR
HOMELESSNESS YOU KNOW THE STATUS
WHAT'S GOING ON I'M SURE AND
WHAT THE PLAN IS AS MORE MONEY
COMES THERE IS NO PLAN. IN LONG
BEACH CALIF LA HAS A PLAN I KNOW
IMPLEMENTATION IS BENEFIT ROCKY
BUT IT IS MOVING FORWARD
SHELTERS ARE OPENING SERVICES
ARE BEING OFFERED THEY ARE TO A
BED IN LONG BEACH BUT AGAIN
THERE'S NO PLAN THERE SO I DON'T
I HOPE WE JUST DON'T TALK ABOUT
LA TODAY BUT ALSO OTHER
COMMUNITIES WHAT THEY ARE DOING
AND MAYBE WHAT THEY'RE NOT OING
TO ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM SO THAT
I'M READY TO SIT BACK AND LISTEN
BACK. TO YOU MISTER CHAIR.
MISTER BLOOM. THANK YOU MR SANTI
. AND YOU FOR- PUTTING TO. THE
SELECT COMMITTEE OR- TEARING THE
FLESH COMMITTEE. PITCHING THE
IDEA TO THE SPEAKER AND WE
SHOULD ALL THANK THE SPEAKER
FOR. FORMING THE SELECT
COMMITTEE- I'VE BEEN WORKING ON
HOMELESSNESS FOR TWENTY TWO
YEARS SINCE I WAS FIRST ELECTED
TO THE SANTA MONICA CITY
COUNCIL- AND IF YOU. HAD TOLD ME
BACK THEN. THAT I WOULD STILL BE
WORKING ON THE ISSUE AND THAT
THINGS HAVEN'T GOTTEN BETTER
THEY'VE ACTUALLY GOTTEN WORSE I
WOULD HAVE. PROBABLY LOOK AT YOU
CROSS EYED- BUT AFTER. WORKING
ON THE ISSUE NOW FOR THAT PERIOD
OF TIME I JUST I KNOW I KNOW
HOW. COMPLEX AND NUANCED IT IS
AND I ALSO KNOW WHAT'S CHANGED-
THAT THAT I MEAN FOR EXAMPLE WE
DON'T HAVE A MATH EPIDEMIC-
BACKGROUND NO. NO YOU KNOW THERE
WAS A LOT OF- SUBSTANCE ABUSE
BUT IT WAS PREDOMINATELY
ALCOHOL- AND THERE ARE OTHER
THINGS THAT HAVE CHANGED TOO WE
DIDN'T HAVE. A HOUSING CRISIS.
THEN THE WAY WE DO NOW- SO IT'S
GOOD TO BE ABLE TO GET TOGETHER
AN UPDATE OURSELVES AND- I DO A
REALITY CHECK I KNOW EVERYBODY
HAS CONCERNS ABOUT THIS ISSUE
ONE THING THAT HAS CHANGED. IS
THAT- EVERYBODY IS- AWARE OF.
AND CONCERNED ABOUT AND- AND-
PROBABLY ALMOST EVERY CASE ANGRY
WHEN I SAY EVERYBODY I MEAN ALL
OF OUR CONSTITUENTS- ANGRY ABOUT
HOMELESSNESS- AND WONDERING. WHY
WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO RESOLVE
ITSELF. I'M GLAD TO BE HERE
ENGAGE IN THIS DISCUSSION- THERE
IS SO MUCH MORE THAT WE CAN BE
DOING AND- I. I LOOK FORWARD TO
HAVING THAT DIALOGUE. ONLY
BECAUSE WE STARTED ALREADY OVER
HERE I'M. GONNA IF IT'S OKAY
WITH YOU SENATOR WOULD YOU GO.
IS ON YOU GET TO TOUCH IT NOW
GOES TO A NEW. YEAH MY NAME MY
NAME IS BOB HER ON THE FORMER
SPEAKER THE ASSEMBLY AND
CURRENTLY THE MAJORITY LEADER OF
THE CALIFORNIA SENATE.
REPRESENTS SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
AND I'M HERE TO WORK. DO
WHATEVER IT TAKES WHATEVER IT
TAKES TO FIX THIS ISSUE IS TOO
BIG IT IS TOO IMPORTANT AND YOU
KNOW IF WE CAN'T GET IT DONE
THEY SHOULD TO US ALL OFFICE AND
TRY TO FIND SOMEBODY WHO SHOULD.
WE GOTTA GET IT DONE THERE ARE
NO EXCUSES. JUST FOLLOWING ALONG
THE TRADITION TO GIVE THEM WOULD
YOU BE OKAY WITH GOING NEXT.
YEAR FIRST OF ALL LET ME SAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO MIGUEL
SANTIAGO ARE CHAIR OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE. ON HOMELESSNESS MY
NAME IS MIKE GIPSON- I REPRESENT
I GUESS NO NO NO MORE NUMBERS
BUT- WHAT'S WILL OF WORK I WAS
WONDER REYES COMPTON CARSON
WOMAN TO NORTH LONG BEACH.
LYNWOOD ALSO GUARDINO. THE MAKES
UP A HALF MILLION PEOPLE ALSO
SHARE THE ASSEMBLY DEMOCRATIC
ALL BECAUSE I'M HAPPY WANT TO BE
HERE. I'M EXCITED TO ONE THAT.
ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES ARE HAVE
JOINED US TO HAVE THIS- VERY
IMPORTANT ROBUST DISCUSSION
AROUND HOMELESSNESS I WILL GO
OUT ON A LIMB TO SAY THAT I MAY
BE THE ONLY ONE UP HERE- SINCE
BEING ELECTED TO THE STATE
ASSEMBLY. WHO SPEND THE NIGHT
WITH HOMELESS PEOPLE EVERY YEAR.
OF 200-014-1516 SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN AND NINETEEN WAS THE
LAST TIME THAT I SPEND THE NIGHT
WITH HOMELESS PEOPLE DO THIS
PANDEMIC. THE REASON WHY SPEND
THE NIGHT IS BECAUSE I WANT TO
MAKE SURE- ONE THAT I UNDERSTAND
THIS ISSUE. I DON'T WANT JUST
PASSED BY IT- ON A FREEWAY.
LET'S SEE AN ACT LIKE IT DOESN'T
EXIST I WANT TO SPEND THE NIGHT
WITH HOMELESS PEOPLE THAT'S ONE
OF THE REASONS WHY TWO THOUSAND
AND- NINETEEN AUTHOR BILL.
MAKING CRIMES AGAINST HOMELESS
PEOPLE HATE CRIME. WHY DID YOU
DO THAT WELL I'M GLAD YOU ASKED
PEOPLE LOOK AND TARGET PEOPLE
WHO ARE HOMELESS BECAUSE THEIR
HOMELESS. LET ME SAY THAT AGAIN
THEY TARGET PEOPLE BECAUSE THEY
ARE HOMELESS JUST LIKE IF YOU
TARGET SOMEONE BECAUSE YOU'RE
ASIAN BECAUSE YOU'RE GAY BECAUSE
THEY'RE JEWISH. IT'S A HATE
CRIME AND SO- WASN'T SUCCESSFUL
WILL KEEP TRYING BUT THAT GIVES
AN EXAMPLE. OF MY- COMMITMENT TO
THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE MY GOD SON
IS HOMELESS MY GOD SON IS ON
CRYSTAL METH. MY GOD SOME WILL
WIND UP ON MY DOOR AT ANY MOMENT
SO THIS SITUATION IS ABSOLUTELY
REAL- HE'S SO FAR GONE HE. COULD
EVEN WHEN I TOOK HIM TO A MOTEL
AFTER. REACH OUT TO THE OF LOS
ANGELES OPERATION KEY. BECAUSE
HE WASN'T BACK. AND SO I PER HIM
TO. A HE COULD NOT EVEN WRITE
HIS NAME. HE COULD WRITE HIS
NAME. AND BECAUSE HE SUFFERED
TRAUMA. AS A CHILD LOSING BOTH
THE MOTHER AND FATHER DUE TO
AIDS. AND HIS BIOLOGICAL
GRANDPARENTS TO NEVER NEVER GOT
HIM THE CARD TO HELP AT SIX
YEARS OLD AT SIX YEARS OLD THE
TRAUMA THAT HE WAS FACED WITH
CONTINUE TO SPILL OVER TO THE
DAHLE LIFE AND NOW HE'S
SOMEWHERE AGAIN. ON THE STREETS
UNDER THE RAIN UNDER A BRIDGE SO
THIS IS ABSOLUTELY I'M COMMITTED
TO THIS ISSUE I'M SERIOUS ABOUT
THIS ISSUE AND IT WE HAVE TO
FIND A SOLUTION TO THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU. GERMAN SANTIAGO FOR
CONVENING THIS IS A VERY.
ALBERT'S THE CHANGE THAT IS OUT
THERE. DOWNEY SUBURBAN COMMITTEE
THAT THE LOOK FOR DIFFERENT MY
DRY OVER THE HEARING I USED TO
WORK IN THE TOKYO AND SO. HOW
MUCH WORSE. THE CRISIS THE
HOMELESS CRISIS CONTINUES TO GET
. BUT I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT
THIS IS DEFINITELY NOT JUST A
CITY OF LOS ANGELES PROBLEM. I'M
GONNA BE FOLLOWING MISTER
GIBSON'S LEAD IN TERMS OF
SPENDING A NIGHT IN A HOMELESS
SHELTER WHEN A TORRANCE BILLS
ITS FIRST TINY HOME SHELTER. TO
BRING HOME THE POINT THAT
HOMELESSNESS IS EVERYWHERE IT'S
NOT JUST. AND OUR URBAN CORE BUT
IT'S IN OUR SUBURBAN COMMUNITIES
IT'S EVERYWHERE AND SO I'M HERE.
TO ADD TO THE SENSE OF URGENCY.
TO GET PEOPLE OFF OUR STREETS OF
OUR SIDEWALKS INTO SHELTER AND
TO HOUSING. THANK YOU FOR COMING
IN AND. HAS IT THAT THE START
BUT BUT I WILL AND- OF COURSE
YOU CAN TAKE OFF YOUR MASK WENT
WHEN YOU FEEL NEEDED WE ARE
OUTDOORS- MONIES BECAUSE ON THE-
I REPRESENT THE FIFTY THIRD
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT- PROBABLY- THE
EPICENTER OF HOMELESSNESS- HERE
IN THE STATES AND PROBABLY THE
COUNTRY. AND THIS ISN'T A
PROBLEM THAT JUST BEGAN ONE DAY
THIS IS BEEN DECADES AND DECADES
OF POLICIES. ARE MEANT TO DO
WELL BUT QUITE FRANKLY DIDN'T
LIVE UP TO EXPECTATION- SOME
MIGHT SAY AND- I WOULD ARGUE IN
SOME CASES FAILED. BECAUSE THE
PART OF THE HOMELESS POPULATIONS
CONTINUE TO GROW- PART OF WHAT I
WANTED TO DO TODAY I THINK YOU
ARE COLLEAGUES WANTED TWO DAYS
TALK ABOUT WHAT WORKED AND WHAT
HASN'T WORKED IN NOT SUGAR
COATING IT. BOTH ON THE STATE
SIDE. FEDERAL AND LOCAL. A. N.
ONE OF THESE UP WANT TO KIND OF
PERCENT AT THE BEGINNING OF THIS
IS WE CAN'T. CONTINUE TO DO THE
SAME THING OVER AND OVER AND
EXPECTING DIFFERENT RESULTS- I
THINK THERE'S OFTEN A KNOWLEDGE
MEANT THAT WE'RE ALL IN THIS
TOGETHER. ROB LINGER POINTING
WE'RE NOT SAYING- THIS AND HE
DID THIS THIS AND HE DID THAT
BUT THAT IT TOOK JOINT
RESPONSIBILITY WHERE IT'S AN ALL
HANDS ON DECK EMERGENCY THAT
WE'VE GOT TO. WE'VE GOT TO
ADDRESS- YESTERDAY- THIS LIKE
COMMITTEE WAS SET UP A FOR A
COUPLE YEARS AGO YEARS AGO. OF
THE LAST MEETING WE HAD IN TWO
THOUSAND AND NINETEEN. PROPOSED
A NUMBER OF PUBLIC POLICY- THE
PLAN PROPOSALS THAT WE THEN
IMPLEMENTED.OVER THE NEX YEAR
NOW KOBE HIT WE HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO MEET IS THE FIRST TIME WE
MET. AND WE THOUGHT THAT WOULD
BE APPROPRIATE TO AT LEAST POINT
OUT A COUPLE THINGS THAT WE HAD
TALKED ABOUT IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THAT THEN WERE
IMPLEMENTED THAT. ARE NOW ON PAR
LAWSUIT WE'RE NOT JUST MEETING
FOR THE SAKE OF MEETING FOR THE
SAKE OF SAYING THINGS WE USE. WE
DOUBLE DOWN- WHEN WE TALKED
ABOUT INVESTMENTS- AND NOW WE
LOOK AT THE STATE INVESTING
TWELVE BILLION OVER THE NEXT TWO
YEARS. AT SIX BILLION OVER THE
NEXT TWO YEARS AND THAT'S JUST
THE START- WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
INVESTMENTS WE WERE TALKING
ABOUT THEN ABOUT HAVING EIGHT
EIGHT A REVENUE STREAM AND WE
DID THAT. AND IN TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN WE HAD HAD A BILLION TO
OVER BILLION DOLLARS. IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TWENTY COULD BE HIT
BUT WE STILL INVESTED IN THAT'S
WHEN YOU SAW MORE INNOVATIVE
WORK LIKE HOME KEY ROOM KEY- IN
IN TWENTY WE FOUGHT VERY HARD
EVERYBODY HERE AND WE'VE GOT. A
UNPRECEDENTED INVESTMENT IN
HOMELESSNESS. BUT BUT BUT I MEAN
LET'S LET'S BE VERY HONEST ABOUT
IT WE STILL SAW AN EXPLOSION
HOMELESSNESS. I WE SAW- IN
TWENTY TWENTY APPOINTING COUNTY
SIXTY SIX THOUSAND PEOPLE. A
LAND ON THE STREETS OF FORTY ONE
THOUSAND IN L. A. COUNTY- A-
IT'S SIXTY SIX THOUSAND IN A
CITY IN THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES THAT WAS EIGHT ALMOST
I'M SING ROUND NUMBERS ALL DAY
TODAY SO MAYBEWE WANT TO PAY ME
TO A EXACT NUMBER- NO WE'RE NOT
DOING THAT- IS. ABOUT 13%
INCREASE IN THE COUNTY AND ABOUT
16% INCREASE IN THE CITY. IF YOU
ASK ANY RESIDENT ANY STAKEHOLDER
IN THE REGION. IF THEY BELIEVE
THAT HOMELESSNESS HAS HAD A
DRINK OR ANY SORT OF IMPROVEMENT
A SAW OR SO OR WE BEGUN TO SOLVE
IT. ARE THEY WOULD THEY WOULD
THEY WOULD THINK WE'RE DOING.
SOMETHING MORE THAN JUST
DRINKING THAT WERE DELUSIONAL.
HOMELESSNESS HAS GOTTEN WORSE
FOR THE QUICK SOCIAL RASKIN
TODAY IS. A IS WE CAN'T CONTINUE
DO THE SAME THING OVER AND OVER
AND EXPECTING A DIFFERENT
RESULT. AND I DON'T THINK ANY
RESIDENT WHAT WOULD IT IN ANY
POLL WOULD SHOW. UP POLL OR ANY
RESIDENT WALKING DOWN THE STREET
OR ANY STAKEHOLDER. THAT WE'VE
ACTUALLY MADE IT TO GET. EVEN
THOUGH WE'VE DONE ON
UNPRECEDENTED INVESTMENT. SO
WE'VE GOT TO TAKE A LOOK AT ALL
DIFFERENT SOLUTIONS WHETHER MORE
INNOVATIVE SOLUTIONS THAT WOULD
PEOPLE TALK ABOUT TINY HOMES
TODAY- WE'VE GOT REPORTS ABOUT
ABOUT THE WAY THAT THE
GOVERNMENT STRUCTURE TODAY- WE
GOT SERVICE PROVIDERS WE'VE GOT
A GOVERNMENT AGENCIES AND IN
FACT THE CITY COMPTROLLER DID A
REPORT. A COUPLE YEARS AGO OR A
YEAR AGO HILL CORRECT ME WHEN IT
WAS THAT THAT HASN'T BEEN REALLY
HURT AND SO WE INVITED HIM TODAY
TO HAVE THAT HURT SO WE'RE NOT
LOOKING AT FINGERPOINTING WE'RE
LOOKING AT A KNOWLEDGE IN THAT
IT IS A SERIOUS PROBLEM. THAT
THE CURRENT SOLUTION TO NOT
ADDRESS THE PROBLEM AND WE'VE
GOT TO BE INNOVATIVE AND WHERE
THE STATE HAS NOT STEPPED UP TO
ITS EXPECTATIONS SAY IT OKAY
WELL GROWN ADULTSHERE WE WANT
TO IMPROVE THINGS BUT WHERE
THERE ARE OTHER AREAS THAT HAVE
ALSO NOT STEPPED UP WE SHOULD
SAY THAT TOO BECAUSE THE
HOMELESS POPULATION HAS GROWN
NOT DECREASED. THE FOCUS TODAY.
REALLY IS ABOUT HOUSING. AND
SHELTER AND ROOF OVER THE HEAD.
THAT'S REALLY WHAT THE FOCUS IS
TODAY SO WE WE'RE NOT GONNA
SPEND A LOT OF TIME A MENTAL
HEALTH CARE SERVICES- BECAUSE WE
WANTED TO DO THAT AND COME BACK
LATER DIFFERENT DAY AND TALK
ABOUT. A MENTAL HEALTH CARE WHAT
WE LEARNED IN THE LAST COMMITTEE
HEARING THAT WE HAD- THAT WE
SPEND A LOT OF TIME. IN
DIFFERENT AREAS WE WANT TO FOCUS
TODAY ON TO SHELTER OVER
PEOPLE'S HEADS. NOW ORIGINALLY
WE WANTED TO DO THIS OUTSIDE. WE
STUCK TO OUR GUNS AND DID
OUTSIDE BECAUSE YOU COULD YOU
IMAGINE IF YOU WERE A WHOLE. AND
MY WIFE I SPENT THE NIGHT A
COUPLE DIFFERENT PLACES. AS WELL
BUT BUT BUT- BUT YOU CERTAINLY
WERE THE LEAD IN MAKING. THAT
CHANGE NUMBER TELLS IT WE GOTTA
GO OUT THERE EXPERIENCE A NIGHT
ON THE STREET. OR WE WON'T KNOW
HOW TO TALK ABOUT IT. NOW I
WOULD I WOULD SAY THOUGH IS- WE
DID OUTSIDE BACK TO MY ORIGINAL
POINT. IS BECAUSE COULD YOU
IMAGINE. I MEAN FOR SOME OF US
ARE ARE STRUGGLING TO STAY OUT
HERE FOR A COUPLE HOURS DURING
HEARING. AND THE SET UP
INFRASTRUCTURE DO THIS. COULD
YOU IMAGINE IF THIS WAS YOUR
LIFE. DAY IN DAY OUT. THIS IS AN
ABOUT THREE FOUR HOURS THE
CONVENIENCE OUTSIDE. IF YOU WALK
OUTSIDE HERE ALL OVER LOS
ANGELES CITY ALL OVER L. A.
COUNTY. IS TEN CITIES EVERYWHERE
WE CAN'T SUGAR COAT THAT. CAN'T
TEN CITIES EVERYWHERE PEOPLE
LIVING IN A N. N. INTENSE PEOPLE
LIVING ON THE CARDBOARD BOXES
PEOPLE LIVING UNDER WOULD SHIFT-
MAKE HOME HOUSES- PEOPLE LIVING
UNDER OFFRAMP ALL ACROSS THE
COUNTY ALL ACROSS THE CITY OF
LOS ANGELES. WE'VE GOT TO
ADDRESS THIS PART AND WE SEE
THAT ALL RIGHT IT CAN GO ON ON
THE LIST OF THINGS. SO THIS IS
JUST A MINOR INCONVENIENCE OF A
COUPLE OF HOURS. BUT IF THIS WAS
YOUR REALITY. FOR YEARS. COULD
YOU IMAGINE IF THERE WAS A SENSE
OF URGENCY TO GETTING THE WORK
DONE. SO I HOPE THIS INSTILLS A
SENSE OF URGENCY WILL TALK ABOUT
SIMPLE TO TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
THERE'S A POLL THAT REVEALED.
THAT 95% OF THE VOTERS THOUGHT
HOMELESSNESS WAS THE BIGGEST
PROBLEM AND THAT THEY WERE ANGRY
FRUSTRATED OVERWHELMED. TODAY WE
INVITE SOMEBODY TO WALK THROUGH
A POLL THAT JUST SHOWS THAT THE
PART OF THAT THE FRUSTRATION OF
THE PROBLEMS GOT WORSE- IN OUR
RESIDENTS SIZE. AND IT NOW IT
REELS A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT.
THERE'S NO DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
WHAT THE YOUR STATE OR LOCAL A
REPRESENTATIVE THEY DON'T SEE A
DIFFERENCE ANYMORE OR WHERE OR
WHAT YOU REPRESENT WE'RE ALL
PART OF THE PROBLEM AND WE'LL
FIX IT I THINK OUR COLLEAGUE THE
SENATE. FOUND A BOTTOM OUT HOW
TO PUT US OUT BOTTOM LINE SO
WE'RE DONE WITH EXCUSES IT ALSO
REVEALS THAT PEOPLE WANT FASTER
ACTION AND FOCUSED ON SHORT TERM
WE WERE HERE LAST TIME I DON'T
THINK THAT WAS THE CASE TODAY
PEOPLE ARE SAYING EMERGENCY
SHELTERS. TINY HOMES WHATEVER IT
IS GONNA GET PEOPLE OFF THE
STREETS GONNA PUSH SHELTER OVER
THEM THAT'S IT N. N. AND I WANT.
IT I WANT TO EMPHASIZE AGAIN
EINSTEIN'S THEORY OF INSANITY
RIGHT CAN'T KEEP DOING THE SAME
THING OVER AND OVER EXPECTING A
DIFFERENT RESULT. BUT BUT I
WANTED TO SAY THAT I'M GRATEFUL
FOR EVERYBODY WHO HAS COME ON
BOARD TO DATE THAT- THE HELP.
AND IN THE HAVE A PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATION SO THAT WE GET TO A
PLACE- WE'RE HAVING THESE. THESE
POSITIVE RESULTS- THAT IS HUMANE
FOR THE PEOPLE LIVE ON THE
STREET. OUR AIR AND IT BEGINS TO
SATISFY OUR STUD EVERYONE'S HERE
COLLECTIVE SENSE OF URGENCY TO
SOLVE THE PROBLEM OF
HOMELESSNESS- WITH A COUPLE A
COUPLE PANELS THE FIRST ONE WILL
TALK ABOUT- THE COST OF
INVESTING IN HOMELESSNESS
HOUSING. AND HOW MUCH WE BUILT
OVER THE LAST COUPLE YEARS IN
THE REGION- WHAT THE GOOD THE
BAD AND THE UGLY WE WANT TO TALK
ABOUT- THE PARTY AS WELL. ALL IN
THE SECOND- WE ALSO WANT A
SECOND SET OF PANELS THAT THE
SECOND THIRD PANEL- IT'S- COME
FROM THE PROVIDER PERSPECTIVE OF
PROVIDING. HOUSING AND FOR OUR
HOUSE NEIGHBORS. WHAT WORKED
WHAT HASN'T THAT'S BROKEN UP
INTO DIFFERENT PANELS. FROM A
LOCAL GOVERNMENT PERSPECTIVE AND
FROM A SERVICE BUT PROVIDER
PERSPECTIVE. I WANT TO EMPHASIZE
ONE MORE TIME- WE'RE ALL IN THIS
TOGETHER IT'S NOT A FINGER
POINTING SESSION. BUT IT'S ABOUT
HAVING AN HONEST CONVERSATION
ABOUT THE GOOD THE AT THAT THE
BAD THE UGLY WHAT WORKED AND
WHAT HASN'T- AND WITH THAT I'D
LIKE TO BEGIN- OUR PANEL AND-
I'D LIKE TO INVITE FIRST IF
YOU'RE OKAY WITH THE MISTER
CONTROLLER- TO COME IN PERCENT
I'M GONNA TAKE A LOT OF
GUIDANCE- FROM- FROM FOLKS
BEHIND ME AS WELL- BUT IF YOU
LIKE THE PRESENT WE WOULD BE.
EXTREMELY GRATEFUL AGAIN WE DID
THIS OUTSIDE NOT FOR A SESSION
OF INCONVENIENCE BUT COULD YOU
IMAGINE. IF THIS WAS YOUR LIFE.
BUT ACCEPTABLE. MISTER
CONTROLLER DAHLE YEARS. IN A
PRESS IT ONCE AND I'M GONNA TIME
EVERYBODY TO FIVE MINUTES JUST
TO THAT WERE AROUND COMFORTABLY
AND I SHOULD HAVE BEEN A LITTLE
BIT BETTER WITH MY- MANNERS-
AMISS AND WHO WOULD YOU ALSO-
SIT DOWN I APOLOGIZE. I SKIPPED
A LITTLE BIT OF THE
INTRODUCTIONS BUT I'M HOPING
THAT YOU INTRODUCE YOURSELF-
JUSTIN IN THIS IN THIS TO GET
THE PROGRAM MOVING. MISTRUST
MISSIVES A THIRD OF ALL PLEASE
AS WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH I'M
SORRY JOB RIGHT INTO IT THANK
YOU. A GOOD MORNING AND THANK
YOU SO VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO INTO EACH OF THE-
LEGISLATORS WHO ARE HERE AS WELL
AS EVERYBODY ELSE IS ATTENDING
THIS HEARING BOTH. HERE AND
VIRTUALLY. AND IN MANY WAYS IT
SEEMS SO APPROPRIATE AS YOU
MENTIONED ASSEMBLY MEMBER THAT
WE ARE OUTDOORS AND WE ARE IN A
TENT ON A RAINY DAY. AND IMAGINE
WHAT IT IS LIKE FOR THE MANY
MANY THOUSANDS WHO EXPERIENCE
THAT EACH AND EVERY SINGLE DAY.
OF HOMELESSNESS IS REALLY THE
EXISTENTIALIST CRISIS OF OUR
TIME IN LOS ANGELES IT'S
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS IT'S A MORAL
CRISIS A PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS. A
COMMUNITY SAFETY CRISIS AND IT'S
ALSO CRISIS THAT I BELIEVE
THREATENS THE VERY DESIRABILITY
OF LOS ANGELES AS A PLACE TO
LIVE TO VISIT TO DO BUSINESS. WE
HAVE THE HIGHEST NUMBER OF
UNSHELTERED PEOPLE LIVING ON OUR
STREETS. AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT
BETWEEN MARCH TWENTY TWENTY AND
JULY OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
FIFTEEN HUNDRED ON HEALTH ELLIE
RESIDENTS DIED ON OUR STREETS.
THAT'S BETWEEN THREE AND FOUR
PEOPLE A DAY. IT'S UTTERLY
UNCONSCIONABLE AND IT'S TRAGIC
AND IT'S LARGELY PREVENTABLE. I
IN MY OFFICE HAVE DEDICATED
SIGNIFICANT TIME TO ANALYZING
VARIOUS ASPECTS OF THE CITY
BAILEY'S RESPONSE TO
HOMELESSNESS. AND WHAT I WANT TO
ADDRESS NOTABLY IS THE ONGOING
AUDITS AND REVIEWS THAT WE'VE
DONE OF TRIPLE H. ON THERE OF
COURSE MANY REASONS THAT PEOPLE
ARE HOMELESS BUT HOUSING IS KEY.
AND A FOCUS OF THE CITY'S
EFFORTS TO ALLEVIATE
HOMELESSNESS OVER THE LAST FIVE
YEARS HAS BEEN TRIPLE H. THIS IS
THE ONE POINT TWO BILLION DOLLAR
VOTER APPROVED TAX PAYER. BOND
MEASURE FROM TWO THOUSAND AND
SIXTEEN THE PROMISE TO RESULT IN
UP TO TEN THOUSAND UNITS
APARTMENT PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING FOR THOSE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. AS OF TODAY WE
HAVE JUST OVER ONE THOUSAND OF
THESE UNITS COMPLETED- I FIRST
LOOK AT TRIPLE H. PROJECT IN
OCTOBER OF TWENTY NINETEEN AND
RECOMMENDING REALLOCATING FUNDS.
TO WHAT I BELIEVE WE'RE LOWER
COST PROJECTS TO STREAMLINING
PERMITTING AND ALSO OTHER THINGS
THAT CAN BE DONE TO GET MORE
PEOPLE OFF THE STREETS MORE
QUICKLY. BECAUSE IT'S TAKING WAY
TOO LONG AND I'LL GIVE YOU SOME
DETAILS OF WHAT THAT IS ABOUT.
NOW LAST MONTH THE CITY ISSUED
TWO HUNDRED AND TWO WELL OF
MILLION DOLLARS IN NEW TRIPLE H.
DEPT OF THE PREVIOUS ISSUANCE
WAS ALL THE WAY BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN. WE HAD
ACTUALLY. ISSUED UP UNTIL JUST
LAST MONTH ONLY THREE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS OF
THE ONE POINT TWO BILLION IN
BOND CAPACITY. NOW WE'VE ISSUED
AN ADDITIONAL TWO HUNDRED AND
TWELVE MILLION. BUT HE THE
ORIGINAL THREE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
TWO MILLION FORTY FOUR MILLION
REMAINS UNSPENT AND OF COURSE
NONE OF THE- RECENT TWO HUNDRED
AND TWELVE HAS BEEN SPENT YET.
AS OF NOVEMBER OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE ONLY SEVENTEEN OF ONE
HUNDRED AND TEN PROJECTS HAVE
BEEN COMPLETED I REGRET TO SAY
DESPITE A LOT OF GREAT EFFORTS
FROM A LOT OF PEOPLE A LOT OF
WONDERFUL PEOPLE WHO ARE
INVOLVED IN THE PROCESS. BUT
IT'S A PROCESS THAT IS BEEN
FRAUGHT WITH PROBLEMS- JUST OVER
ONE THOUSAND BOND FUNDED UNITS
ARE ACTUALLY IN SERVICE. OF
WORLD TOLD THAT THERE WILL BE
SEVEN THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED SOME
UNITS ARE TRANSLATING INTO ABOUT
EIGHTY THREE HUNDRED BEDS. NOW
THERE'S ALSO INNOVATION
CHALLENGE PROJECTS THAT'S A
HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
SET ASIDE. RIGHT NOW THEY'RE
FIFTEEN PROJECTS IN THE PIPELINE
THESE WERE THE ONES THAT WERE
SUPPOSED TO GET DONE QUICKLY.
BUT ACTUALLY NONE ARE COMPLETED
AND TWO ARE UNDER CONSTRUCTION-
OF THE ONE POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS ALSO THIS FORTY SEVEN
MILLION THAT'S BEEN SPENT FOR
FACILITY PROJECTS. AND WHAT
WE'RE FINDING IS THAT THE
HOUSING IS TAKING FOUR TO SIX
YEARS TO BUID. NOW ALL THE
CITIES PAYING ABOUT AN AVERAGE
OF A HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR EACH TRIPLE
H. UNIT. UP AND WHILE THE UNITS
WERE SUPPOSED TO COST BETWEEN
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
TO FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
THOUSAND. THE AVERAGE IS NOW AT
FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS A DOOR THAT'S
ROUGHLY THE SAME AS PURCHASING A
NEW SINGLE FAMILY. AT A RATHER A
NEW CONDO IN L. A. COUNTY. AND
WHAT WE HAVE FOUND ALSO IS THAT
THERE ARE UNITS THAT ARE COSTING
AS MUCH AS SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS. AND WE ARE
EXPECTING THAT THAT NUMBER IS
GOING TO BE SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND PLUS FOR SOME
UNITS. WHICH I HAVE TO SAY I
THINK IS ABSOLUTELY OUTRAGEOUS
IT'S A LITTLE BIT LESS WHEN YOU
LOOK AT IT AND COST PER BED IT'S
ABOUT. FOUR HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT
THOUSAND JUST SHY OF FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND PER BAD BUT THAT'S
STILL VERY HIGH. SO WHAT'S THE
PROBLEM FIRST OF ALL TOO MUCH
FUNDING COMPLEXITY ON AVERAGE WE
FOUND. THAT OF FOR PROJECTS THAT
WE'VE APPROVED FOR TRIPLE H.
THERE ARE SEVEN FUNDING SOURCES
IMAGINE PIECING TOGETHER SEVEN
DIFFERENT FUNDING SOURCES IT
TAKES YEARS IT TAKES A LOT OF
CARRYING COSTS. A CHALLENGING
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK- BECAUSE
THERE ARE ALL OF THESE SUBSIDIES
INVOLVED WE FOUND THAT MANY
PROJECTS HAD AN UNUSUALLY HIGH
PERCENTAGE OF SOFT COSTS
ANYWHERE BETWEEN. THIRTY FIVE
AND 40% SOFT COST IN SOME CASES.
OFTEN IT'S OF THE LAND USE
CONSULTANTS THE LOBBYIST THE
ATTORNEYS OF THE- OF COURSE COST
OF CARING FOR YEARS AND YEARS.
AND COST OF CONTINUE TO RISE WE
KNOW THAT BECAUSE OF
CONSTRUCTION OF MATERIALS HAVE
INCREASED SIGNIFICANTLY SO THE
LONGER IT TAKES THE MORE
EXPENSIVE IT GOES. WE ALSO FOUND
THAT THERE WAS A LIMITED POOL OF
ELIGIBLE DEVELOPERS BECAUSE
TRIPLE H. REGULATIONS. ARE
REQUIRED TO LEAD DEVELOPERS TO
DEMONSTRATE A HISTORY OF
BUILDING AND MANAGING SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING PROJECTS BUT THERE WAS
NOT A BIG POOL OF THOSE
AVAILABLE. AND OF COURSE LABOR
COMES INTO IT AS WELL. I BELIEVE
THAT WE HAVE TO FIND WAYS TO GET
FASTER CHEAPER PROJECTS AND
PEOPLE OFF THE STREET MORE.
QUICKLY YOU LOOK AT A PROJECT
HOME TO YOU LOOK AT PROJECT ROOM
KEY LOOK AT SAFE SLEEPING
VILLAGES SAFE PARKING. AND THESE
ARE IN PERFECT BUT THERE ARE
WAYS TO SAVE LIVES TODAY. AND
ALSO WAYS TO REALLY MAKE THE
WHOLE PROCESS OF TAX CREDITS
MUCH MORE QUICK AND MUCH MORE
EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT. WITH
BEING MORE NIMBLE WITH MORE
COLLABORATION BETWEEN THE CITY
AND THE COUNTY IN THE STATE AND
QUITE FRANKLY MORE COMMON SENSE
AND I AM DEEPLY GRATEFUL. FOR
YOUR TIME AND FOR THE TIME OF
THOSE WHO I SHARE THIS TABLE
WITH AND FOR ALL OF YOUR HARD
WORK. ON BEHALF OF THOSE WHO ARE
ARE ON THE HOUSE. SISTERS AND
BROTHERS THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH HONEST
FEDERAL FIFTY IF YOU'D BEGIN AND
ALSO- WELFARE TITLE THE EXACT OF
DIRECTOR FOR THE L. A. COUNTY-
HOMELESS INITIATIVE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE TODAY
WE REALLY GREATLY APPRECIATED
AND I GOT A COUPLE A FEW EXTRA
MINUTES- I TIME IT JUST THE-
ONLY THE INTEREST OF TIME OF ALL
THE SPEAKERS. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ABSOLUTELY AND THANK YOU AND
GOOD MORNING- I'M SORRY TODOROV.
I AM BE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE L. A. COUNTY HOMELESS
INITIATIVE AND FOR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. I THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME HERE TODAY THANK YOU TO
DOWNTOWN WOMEN'S CENTER FOR
HOSTING AND FOR THE AMAZING WORK
THAT YOU DO EVERY DAY. TO LIFT
WOMEN OUT OF HOMELESSNESS. I'M
I'M GONNA BEGIN BY TALKING JUST
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE CURRENT
STATE OF HOMELESSNESS IN L. A.
COUNTY WE'VE HEARD ABOUT THAT SO
I'LL MOVE QUICKLY THROUGH THAT-
AT OUR LAST- HOMELESS COUNT WE
HAD OVER SIXTY SIX THOUSAND
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
IN OUR- COUNTY. OVER 70% OF
THOSE RUN SHELTER. AND THIS
NUMBER WAS UP FROM TWENTY
NINETEEN AND AS ALREADY BEEN
SAID WE EXPECT THAT
UNFORTUNATELY WILL SEE THAT-
WILL CONTINUE- TREND AS WE DO
OUR COUNT IN TWENTY TWENTY TO.
BE ACCELERATING GAP BETWEEN
SKYROCKETING SKYROCKETING
HOUSING COSTS A LACK OF INCOME
GROWTH. IS THE PRIMARY DRIVER.
OF OUR HOMELESS AND HOUSING
CRISIS. IN TWENTY NINETEEN L. A.
COUNTY OR OVER ONE POINT EIGHT
MILLION RENTER HOUSEHOLDS. THAT
IS HIGHER THAN THE NUMBER OF
OWNER HOUSEHOLDS WHICH IS ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION. ALMOST FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND OR HALF A
MILLION OF THOSE LOWEST INCOME
RENTER HOUSEHOLDS PAY OVER 50%
OF THE HOUSEHOLD INCOME ON RENT.
A UNITS CONSIDERED AFFORDABLE OF
A RENT EQUALS NO MORE THAN 30%
OF HOUSEHOLD INCOME. WHAT THAT
MEANS IN OUR CITY HAS THAT A
WORKER NEEDS TO EARN ALMOST
FORTY DOLLARS PER HOUR OR MORE
THAN TWO AND A HALF TIMES THE
MINIMUM WAGE. TO FOR THE AVERAGE
MONTHLY RENT OF TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS- OVER THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS- IN THE COUNTY RENTS HAVE
INCREASED 454% AND INCOMES HAVE
INCREASED 16% SO IN ADDITION TO
THE SIXTY SIX THOUSAND PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS EVERY
DAY WE HAVE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF ADDITIONAL
HOUSEHOLD ONE PAYCHECK ONE RENT
BOB ONE ILLNESS ONE CAR REPAIR
AWAY FROM NOT BEING ABLE TO MAKE
FRIENDS. THIS CRISIS IS GROWING
AT THE SAME TIME WE HAVE MADE
MAJOR INVESTMENTS IN OUR
HOMELESS SERVICES SYSTEM AND WE
ARE WE HOUSING MORE PEOPLE THAN
EVER. IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN COUNTY
VOTERS APPROVED MEASURE H. WHICH
IS A QUARTER CENT SALES TAX TO
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES FOR PEOPLE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. FEFE THAN SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE HAV BEEN
PLACED IN PERMANENT HOUSING IN
OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND IMPACTS
SERVED AND SHELTERS. IN TWENTY
TWENTY ALONE OVER TWENTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE WERE PLACED IN
PERMANENT HOUSING. TODAY L. A.
COUNTY HAS AROUND THIRTY
THOUSAND SHELTER BEDS. AND
THIRTY THREE THOUSAND PERMANENT
HOUSING OPTIONS WE HAVE MADE D.
INVESTMENTS AND SHELTER THE
NUMBER OF SHELTER BEDS HAVE
INCREASED ALMOST 60% OVER THE
LAST THREE YEARS. WE HAVE ALMOST
THIRTEEN THOUSAND PERMANENT
HOUSING UNITS THAT ARE IN
DEVELOPMENT AND AT LAKE COUNTY.
AND WE WANT TO SEE THEM
DEVELOPING QUICKER ABSOLUTELY.
I'M FEDERAL RENTAL SUBSIDIES ARE
ESSENTIAL TO OUR WE HOUSING
EFFORTS ONE TYPE OF FEDERAL
SUBSIDY PROJECT BASED VOUCHERS
SUPPORT THE DEVELOPMENT OF
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
WHICH IS HOUSING FOR PEOPLE
EXPECTING HOMELESSNESS
THROUGHOUT THE MOST COMPLEX
HEALTH AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS. THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY DEVELOPMENT AUTHORITY OR
L. A. CDA HAS OVER FOURTEEN
HUNDRED PROJECT BASED VOUCHER
UNITS WITH ANOTHER FORTY ONE
UNITS A PART OF ME FELT HIS
COMMITTED TO HOUSING PROJECTS
THAT ARE IN THE DEVELOPMENT
PIPELINE. L. A. C. D. A.
ADMINISTERS OVER TWENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND TENANT BASED VOUCHERS
THAT ALLOW CLIENTS TO LEASE
UNITS THE PRIVATE RENTAL MARKET
. WHILE FEDERAL RENTAL SUBSIDIES
ARE ESSENTIAL TO LIFT THE PEOPLE
OUT OF HOMELESSNESS WE HAVE NO
WHERE NEAR THE AMOUNT THAT WE
NEED TO MEET THE NEED. SO
NATIONALLY ABOUT ONE IN FOUR
PEOPLE WHO QUALIFY FOR FEDERAL
HOUSING ASSISTANCE RECEIVE A
VOUCHER. ANY FEARS EVEN MORE
DESPERATE AS HE WITH ONE INTENT
COUNTY RESIDENTS ACTION WHO
QUALIFY ACTUALLY GET VOUCHERS.
ANOTHER TALENTED THAT HAD ONLY
ALLOWS UP 230% OF SECTION EIGHT
VOUCHERS TO BE USED FOR PROJECT
BASED HOUSING AND WE ARE NEARING
OUR CAP. THIS IS GREATLY
IMPACTING OUR ABILITY TO SUPPORT
NEW HOUSING DEVELOPMENT. AND A
VERY CONCRETE EXAMPLE OF THIS
ACTUALLY HAVE TO DO WITH THE
HOME KEY PROGRAM WELL ONE OF THE
LIMITING FACTORS WITH BEING ABLE
TO. ACQUIRE MORE HOME FOR UNITS
OF WITH THE WITH THE STATE'S
SUPPORT FOR THAT ACQUISITION
RENOVATION. IS THAT WE DON'T
HAVE THE PROJECT BASED VOUCHERS
TO PUT INTO THOSE PROJECTS SO
THAT THEY HAVE LONG TIME
OPERATING COSTS. SO I'M GONNA
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE- THE
MOST RECENT STATE INVESTMENTS
I'M- IN THE STATE IN AN L. A.
COUNTY. SO AS WE KNOW IN OVER
THE NEXT TWO FISCAL YEARS THE
STATE'S GOING TO BE ALLOCATING-
SEVEN POINT SEVEN BILLION
STATEWIDE DIRECTLY TO
HOMELESSNESS RELATED FUNDING.
WHICH INCLUDES TWENTY NINE
DIFFERENT ALLOCATIONS
ADMINISTERED ACROSS TEN
DIFFERENT STATE DEPARTMENTS.
THIS INCLUDES FUNDING FOR I'M
HAPPY FOR THE HOMELESS HOUSING-ASSISTANCE AND PREVENTION
PROGRAM HOME KEY ROOM KEY. CAL
WORKS HOUSING H. TAPPED HOME
SAFE IN A NUMBER OF OTHER
INITIATIVES. AND THE L. A.
COUNTY REGION IS ESTIMATED TO
RECEIVE ABOUT ONE POINT FOUR
FIVE BILLION OF THOSE DOLLARS
OVER THE NEXT TWO FISCAL YEARS.
WITH THE LARGEST INVESTMENTS
BEING AND THE HALF PROGRAM. HOME
KEY. AND H. DOT. THIS THIS STATE
FUNDING IS ALLOWING US TO
CONTINUE SERVING SOME OF THE
MOST VULNERABLE PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. I'M
TO OUR PROJECT ROOM KEY- PROGRAM
WITH EXTENSION ABOUT FUNDING
THROUGH THE HOME FEE PROGRAM
WHERE THE COUNTY WE ACQUIRED
EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS IN
ROUND ONE. AND HOPE TO ACQUIRE
ANOTHER THOUSAND IN ROUND TWO.
AND WE'RE ALREADY LAUNCHING
VITAL PROGRAMS WITH A HALF THREE
FUNDING INCLUDING PARTNERING
WITH CITIES ACROSS THE COUNTY TO
OPEN MORE SHELTERS. AND ACTUALLY
A PARTNERSHIP- RIGHT HERE WITH
DOWNTOWN WOMEN'S CENTER- TO HELP
END HOMELESSNESS FOR WOMEN IN
SKID ROW. AND THAT IS DONE IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH MANY OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING THE CITY
. EVEN WITH THE STATE AND
FEDERAL INVESTMENTS THERE IS SO
MUCH MORE THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE.
WE NEED MORE FEDERAL SUBSIDIES
AS PREVIOUSLY STATED ONLY ONE IN
FOUR ELIGIBLE PEOPLE GET THEM
THAT NUMBER'S EVEN LESS HERE IN
LA COUNTY. WE NEED MORE VOUCHERS
AND WE NEED TO HAVE LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS HAVE THE
FLEXIBILITY TO USE THOSE
VOUCHERS TO BEST MEET THEIR
LOCAL NEEDS. WHICH WOULD MEAN
INCREASING OR ELIMINATING THE
CAP ON PROJECT BASED VOUCHERS.
WE NEED ONGOING IN LARGE AND-
LARGER- FUNDING COMMITMENTS-
FROM THE STATE THE STATE WIDE
ONE BILLION FLEXIBLE FUNDING
THROUGH. HAPPY IS A GAME CHANGER
OVER THE NEXT TWO YEARS. IT WILL
BE EXTREMELY IMPACTFUL. IT HAS
THE FLEXIBILITY TO ALLOW LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO DO WHAT THEY
NEED BUT AWFUL ALSO THE
OVERSIGHT AND OUTCOMES- THAT ARE
EXPECTED- WITH. EXCUSE ME I'M-
SO THE CHALLENGE WITH THAT IS AT
THIS POINT THEIR SHORT TERM
INVESTMENTS RIGHT THERE ONE TIME
WE DON'T HAVE THE SUSTAINABLE
FUNDING AND WITHOUT SUSTAINABLE
FUNDING IT'S REALLY DIFFICULT TO
MAKE PERMANENT INVESTMENTS. IT'S
REALLY DIFFICULT FOR HOMELESS
SERVICES PROVIDERS WHO DON'T
HAVE CONTINUITY OF FUNDING TO
REALLY BUILD STRONG PROGRAM TO
MAINTAIN THEM OVER TIME WITH ALL
OF THE SPENDING SWINGS. I'M AND
THEN WE NEED MORE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING- WE HAVE A SHORTFALL OF
OVER FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
AFFORDABLE UNITS IN L. A. COUNTY
AS A RESULT EVEN PEOPLE WHO HAVE
RENTAL SUBSIDIES TO HAVE A PAY
TO PAY TO HAVE A WAY TO PAY THE
RENT TO HELP ON THOSE FEDERAL
SUBSIDIES. THEY CAN WAIT SIX
MONTHS TWELVE MONTHS OR EVEN
LONGER TO FIND A UNIT AND ALLOW
LOCAL RENT TO THEM. SO SOME
PEOPLE ACTUALLY WITH THOSE
FEDERAL SUBSIDIES THEY HAVE AT
THEIR EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
THEY HAVE A WAY TO PAY THE RENT.
THEY'RE ACTUALLY NOT ABLE TO
LEASE UP- THAT IS THAT IS LIKE
THAT'S THE ULTIMATE SORT OF
TRAGEDY IN THE SITUATION. I'M I
THINK YOU KNOW WITH THAT- IN
CONSIDERATION OF THE TIME- I'M
GONNA GO AHEAD AND STOP AND TURN
IT OVER K. AND I JUST WANT TO
THANK THE CHAIR AND EVERYBODY
HERE FOR CONVENING THIS HEARING.
FOR GIVING US HIS OPPORTUNITY-
AND TO BE ABLE TO COME TOGETHER
IN PARTNERSHIP TO TALK ABOUT HOW
TO SOLVE THIS CRISIS THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK AND I
APPRECIATE YOU BEING VERY HONEST
ABOUT THE STATE. CONSISTENT
FUNDING BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WE-
WERE HERE TO HAVE AN HONEST
CONVERSATION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR WORK. IT'S CONTROL
THANK YOU AND I KNOW- MISSILE IN
YOUR CURRENT ROLE IN YOUR
PREVIOUS ROLES YOU WERE VERY
HARD WITH US TO DO. A NUMBER OF
BIG PROJECTS. LIKE GETTING- SIX
STREAMLINED FOR PERMITS FOUR
THOUSAND MERGING SHELTERS. AS
DID- MISTER HERTZBERG AND
EVERYBODY HERE- LET THE TELL THE
STORY COMPLAIN TEMPLE TOLD THAT
LATER. BUT I THINK ARE MUCH IS
ALSO GOING TO. THE VERY MUCH
THANK EVERYBODY FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY HERE UNFORTUNATELY I
HAVE A ANOTHER COMMITMENT THAT I
HAVE TO BE A- YOU'RE NOT STAYING
TO HEAR ME READ BUT- EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF YOUR PLACE. AN
HONEST CONVERSATION. I AM HAPPY
TO HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH YOU
ABOUT THAT I AM SURE YOU.
PERHAPS ON SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE
SOMETIME. MITCHELL PLEASE YOUR
YOU KIND OF KNEW THE POSITION SO
ALL YEARS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND GOOD MORNING I DON'T MEMBERS
I AM ANSWERABLE THE GENERAL
MANAGER OF THE LOS ANGELES
HOUSING DEPARTMENT WE'RE
RESPONSIBLE FOR FINANCING OF THE
SUBSIDIZED AFFORDABLE HOUSING
INCLUDING PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING AND MANAGING A PORTFOLIO
OF OVER FORTY SEVEN THOUSAND
AFFORDABLE UNITS- AND OVERSEEING
THE RENT STABILIZATION PROGRAM
EVICTION DEFENSE PROGRAM AND
CODE ENFORCEMENT FOR ALMOST
FAMILY HOUSING IN THE CITY. WE
COORDINATE WITH THE CITY
ADMINISTRATOR'S OFFICE TO WHO
LEADS ON- FUNDING INTERIM
HOUSING AND SHELTERS AND WITH
THE MAYOR'S OFFICE ON ST
STRATEGIES AND I'M GOING TO TALK
ABOUT THE WORK WE'VE DONE IN ALL
THOSE AREAS- AND I THINK IF I IF
I HAVE AN OVERALL THEME IT'S
ADDRESSING THE CHAIR'S COMMENT
THAT- TRENDING OAKS THAT. IT'S
CRAZY TO KEEP DOING THE SAME
THING OVER AND OVER AND
EXPECTING DIFFERENT RESULT AND I
GUESS MY QUESTION WOULD BE THAT
WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT WHAT IS
THE SAME THING IS THAT THE WAY
THAT WE'VE BEEN DOING. IN A ROOM
IN SUPPORT OF HOUSING OR IS IT
THE CONSISTENT UNDERFUNDING
PIECEMEAL FUNDING AND LACK OF
REALISM ABOUT WHAT WE ACTUALLY
NEED TO PUT INTO THIS SO I'M
GOING TO. BUILD YEAH SURE AND I
DID NOT COORDINATE THIS TOGETHER
BUT I'M GOING TO HIT ON THOSE
THINGS. SO I WANT TO START WITH
A QUICK OVERVIEW OF WHAT WE HAVE
DONE IN THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS
AND THE AND THE ROLE OF THE
STATE INVESTMENTS IN THAT IN THE
CITY. AND THEN LOOK AT WHAT
STILL NEEDS TO BE DONE TO
PROVIDE HOUSING FOR ALL INJURY
KNOWS AND CONSIDER THE
CONSTRUCTION AND OPERATING COSTS
OF VARIOUS MODELS. SO AS AS SHE
MENTIONED IN THE CITY OF LA YOU
KNOW THE VICTIMS AND THEN THIS
IS A FALSE. HOMELESS PEOPLE DO
NOT STAY IN ONE NEIGHBORHOOD YOU
KNOW ONE CITY BUT THE CITY HAS
FORTY ONE THOUSAND HOMELESS
PEOPLE IN THE LAST POINT IN TIME
COUNT. AND TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND
OF THOSE PEOPLE ALMOST TWENTY
NINE WERE AND SHELTERED. 64%
WERE INDIVIDUALS 20% WERE
FAMILIES 9% WERE SENIORS AND 7%
REVIEWS. IN THE PAST THREE YEARS
THE CITY HAS OPENED TEN THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED SHELTER BEDS AND
FACILITIES RANGING FROM PROJECT
ROOM KEY. AND PROJECT HOME CHEMO
. TWENTY SEVEN CONGREGATE SITES
WITH TWO THOUSAND BEDS IN OUR
BRIDGE HOME PROGRAM. TWO
THOUSAND BEDS IN TINY HOME
VILLAGES AND SAFE PARKING AND
SAFE SLEEP SLEEPING SITES THAT
PROVIDE. CHANCE ACCESS TO MEALS
HYGIENE A CASE MANAGEMENT
SERVICES. AS WELL AS TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED RAPID RE HOUSING OR
SHARED HOUSING VOUCHERS TO- TO
LANDLORDS IN NONPROFIT SUCH AS
DOWNTOWN WOMEN'S CENTER
ALTHOUGH. AS WAS MENTIONED THAT
THE LACK OF HOUSING SUPPLY MEANS
THAT ONLY 30% OF THE VOUCHERS
THE REGULAR- TENANT CHOICE
VOUCHERS OR RAPID RE HOUSING
VOUCHERS ARE BEING DEPLOYED AT
ANY ONE TIME WE REALLY. NEED TO
ADDRESS OUR SUPPLY ISSUES. THE
CAPITAL. COST PER BED FOR
SHELTERS RANGE FROM TWO HUNDRED
AND TO. TWENTY THREE. TO
PURCHASE A MOTEL ROOM. TO TWENTY
FOUR THOUSAND FOR CONGREGATE
SHELTER TO NOTHING FOR RENTED
APARTMENTS. THE AVERAGE CAPITAL
COSTS WAS ABOUT THIRTY SEVEN
THOUSAND. THE MOST EXPENSIVE
BEDS TEND TO BE THE MOST
EFFECTIVE BEDS. YOU CAN GET
CONCRETE SHELTERS THAT ARE NOT
FULL BUT THINGS LIKE ROJECT
ROOM KEY WHERE PEOPLE HAVE. THE
ABILITY TO HAVE THEIR OWN THINGS
IN THEIR PARTNERS AND THEIR PETS
AND- YOU KNOW. BATHROOM IN A
LOCKED DOOR ARE ARE FULL AND
PEOPLE ARE NOT- LEAVING UNTIL
THEY HAVE A HOUSING PLAN UNLIKE
SOME OF THE- THE LESS- WITH THE
SUPPORTED SHELTERS. THE MOST
EXPENSIVE BEDS- LIKE PROJECT
HOME KEEPER PURCHASED IN THE
LAST FOR AT LEAST FIFTEEN YEARS
OR BE CONVERTED TO PERMANENT
HOUSING. AND THE LEAST EXPENSIVE
PROFIT ON SITES LEAST FROM
PUBLIC AGENCIES FOR THREE TO
FIVE YEARS. IN TOTAL THE CITY
AND OUR PARTNERS HAVE INVESTED
THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN
MILLION IN THE PRODUCTION OF
THESE TEN THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
BEDS. WHAT WE REALLY NEED TO BE
PAID ATTENTION TO AN INTERIM
SHELTERS ARE REALLY AND ALL
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS OPERATING
COSTS IF YOU CAN'T OPERATE IT
THERE'S NO POINT IN BUILDING IT.
AND THE INTERIM HOUSING
OPERATING COSTS TEND TO AVERAGE
ABOUT NINETY DOLLARS PER BED PER
NIGHT. BECAUSE YOU NEED MEALS ON
SITE STAFF SECURITY MAINTENANCE
HELP FROM CASE MANAGERS.
PERMANENT HOUSING PEOPLE PAY
RENT OR THEY HAVE THE RENT
VOUCHERS AND THERE IS NO
ADDITIONAL OPERATING COSTS THAT
WE HAVE TO KEEP INVESTING. IN
THERE SO THE OPERATING COST PER
BED PER NIGHT WORKS OUT TO ABOUT
THIRTY TWO THOUSAND PER BED FOR
YEAR. HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
THOUSAND OVER A FIVE YEAR TERM-
OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS. WE'VE
SPENT. THE M. EIGHT HUNDRED AND
FIFTY NINE FIVE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SEVEN AND FIFTY NINE
MILLION FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND. ON THE
PRODUCTION OF THESE BEDS AND 33%
HAS COME FROM THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA PRIMARILY FROM THAT.
THEY KEEP THE HELP AND THE
PROJECT HOME HE PROGRAMS ARE THE
FUNDING SOURCES OF INCLUDED THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S IMMER
EMERGENCY SHELTER GRANT AND CO
GOOD PROGRAMS AS WELL AS CITY
GENERAL FUNDS. WE KNOW THAT
INTERIM HOUSING IS REALLY
IMPORTANT WE KNOW THAT WE NEED
TO RAMP THAT UP AND IT IS
CRUCIAL BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT
WITHOUT PERMANENT HOUSING AT THE
OTHER END INTERIM HOUSING IS A
FALSE HOPE. SO SINCE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WE HAVE FUNDED EIGHTY
FOUR HHH SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
PROJECTS WITH FIVE THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED UNITS. SEVENTEEN OF THEM
A HUNDRED WITH IT WITH A
THOUSAND FORTY WHEN UNITS ARE
COMPLETED. ANOTHER SIXTY SEVEN
WITH FOUR THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
UNITS ARE IN CONSTRUCTION. THE
KEY TAKEAWAY ABOUT HHH IS THAT
WE STARTED OUT THE VOTERS
APPROVED. ENOUGH MONEY TO DO
SEVEN THOUSAND UNITS TO
SUPPLEMENT THE CITY'S THREE
THOUSAND UNITS. RIGHT NOW WITH
HHH WE HAVE A PIPELINE OF EIGHT
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY
FIVE UNITS. AT A SUBSIDY THAT'S
FIFTEEN THOUSAND A UNIT LESS
THAN WE PROJECTED IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN. AND WE WILL BE DONE
WITH IT TWO YEARS EARLIER THAN
THE TEN YEARS WE PLANNED. SO
EIGHT THOUSAND UNITS FIFTEEN
THOUSAND UNIT LESS. TWO YEARS
EARLIER IT IS TRUE THAT IT TOOK
AWHILE TO GET THE FLY WHEEL
GOING AND TO YOU KNOW START THAT
PRODUCTION PROCESS. BUT THANKS
TO THINGS LIKE AB ELEVEN NINETY
SEVEN THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO. AUTHORED A COUPLE
YEARS AGO WITH A SEQUEL
EXEMPTION FOR ALL AND EIGHTY
TAKES PROJECTS FOR. OTHER PEOPLE
AND MISTER HERTZBERG AND OTHERS.
YOU KNOW WE ARE SEEING NOT ONLY
COSTS GO DOWN BECAUSE DEVELOPERS
DON'T FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE TO DO
THINGS TO SATISFY PEOPLE WHO
MIGHT FILE A SECRET LAWSUIT SO
THEY'RE NOT. PUTTING IN A NEEDED
PARKING AND THINGS LIKE THAT BUT
WE'RE ALSO JUST SEEING THINGS GO
MUCH FASTER. THE MAYOR AND THE
AND THE CITY DEPARTMENTS OF ALSO
WORKED VERY HARD ON STREAMLINING
AND WE HAVE REDUCE THE CUT THE
TIMELINE TO GET PERMITS FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECTS. BY
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY DAYS- AS
PART OF THAT WORK. WE'VE ALSO-
THE YOU KNOW THAT NO PLACE LIKE
HOME DOLLARS THAT WERE CREATED
YOU KNOW AND FROM THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT AND RATIFIED
BY THE VOTERS IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
WITH THE LEADERSHIP OF THEN
SENATOR DALY- WHICH IS PUT IN
NINETY EIGHT THOUSAND PER UNIT
FOR THREE THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
UNITS IN OUR PIPELINE SO FAR.
WE'VE ALREADY MENTIONED THE
MAJOR PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
PROJECT HOME KEEP PROGRAM WHICH
WAS REALLY GREAT LAST YEAR ONE
OF THE THINGS IT DID WAS IT PUT
IN ONLY TWO SOURCES OF FUNDING
AND THEY BOTH CAME TO THE CITY
THERE WAS MONEY FROM THE STATE
AND THEN WE HAD OUR OWN
CORONAVIRUS MONEY SO PEOPLE DID
NOT HAVE TO DO THE LEVERAGE
FINANCING THE CITY WAS ABLE TO
PURCHASE SIXTEEN HUNDRED UNITS-
WITH A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT FROM
THE STATE. AND M. FUNDS FROM US
IN THE NEXT ROUND WE ARE HOPING
TO INVEST- OUR OWN HHH MONEY
HOME AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN MANY
IN OTHER CITY FUNDS TO SECURE
ENOUGH OF A STATE MATCH TO DO
FOURTEEN HUNDRED UNITS AS WAS
ALREADY MENTIONED THE REAL
LIMITING FACTOR THESE DAYS IS
OPERATING MONEY AND WE'RE HOPING
THAT BUILD BACK BETTER PASSES
WITH A LOT MORE VOUCHERS.
OTHERWISE WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
START GETTING REALLY CREATIVE IN
HOW WE MEET THAT OPERATING MANY-
I. SENSE FROM MIGUEL THAT I'M
RUNNING OUT OF TIME- I BASICALLY
SPENT SOMETIME YESTERDAY
TINKERING WITH WE KNOW ALL THESE
COSTS WE KNOW THAT WE HAVE AT
LEAST EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
UNSHELTERED HOMELESS PEOPLE ON
THE STREET. IT'S YOU KNOW I FOR
SIX YEARS I'M NOT ON THE FEDERAL
RESERVE BOARD AND LOS ANGELES
AND JANET YELLEN WAS THE
PRESIDENT AND JANET'S FAVORITE
SAYING WAS LET'S BE DATA DRIVEN
ABOUT THIS SO LET'S BE DATA
DRIVEN LET'S THINK ABOUT. YOU
KNOW WHAT WOULD IT TAKE TO
REALLY. ACTUALLY ADDRESS
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED UNITS OF
INTERIM HOUSING AND THEN THE
PAYMENT HOUSING TO GO WITH IT.
THE CAPITAL COSTS WOULD BE SIX
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY THREE MILLION
TO DO. EIGHTEEN HUNDRED BEDS OF
INTERIM HOUSING AND WE WOULD
NEED ONE POINT THREE BILLION
DOLLARS EVERY YEAR TO OPERATE
IT. I THINK THAT WOULD BE AN
INVESTMENT WORTH MAKING BUT AT
THE SAME TIME WE WOULD NEED TO
DO SUPPORT OF HOUSING. SO THAT
PEOPLE COULD NOT STAND IN A ROOM
FOR EVER WE DON'T WANT TO BE NEW
YORK TWENTY YEARS FROM NOW JUST
PAYING INTERIM HOUSING OVER AND
OVER AGAIN. WE NEED TO MOVE
PEOPLE INTO PERMANENT HOUSING
AND SHOULD DO. ANOTHER EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED UNITS WE'D NEED TWO
POINT FIVE BILLION FROM THE CITY
AND TWO POINT TWO BILLION FROM
THE STATE AS WELL AS SUPPORT
FROM. OUR FEDERAL AND STATE TAX
CREDITS. SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU TO FIND THAT
MONEY AND- AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU
BECAUSE I'M CHAIR AND I'M
RESPONSIBLE FOR US BEING LATE I
HAVE BEEN ON THE TABLE MY
QUESTIONS IF I. SO IF ANY
MEMBERS HERE HAVE QUESTIONS- AND
I'M JUST GONNA MOVE A LITTLE
BRIEF BECAUSE I WANT TO
APOLOGIZE THE NEXT BECAUSE
BECAUSE WE STARTED A LITTLE BIT
LATE- DUE TO. RAIN AND- GET ALL
SET UP OUTSIDE FIVE PAUL GEORGE
PROFUSELY THE METHOD SPEAKERS.
ON THE BILL. HI SO I USED TO BE
THE OF PLANNING DEPUTY FOR
CAREER NO USED TO DO AS THEY
HAVE HOUSING DEPARTMENT HOUSING
AUTHORITY CRLA LOOKS YOU
REMEMBER CRLA- SO WHAT WE DID
WAS WE CREATED WHAT'S CALLED A
CASE MANAGEMENT SYSTEM WHERE WE
GOT EVERYBODY IN A ROOM PLANNING
BUILDING SAFETY PUBLIC WORK
BECAUSE THERE WILL ALWAYS BE A
BOTTLENECK GOVERNMENT WORKS IN
SILOS AS I LISTEN TO EACH OF
YOU. YOU'RE WORKING IN SILOS
ONCE WE GOT THEM TO WORK
TOGETHER GOT THEM ALL IN A ROOM
TO BE ABLE TO WORK THROUGH THESE
PROBLEMS- WE WERE ABLE TO GET
THINGS DONE IF YOU LOOK AT
DOWNTOWN LA THAT WAS BASED ON
CASE MANAGEMENT WORKING
TOGETHER. I'M HEARING THAT WE
PROBABLY NEED THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT REPRESENTATIVE HERE
FOR ADDITIONAL THINGS AND SO IT
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE. EVERYONE'S
WORKING TO GATHER IS LIKE YOUR
PERFECT IN YOUR SILO BUT THERE
IS NO CROSS POLLINATION SO YOU
YOU MAY BE REALLY GOOD AT
BUILDING HOUSING BUT THE
PROGRAMMING IS ON A SEPARATE
TRACK IN IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE
IT'S CONNECTING SO- AT SOME
POINT WHEN WILL WE ALL IN THE
STATE WHATEVER YOU WANT FROM US
WE ALL NEED TO BE IN THE SAME
ROOM AT THE SAME TIME DO WE HAVE
THAT MECHANISM WILL WE HAVE THAT
MECHANISM IS THIS SOME HAS
ALREADY BEEN DONE. OR DOES NEED
TO BE A LOT MORE EFFECTIVE. IT'S
ALWAYS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
IMPROVEMENT WITH THE ONE OF THE
WAYS WE SHORTEN THE PROCESSING.
IT IS CASE MANAGEMENT YOU KNOW
THE HUNDRED FIFTY DAYS. BUT YOU
KNOW AGAIN IF I HAD MY DRUTHERS
RATHER THAN THE STATE HELPING
ONE APPLICATION FOR ALL ITS
HOUSING PROGRAMS. IT WOULD JUST
DEFAULT ALL OF LA CITY AND ONLY
COUNTY'S MONEY TO THE CITY AND
COUNTY AS WE'RE DOING WITH HOME
KEY. SO THAT WE COULD JUST HAVE
ONE SOURCE OF FUNDING INSTEAD
OF. OUR DEVELOPERS HAVING TO
LOOK BACK AND FORTH SO. YEAH
THERE IS NOT TO GIVE YOU A HARD
TIME. WE'VE WE'VE DONE THAT AND
IT HASN'T MOVED IN SO THAT'S I'M
NOT GIVING YOU A HARD TIME BUT-
AS A SOMEBODY WALKS OUT OF YOUR
HOME. THEY STILL SEE THE SAME
HOMELESS PERSON SITTING.
ENCAMPED FROM THEIR HOUSE.
PEOPLE WANT TO SEE SOMETHING.
HAPPEN VISUALLY MOVE SO- I DON'T
THINK I'M NOT TWENTY HIGH TECH
IS YOU CAN YOU CAN MARINADE ON
THIS AND GET BACK TO ME BUT AT
SOME POINT. VISUALLY WE'VE GOT
TO MAKE SOMETHING HAPPEN. AND
I'M GONNA HEAD OVER TO MISTER
HERTZBERG ABOUT RUSHING US IS
ONLY TRY TO GET BACK ON TRACK SO
I APOLOGIZE ABOUT THAT. MISTER
HERTZBERG. WHY IS THE CITY
COMPTROLLER WRONG IN THE
ANALYSIS WOULD BE PROVIDED TO
US. BECAUSE IT'S PRETTY PAINFUL.
THAT'S A LONGER DISCUSSION AND
WE PROBABLY HAVE TRIED SAYING
THAT HE'S WRONG. I'M SAYING THAT
TALKING ABOUT THE COST OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND NOT
TALKING ABOUT THE OVERALL COST
OF HOUSING. AS THOUGH AFFORDABLE
HOUSING RIGHT OUTLIER IS- NOT
PRESENTING ALL THE FACTS- AND I
ALSO SAYING THE WORD HE'S NOT
NECESSARILY- FOCUS ON SORT OF
THE TREND OF SPEED WE DOUBT. WE
ARE LITERALLY CLOSING HHH
PROJECT EVERY TEN DAYS IN THE
DEPARTMENT WE HAVE A HUGE
PIPELINE IN THE PROCESS AND IN
EIGHTEEN MONTHS THEY WILL BE
COMING ONLINE EVERY TEN DAYS
BECAUSE THAT'S THE WAY IT WORKS
IT JUST TAKES AWHILE TO GET.
THINGS GOING SECOND LAST IF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA- CRAIG
LEGISLATION. THAT GAVE YOU EVERY
NICKEL THAT YOU WANTED. WOULD
YOU THINK IT WOULD BE
APPROPRIATE TO AGREE TO A
PROVISION THAT SAID IF IT WASN'T
SUCCESSFUL YOU HAVE TO PAY IT
BACK. FOR THAT WE WOULD. REMOVE
YOU FROM THAT PROCESS BECAUSE
WHEN YOU GO TO BUY SOMETHING YOU
WANT TO RESULT FINE HERE'S A
CHECK GET IT DONE. WE GIVE A
CHECK IT DOESN'T GET DONE HAS TO
BE CONSEQUENCES ANY THOUGHTS ON
THE- PAY IT BACK FROM WHAT DOES
MANDATE DELIVER TAXPAYERS CITY
LOS ANGELES BAY OR SOMEBODY
BECAUSE THE REST OF THE STATE'S
PICKING UP THE TAB FOR THIS AND
FINE WE'LL GIVE YOU THE MONEY
WE'LL GIVE YOU CONTINUED FLOW
BUT YOU GOTTA GET WORK AND
DOESN'T WORK. WHAT'S THE PURPOSE
. YEAH A FAIR OBSERVATION- I
THINK YOU HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE- YOU KNOW THE LIST THINGS
THAT YOU WERE FUNDING OR
ACTUALLY THE THINGS THAT YOU.
YOU KNOW THAT THAT THERE'S A
POSSIBILITY FOR SUCCESS OTHER
THINGS THAT WE FIND THE THINGS
YOU TELL US TO BE DEFINED IF WE
WANTED OF AUTHORITY TO THE CITY
TO THE COUNTY. OKAY GIVE YOU THE
MONEY YOU TELL US HOW YOU'RE
GONNA DO IT. GO IMPLEMENTED
SOLVE THE PROBLEM DON'T SOLVE
THE PROBLEM PAY IT BACK. AT A
TIME LIKE THANK YOU FOR. IT UP
I'M AT THE- LEGACY OF THAT OUT
FOR. WELL AND PARTIALLY
CONTROLLED. AND THEN MISTER OF
MERCY IN ONLY RUBIO WOULD YOU
GUYS ALLOW ME TO JUST THE NEXT
PANEL AFTER THAT. THANK AYE AND
THEN MISTER BLOOM. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I A ON YOU KNOW- MISSY
WELL YOU YOU YOU YOU TALKED
ABOUT YOU AND YOUR COMMENTS BY
FOCUSING ON THE DATA BUT- I
ALONG WITH CENTER HERTZBERG I
MEAN I. YOU DON'T HAVE IT IT'S
HARD NOT TO FOCUS ON- CONTROL
CONFERENCE- EARLIER COMMENTS I
THINK WHEN VOTERS. VOTED TO
APPROVE MEASURE HHH THEY WERE
NOT THINKING ABOUT YOU KNOW THE
AVERAGE UNIT. OF OF HOUSING TO
BE BUILT TO BE BETWEEN. YOU KNOW
WELL FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS. I KNOW
THAT WAY WHEN I. VISITED OF THE
SOME OF THE THAT THE UNITS THAT
THE IS THAT HAVE BEEN BUILT. I
MEAN I YOU KNOW I. IT WAS BETTER
THAN THE APARTMENT THAT I LIVE
IN IN SACRAMENTO YOU KNOW AND-
AND IN THE MEANTIME THERE ARE
PEOPLE. YOU KNOW FIFTEEN HUNDRED
PEOPLE THAT HAVE DIED HOMELESS.
YOU KNOW THREE TO FOUR PEOPLE A
DAY SO WHEN I SEE THAT I DON'T
SEE IT AND IT TAKES. IT TAKES
FOUR TO SIX YEARS TO BUILD THESE
UNITS. I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY
WE'RE NOW PRIORITISING EVEN MORE
SO. YOU KNOW THE SHELTERS OVER
THE PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
I UNDERSTAND LONG TERM PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING IS NEEDING.
BUT IN THE MEANTIME PEOPLE ARE
DYING AND WE NEED TO SHOW THE
PEOPLE THAT VOTED FOR THE TAX
INCREASE. TO ADDRESS THE
HOMELESS PROBLEM BY PRIORITIZING
SHELTERS. BUT I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT IT MUST BE BOTH BANDS
BECAUSE IT DOES TAKE AWHILE TO
DO HOUSING AT THE END SO WE NEED
TO DO IMMEDIATE INTERIM HOUSING
SHELTERS. AND WE NEED TO ALSO
KEEP A PIPELINE GOING SO THAT
PEOPLE HAVE A PLACE TO MOVE TO.
DATE JUST LAST COMMENT IS IT WE
HAVE LIMIT WILL HAVE LIMITED
RESOURCES IT'S A MATTER
PRIORITIES THANK YOU. AND I'M
GOING TO HAND IT OVER TO MR
BLOOM- THANK YOU- ONE OF BUT-
THE SITUATIONS THAT WE FACE NOW
IS THAT ON A DAILY BASIS MORE
PEOPLE ARE ENTERING HOMELESSNESS
THAN WERE ACTUALLY HOUSING WE'VE
HEARD THAT- OVER THE LAST COUPLE
OF YEARS OVER AND OVER AGAIN-
HERE IN LOS ANGELES. SO WHAT IS
THE ROLE OF PREVENTION KEEPING
PEOPLE IN THEIR EXISTING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SO- THEY
DON'T. END UP ON THE STREET IN
THE FIRST PLACE. THANK YOU FOR
RAISING THAT ACTUALLY PREVENTION
IS ESSENTIAL AS YOU'RE SAYING WE
HAVE MORE PEOPLE FALLING INTO
HOMELESSNESS EACH DAY THAT WE
HAD X. HITTING IT DESPITE ALL OF
THE NEW INVESTMENTS THAT WE HAVE
MADE AND IS CONTINUING GROWTH-
PREVENTION IS VERY COMPLICATED
THERE'S THE PIECE THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT ABOUT KEEPING
PEOPLE IN THE HOUSING THAT
THEY'RE IN RIGHT NOW. WHICH IS
ABSOLUTELY THE MOST ESSENTIAL
THING A SODA SOMEBODY FALLS INTO
HOMELESSNESS THE COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH GETTING HOUSE
BEGAN AND THE LENGTH OF TIME IT
TAKES JUST TO GET AT IT.
SACRAMENTO EXPONENTIALLY MORE
COMPLICATED- AND SO HELPING WITH
YOU KNOW IF EXTEND- PREVENTION
LEGAL DEFENSE OF HELPING- WITH-
PREVENTING FORECLOSURES AMONG
LOW INCOME HOMEOWNERS ALL OF
THOSE ARE EXTREMELY EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT AND THEN THERE'S A
LARGER SORT OF EVEN BACKING UP
FURTHER PREVENTION WHICH I KNOW
WE'RE NOT HERE TO TALK ABOUT
TODAY BUT PREVENTION STARTS WAY
BEFORE THAT IT TALKED ABOUT
ACCESS TO EDUCATION. IT TALKS
ABOUT HOUSING WHEN YOU'RE A
CHILD IT IS ABOUT ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE IS ABOUT ACCESS TO
AFFORDABLE WAGES ALL OF THOSE
THINGS- ARE ARE IMPACTING THE
INFLOW OF PEOPLE INTO
HOMELESSNESS UNTIL WE GO BACK
THAT FAR START ADDRESSING THOSE
THINGS IT'S GONNA. BE VERY HARD
TO STOP THAT FLOW OF PEOPLE.
THANK YOU AND I. THE COMMITTEE
ALLOWING ME TO RUSSIA THROUGH-
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I GOT
A BIG JOB AHEAD OF YOU KNOW WHAT
I WANT TO. REEMPHASIZE THE FACT
THAT WE'RE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER.
AFTER THE TOUGH QUESTIONS YOU
SHOULD BE ASKING THE TOUGH
QUESTIONS ABOUT AS TO- AND I
REALIZE THAT YOU'RE NEW TO
DESIGNING AND STUFF BUT THE
PROGRAMMING. YOU'RE DOING THE
BEST IMPLEMENTED. BUT I THINK
FROM A VOTER PERSPECTIVE- FOR
ANY ANYBODY IN IN PUBLIC BECAUSE
THEY'RE ANYBODY FOR ANYBODY
PUBLIC OFF ANYBODY'S IS WATCHING
THIS. THING I THINK WOW. WHAT A
BOONDOGGLE FOR FIVE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS A UNIT YOU SAID.
THOUSAND DOLLARS UNIT YOU KNOW.
BUT BUT BUT LOOK HAVING HAVING
SAID THAT I KNOW YOU DO THE VERY
BEST JOB AND IF YOU CAN HELP
WITH THAT. TO IF THERE ARE
THINGS THAT THE STATE CAN DO TO
FACILITATE THAT LET US KNOW. YOU
KNOW IN TERMS OF HOW WE WORK
THROUGH THIS LIKE YOU WERE
HOPEFUL TO SEE PROJECTIONS. AND
I EXTREMELY APPRECIATE. YOUR
HARD WORK IN HELPING US TO GET
THAT DONE. THANK YOU I'M GONNA
CALL UP THE NEXT. COMMITTEE BUT
THANK YOU ONE ROUND OF APPLAUSE
. THANK YOU. MUCH THANK YOU
EIGHT I TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR
BEING- SO I'M REALLY SORRY ABOUT
THAT AND I'M RUSHING TO GET US
STARTED ON THE NEXT PANEL WERE
WERE. VERY- WE'RE EXTREMELY
GRATEFUL FOR SUPERVISORS LEASES-
COUNCILMEMBER OF RAMAN AND- MISS
MARTIN TO BE HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT. AND- I THANK YOU FOR
COMING- AND I'M GONNA JUMP RIGHT
IN I DON'T THINK YOU NEED TO-
AND INTERACTIONIST LEASE AT ALL
BECAUSE I THINK- YEAH BECAUSE I
THINK WE ALL KNOW. EXACTLY WHO
YOU ARE AND YOUR HARD WORK AND
ADVOCACY ON THE HOMELESS ISSUE
THEY WERE EXTREMELY GRATEFUL
THAT YOU'RE HERE WITH US TODAY
THANK YOU- THANK YOU. FOR YOUR
I'M JUST I'M JUST KEEPING A
RUNNING TALLY JUST TO TRY TO GET
BACK OKAY I'LL TRY TO BE ON THE
FIVE MINUTE ENOUGH I CAN I DON'T
HAVE TO READ ALL THIS. WHICH IS
GREAT. APPLE KILL ME BUT THAT'S
OKAY AND WHAT WE KNOW HOW THAT
IS. WHAT WE SAID TO THE EARLIER
DAYS IT IS WE WANT TO. THE GOOD
THE BAD AND THE UGLY SO WE'RE
ALL IN THIS TOGETHER WE'RE
STANDING SO THERE'S THINGS THAT
THE STATE HASN'T DONE. YEAH I
MEAN WE NEED TO HEAR THAT RIGHT
I MEAN. THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE.
OKAY I DON'T KNOW I THINK YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT AND I'M VERY.
HONORED TO PLEASE EVEN VIæT ME
TO BE HERE- I'M GLAD. WHAT I'M
HEARING ALREADY IN TERMS OF
DISCUSSION. IS SOME OF WHAT I
WOULD HAVE SAID- BUT I'LL PUT IT
IN A DIFFERENT CONTEXT. BUT I
WANT TO ALSO OFFERS THANK THE-
DOWNTOWN WOMEN'S CENTER. BECAUSE
THEY'VE BEEN TREMENDOUS. IN
HOSTING US FOR SEVERAL EVENTS
WE'VE HAD SOME MAJOR- MEETINGS
HERE BUT- THE FACT THAT- AS YOU
WALK INTO THIS- PROJECT YOU SEE.
OUTSIDE THAT THERE ARE MANY-
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE LIVING
OUTSIDE. THAT ARE NOT HERE AND A
WARM TAN. DON'T HAVE COFFEE.
DON'T KNOW WHERE THEIR NEXT MEAL
IS AND DON'T KNOW IF THEY'RE
EVEN GOING TO MAKE IT THROUGH.
THE NEXT FEW WEEKS SO. WE REALLY
HAVE AN URGENCY. I TRULY BELIEVE
THAT. AND AS A MEMBER OF THE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS I
JUST GAVE OVER. MY CHAIRMANSHIP
I AM NOW- DURING THE GAVEL OVER
TO ONE OF YOUR FORMER
COLLEAGUES- THAT'S A- SUPERVISOR
HOLLY MITCHELL WHO I KNOW IS
VERY. VERY KEENLY AWARE OF WHAT
THE ISSUES ARE HERE- AND I JUST
WANT TO SAY. IF I MIGHT. AND YOU
HEARD THIS ALREADY. THE MOTOR OF
LAWCENTER COUNTY OR THINKER.
CHEN ON THE ISSUE THEY HAVE BEEN
. THEY HAVE BEEN. BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THEY HELPED
US PASSED. MEASURE H. WHICH
YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD ABOUT. AND
MANY OF THOSE CITIES ACROSS THE
COUNTY PARTICIPATED IN THAT WE
HAD TO CONVINCE THEM THAT THIS
WAS SOMETHING OF AN INVESTMENT
THAT THEY COULD GET A RETURN ON-
I WANT TO SAY THAT- THUS FAR-
WE'VE LEARNED. THROUGH OUR OWN-
MISTAKES. AND PROGRESS. THAT
THERE'S STILL A LOT TO BE DONE-
WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE FOR
EXAMPLE- SINCE A- JULY ABOVE
TWENTY SEVENTEEN SEVENTY TWO
THOUSAND. PEOPLE THAT THE EXIT
HOMELESSNESS INTO PERMANENT
HOUSING THAT'S SINCE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THAT MAY
SOUND OKAY. BUT WHEN YOU'RE
REALLY LOOKING AT ANNUALLY EVERY
YEAR YOU SEE MORE THAN. SIXTY
SIX THOUSAND EIGHT IN AN UPWARD
THAT NUMBERED ESPECIALLY BECAUSE
OF PANDEMIC WE'RE REALLY WE'RE
REALLY CHASING MY TAIL HERE. TO
TELL THE DOC INSTEAD OF HELPING
TO LEAD AND I THINK WE CAN DO A
LOT MORE THERE I REALLY BELIEVE
THAT. AND I THINK THAT WHAT I'VE
HEARD ALREADY FROM OTHERS
SPEAKERS IS THAT THERE HAS TO BE
A PARALLEL TRACK HERE. I GET IT
THE PEOPLE DO NOT WANT TO SEE
FOLKS OUTSIDE NOBODY SHOULD HAVE
TO BE HUMILIATE THE MILLIE AIDED
IN THAT MATTER ESPECIALLY WHEN
IT COMES TO- WOMEN WOMEN WITH
CHILDREN. WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
FACILITIES TO DEAL WITH THE
GROWING NUMBER OF WOMEN AND
THEIR CHILDREN. AND WE NEED TO
WE REALLY NEED TO PRIORITIZE
THAT TWENTY THIRTY YEARS AGO
LONG BEFORE MANY OF US WERE
HERE- THERE WAS A CHANGING THE
TRAJECTORY IN TERMS OF HOW YOU
DEAL WITH MENTAL HEALTH BILL%
ILLNESS. SUBSTANCE ABUSE WE KNOW
THAT STORY WE DON'T WE DON'T
EVEN HAVE ENOUGH- BOARDING CARE
FACILITIES THEIR CLOSING LIKE
THAT. THOSE ARE FACILITIES THAT
WE SHOULD BE INVESTING IN RIGHT
AWAY AND PUTTING MONEY AND
PUTTING OUR STOCK IN THAT. LAST
TIME- I THINK OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. SANTIAGO WE JOINED THE
GOVERNOR AT A FACILITY THAT WAS
IN OUR DISTRICT THAT IS ACTUALLY
OF WAS WAS- GIVEN A LIFEBOAT. SO
THAT THEY COULD PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE TO PEOPLE THAT DON'T
NEED A CUTE ASSISTANCE AND IT'S
LESS COSTLY BUT DO IT THROUGH
BOARDING CARE TYPES OF
FACILITIES AT THE PEPPER ALL OF
OUR CITIES ALL OF OUR DISTRICTS.
THOSE HAVE BEEN CLOSED- THAT
MODEL I THINK HAS TO BE REVAMPED
IN THE AND WE HAVE A ROLE THERE
I THINK THAT THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES AND THE VARIOUS CITIES
AND I'M GONNA SPEAK. NOT JUST
ABOUT THE CITY OF LA BECAUSE
THEY'VE DONE A TREMENDOUS JOB WE
HAVE BEEN ACTIS REALLY TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN DO A
BETTER JOB THERE'S A LOT OF
CRITICISM THAT COULD BE THROWN.
AT ANY ONE OF US ANY SINGLE DAY
BUT I WILL SAY YOU YOU THAT SOME
OF US. DO ONE TO SEE SOMETHING
HAPPEN. AND I WOULD ASK YOU
BECAUSE WE SEE A SURPLUS IN
CALIFORNIA THIRTY ONE BILLION
DOLLARS. THAT WE REALLY CAN'T BE
CHEAP ON THIS ISSUE. AND I WILL
POINT OUT THAT ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I KNOW ARE COUNTY DID WAS
ASK FOR I BELIEVE TEN. I THINK
IT WAS TEN BILLION DOLLARS
THROUGH THE H. H. A. P. FUNDS.
AND SO FAR I'VE I'VE LEARNED
THAT WE'VE ONLY RECEIVED. IT FOR
TWO YEARS A BILLION EACH YEAR.
WHERE DOES THAT COME CLOSE TO
HELPING US WITH PROVIDING THE
REAL. SUBSTANTIVE KIND OF
SERVICES THAT PEOPLE REALLY NEED
YOU HEARD ABOUT IT ALREADY. NOT
ALL OF IT IS JUST ABOUT BUILDING
FACILITIES IT'S ABOUT THE
OPERATIONAL COSTS AND THE
STAFFING COSTS WHAT I THINK WE
SHOULD ALL BE DOING HERE. IS
TAKE A TAKE A NOTE A FOOTNOTE
OUT OF THE KENNEDY
ADMINISTRATION. AND THAT IS WE
WANT TO PUT A PUT A PERSON ON.
THE MOON. WHY CAN'T WE PUT TAKE
PEOPLE OUT OF. THIS OUT OF THE
SIDEWALKS AND PUT THEM IN
HOUSING NOT AND I AM NOT SEEN
PERMANENT HOUSING I'M SAYING
BILL TWO TRACKS. INTERIM AS WELL
AS AFFORDABLE AND AFFORDABLE CAN
BE DONE IN ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT THE STATE CAN DO RIGHT AWAY
WITH THAT SURPLUS IS HELP US
PROVIDE. A FUNDING STREAM THAT'S
NOT GOING TO GO AWAY IN TWO
YEARS AFTER YOU. EXHAUST YOUR
YOUR SURPLUS BUT THAT THERE IS
AN ACCOUNTABILITY MECHANISM SO
THAT WE HAVE OPERATIONAL
FUNDING. LET ME TELL YOU WHAT
HAPPENED THE EXPERIENCE THAT I
CAN SPEAK VERY HONESTLY ABOUT.
DURING MEASURE H. WE THOUGHT
THIS WAS GOING TO BE A CURE FOR
MANY OF MANY OF THE ISSUES THAT
WE'RE HEARING TODAY. WELL
UNFORTUNATELY WE FOUND OUT THAT
WAS JUST THE BEGINNING OF WHERE
WE NEED TO GO IN PART OF IT WAS.
IS THAT. LHASA THE COUNTY WE
REALLY. WE REALLY STE STOOD UP
TO TRY TO GET MORE PEOPLE ENGAGE
TO BUILD OUT THIS SO CALLED NEW
DEPARTMENT SO TO SPEAK. WE HIRED
PEOPLE FROM OUR NEIGHBORING
CITIES FROM THE SAN GABRIEL
VALLEY IN PARTICULAR. COME AND
WORK FOR LASSA WHICH IS GREAT
BUT GUESS WHAT WE DIDN'T BACK
FILL. THOSE POSITIONS. SO IN THE
SOUTH GATE AREA IN THE GATEWAY
AREAS WE FOUND THAT THERE WAS A
BIG VACUUM IN TERMS OF STAFFING.
AND WE CAN'T JUST TAKE OUR EYE
OFF. OFF THE- MARKER THERE WE
HAVE TO CONTINUE TO FEED THAT
SYSTEM. AND WE NEED TO ENGAGE
NOT JUST OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
BUT PEOPLE WHO HAVE HAD LIVED
EXPERIENCES. TO GET THEM
TRAINED. DOES IT WANT TO BECOME
PARTNERS WITH US SO THAT THEY
BECOME OUR TEAMS THAT ARE OUT
THERE. AND THEY CAN SPEAK THE
LANGUAGE WE NEED PEOPLE WHO ARE
MORE TRULY. CULTURALLY
COMPETENT. TO DEAL IN ALL OF OUR
DIFFERENT DISTRICTS BECAUSE WE
HAVE PEOPLE THAT SPEAK WHAT OVER
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY OR MORE
LANGUAGES. IN THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES WE OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO
HIRE PEOPLE UP AND PAY THEM GOOD
WAGES FOR THAT AS WELL. AND NOT.
NOT PICK FROM ONE OF PART OF THE
CITY OR THE COUNTY AND BRING
THEM ALL INTO ONE AREA WE NEED
TO HAVE A FORM TEAM AND THAT
COSTS MONEY THAT'S OPERATIONAL
COSTS. AND THENIF WE ARE GOING
TO BE CHARGED THE COUNTY TO DEAL
WITH OPERATIONAL COSTS. AND WE
ALSO NEED TO BE ACCOUNTABLE
ABOUT THAT AS WELL. AND KEEP IN
MIND MANY OF THE SOURCES OF
FUNDING THAT WE RECEIVE. ARE
TIED TO FORMULAS WHY DON'T WE
HAVE. AN URGENCY TO LOOK AT HOW
YOU DE COUPLE THAT AND IT ISN'T
JUST THIS THE COUNTY OR THE
STATE IT'S ALSO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. SO THEY ALSO HAVE TO
BE A PART OF THIS DISCUSSION
WITH A SO I AGREE SOMEONE. SAID
THAT EARLIER THAT WE NEED TO
HAVE THE FENCE HERE ABSOLUTELY.
AND WITH THE NEW INITIATIVES
THAT ARE COMING OUT OF THE
ADMINISTRATION I BELIEVE THAT WE
COULD DO THINGS WITH HUD. WE CAN
DO. WE CAN DO OF JOB CREATION
WORKFORCE TRAINING FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE SAFE MAYBE AT THE
INTERIM. HOUSING LEVEL TO GET
THEM INTO JOB TRAINING AND THEN
BEGIN TO HELP THEM BECOME MORE
RISK BILLION. AND THERE ARE
PROGRAMS WE CAN SET UP TO DO
THAT THE COUNTY ALREADY IS. IS
PILOTING PROGRAMS TO DO THAT WE
WANT TO HIRE UP THE VERY PEOPLE
THAT WE'RE TREATING. SO WE'RE
BRINGING IN OUR WORKFORCE
INVESTMENT BOARDS WHICH YOU
HAVE. FUNDING STREAMS AVAILABLE
WHY COULDN'T YOU EARMARK SOME OF
THAT. TO BE PLACED IN THOSE
PARTICULAR SETTINGS WHERE WE ARE
IT IS CHRONIC. I WOULD ALSO ASK
YOU TO THINK ABOUT- I KNOW THE
COST OF BUILDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IT'S ASTRONOMICAL. AND
WE'RE WE'RE IN THIS MODE NOW
WERE. MANY PEOPLE DON'T WANT
DEVELOPERS DON'T WANT TO ENTER
INTO THAT FIELD BECAUSE OF. THE
COMPLEX LICENSING PERMITTING
PROCESS AND WHAT HAVE YOU WELL
GUESS WHAT WE DID NOT TOO FAR
FROM HERE AND I. WOULD INVITE
ALL OF YOU TO PLEASE COME AND
VISIT. THE CARE VILLAGE ON BIG
MYSTERY. WHICH WAS INITIALLY
GOING TO BE- USED AS A PARKING
LOT TO BUILD THE MEN'S CENTRAL
JAIL. THAT'S IN MY DISTRICT I
SAID WE'RE NOT GOING TO WE'RE
NOT GOING TO BUILD ANYTHING.
OTHER THAN. A SHELTER FOR
HOMELESS PEOPLE AND WE DID IT
WITH CARES ACT MONEY WE COUPLED
OUR OWN MONEY I PUT IN. I WOULD
SAY SIX SIX A MILLION OF MY OWN
DISCRETIONARY MONEY WHICH ISN'T
AVAILABLE ALL THE TIME FOR
EVERYBODY. HOWEVER WE USED A
CARES ACT MONEY AND WE WERE ABLE
TO PUT UP A FACILITY THAT IS NOW
HOUSING. INTERIM HOUSING. TWO
HUNDRED AND THIRTY TWO UNITS OF
HOUSING AND SOMETHING THAT WAS
SAID EARLIER- WHICH I TOTALLY
AGREE WITH. YOU GIVE DIGNITY AND
RESPECT TO SOMEONE WHEN THEY
HAVE. THEIR OWN RESTROOM IN THE
SAME FACILITY IN THE SAME
FACILITY SO. THE MOTELS HOTELS
PROJECT ROOM P. HONKY I TOTALLY
AGREE WITH CELLS. AND I WANT TO
SEE THAT ENCOURAGE MORE I WOULD
LOVE TO SEE THAT ENCOURAGED. BUT
YOU CAN ALSO INVEST IN NEW
INNOVATIVE PROJECTS. WE HAVE THE
TINY HOMES THAT'S ONE. BUT IF
YOU HAVEN'T SEEN THE CONTAINERS
AND CONTAINERS IS PROBABLY NOT A
GOOD WORD TO DESCRIBE WHERE
THESE PEOPLE ARE LIVING NOW.
BECAUSE IF YOU WERE TO WALK INTO
ONE OF THOSE UNITS. YOU WOULD
THINK YOU WERE YOU WERE GOING
INTO A- UPSCALE. NOT EVEN MOTEL
SIX BECAUSE ARE CLEANER THAN
THAT. YOU YOUR OWN BATHROOM. THE
FIRST FLOOR OF THE FACILITIES
THREE STORIES STACK STACKABLE
CONTAINERS. THE COST IS BEEN
REDUCED MORE THAN HALF SO YOU'RE
NOT PAYING FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND PER UNIT. YOU CAN CUT
IT IN HALF THEY CAN BE EASILY
PUT UP IN A MATTER OF TIME WE
DID OURS IN SIX MONTHS AND
PARTLY BECAUSE WE CONTROLLED.
SEEK WHAT. THE REGULATIONS SO I
WOULD ASK YOU TO ALSO THINK
ABOUT. LEADING US FOR LEASING
OR- GRANTING. SOME PROPERTY THAT
KEPT THAT THAT THE STATE OWNED
AND NOT JUST CALTRANS PROPERTY
YOU HAVE A LOT OF THE PROPERTY.
A LOT OF PROPERTY IN MY
DISTRICT. IT IS JUST. OF
BECOMING ENCAMPMENTS. WHY DON'T
WE START TARGETING THOSE AREAS.
IT'LL BE LOW COST GIVE IT OVER
TO THE COUNTY OR WHOEVER FOR A
DOLLAR. AND LET'S SEE WHAT WE
CAN BUILD THEIR INTERIM AND
PERMANENT. AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
DEAL WITH WITH US CITIES OUTSIDE
OF JUST BARELY CITY BECAUSE OUR
PROBLEM IS IT ALL JUST. L. A.
CITY IN SKID ROW. YOU HAVE
PEOPLE IN MY DISTRICT RIGHT NOW
THEY'RE LIVING IN THE WATERSHED
IN AZUSA CANYON IN WHITTIER
NARROWS IN OUR PARKS. WE DON'T
WANT THAT. WE WANT A BETTER LIFE
FOR THEM BUT WE CAN'T JUST PICK
THEM UP SCOOP THEM UP AND SEND
THEM WHERE IF THERE'S NO
FACILITIES ALSO. INDICATED AREAS
IN CITIES THAT ARE TO SMALLER
CITIES. THAT ARE RIGHT NOW GOING
THROUGH NIMBYISM. I'VE I'VE HAD
TO DEAL WITH THAT. FOR THE LAST.
THREE YEARS NOW. AND IT'S BEEN
VERY HARD BUT I WILL SAY THAT
THERE IS SOME ENCOURAGEMENT.
THROUGH THE TRUST FUND THAT YOU
WILL HELP TO ESTABLISH I THINK
CENTER RUBIO. HAD SOME FUNDING
SET ASIDE FOR FAR SAN GABRIEL
VALLEY CAUGHT. SHE PUT IN I
THINK FIVE MILLION I THINK SHE'S
GOING TO PUT TWENTY WE PUT IN
ALSO MONEY. SO IT ISN'T AS
THOUGH WE'RE SAYING GIVE ME A
HAND OUT WE'RE SAYING WILL HELP
MATCH YOU. IN THE WAY THAT WE-CAN. BUT TO START BILL DOES
BRIDGE BUILDING THOSE BRIDGES
WITH SOME OF OUR CITIES. THE
OTHER EIGHTY SEVEN CITIES IS
VERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE ALL OF
YOU REPRESENT DIFFERENT AREAS.
THROUGHOUT THIS THE COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES AND IF WE REALLY ARE
GOING TO BEAT THIS OR LOOK AT
OTHER- MECHANISMS THEN WE HAVE
TO MAKE THOSE INVESTMENTS AND
ONE SIZE DOES NOT FIT ALL. I
WILL TELL YOU THAT IT DOES NOT
WORK THAT WAY- WE OPENED UP. OF
TWENTY SEVEN I THINK TINY HOMES
INVOLVED PARK. NEXT TO A LOT
THAT THE CITY OWNED. SO ENGAGE
CITIES CITIES TO HELP PROPERTY
THAT ARE THAT ARE JUST SITTING
THERE IDLE WHY COULDN'T WE START
TO LOOK AT HOW STRATEGICALLY WE
CAN PLAN. TO BUILD MORE HOUSING
UP MAKE IT SAFE MAKE IT SECURE
BUT CONTINUE TO HAVE. THIS
DISCUSSION THAT IT HAS TO BE
ONGOING OPERATIONAL BUT SO THE
FIRST THING THE CITY OF
BALLPARK. AND SOME OF OUR OTHER
CITIES ARE TELLING US KILL THE
WILL ENGAGE WITH YOU MONTEBELLO
WILL- AND OTHER CITIES. BUT THEY
WANT TO KNOW WHERE THE OPERATE
OPERATING COSTS ARE GOING TO
COME THAT IS GOING TO COME OUT
OF MEASURE H. THERE IS NOT
ENOUGH MONEY. AND THAT IS GOING
TO END IN SEVERAL YEARS SO WE
KNOW IF I'M GONNA BE ABLE TO GO
BACK OR WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO
GO BACK. TO OUR TAXPAYERS WOULD
HAVE TO SHOW THEM SOME RESULTS.
AND WE'RE GONNA NEED TO SAY IT
IN A WAY THAT ALL OF US ARE
REALLY ENGAGED. SO I WOULD
REALLY ASK FOR THAT AND I WOULD
INVITE YOU AGAIN TO PLEASE COME
OUT AND VISIT. THE VILLAGE THAT
WE PUT UP. IT HAS A DOG PARK
THERE IS A SEPARATE FACILITY
THAT HAS A KITCHEN. A STATE OF
THE ART KITCHEN THAT WILL BE
USED AS SOON AS IT'S POP PROPPED
UP. FOR TRAINING CULINARY ARTS.
NO BIG IDEA THERE JUST. PUT THE
KITCHEN TO USE THE PEOPLE THAT
LIVE THERE. ALSO FACILITIES THAT
ARE THAT ARE IN A CONTAINED AREA
WHERE. THERE'S A WASHERS DRYERS
AND ALL OF THAT. EVERYBODY THAT
COMES IN IS DIAGNOSED TO GET
CASE. BIGGEST CASE MANAGEMENT.
AND IT'S BEING DONE THERE'S- A
LIKE I SAID THERE'S EVEN A DOG
PARK THERE I MEAN WHO WOULD
THINK OF THAT. RIGHT BECAUSE
MANY OF OUR HOMELESS ARE
ATTACHED TO THEIR PETS. AND THEY
WON'T GO INTO SHELTERS UNLESS
THEY CAN BRING THEIR PETS. SO
WHY ARE WE DENYING PEOPLE.
THINGS THAT. THEY HELP THEM.
FEEL FEEL BETTER ABOUT WHO THEY
ARE- ONE THING I WILL I WILL SAY
TO YOU. AND SOME OF YOU HEARD
THIS I THINK- THAT WERE THAT
WERE- IT WAS LAST YEAR TOO WHEN
WE WENT UP TO SACRAMENTO TO TALK
TO THE DELEGATION. ABOUT HELPING
US FIND A RESTORATIVE CARE
VILLAGES AND WHAT I'M SAYING
THERE IS THAT KELLY C. WITH C.
FOR EXAMPLE WE HAVE ALREADY
BUILT I'D SAY ABOUT A HUNDRED
AND OF. A HUNDRED AND SIXTY
UNITS OF RECUPERATIVE BEDS. BEDS
AND THAT MEANS SO THE- WE'RE
WE'RE LOOKING AT NOT JUST
LOCKING PEOPLE UP BECAUSE IT
ISN'T ABOUT THAT IT'S GIVING
THEM THE TREATMENT THAT THEY
NEED. SO THEY COME OUT OF JAIL
OR THE COME OUT OF BEING
HOMELESS ON THE STREET. WE CAN
WE CAN ATTACH THE HEALTH CARE
UNIT IT'S RIGHT ADJACENT THERE
THEY CAN GET THE APPROPRIATE.
MEDICAL TREATMENT. AND THEN
HOPEFULLY BE ABLE TO STEP DOWN
FROM THOSE UNITS. THAT THAT
FACILITY WILL BE OPEN IN SPRING.
SO I HOPE THAT. I HOPE THAT
SOMEBODY WILL COME AND VISIT US
BECAUSE THAT FACILITY THE
BUILDINGS ARE ALREADY PHYSICALLY
THERE. BUT I WOULD LOVE TO
INVITE YOU. AND I WOULD TELL YOU
THAT ON OUR OWN PROPERTY ACROSS.
FROM FROM OUR HOSPITAL- IN OUR
PARKING LOTS WE'RE GOING TO TRY
TO BUILD TWO HUNDRED ADDITIONAL
UNITS OF LOW INCOME. HOMELESS
HOUSING BUT WE NEED FUNDING. AND
WE NEED DEVELOPERS IT'LL WORK
WITH US AND BECAUSE IT WOULD BE
ON OUR PROPERTY WE COULD
EXPEDITE I BELIEVE. THOSE
PERMITS AND SEEK WAS IN IS IN
OUR IS IN ARE ALL. YOU KNOW IS
WITH US AND THOSE THINGS CAN BE
EXPEDITED SO ALL OF THAT I THINK
COMING TOGETHER CAN HELP US. AND
THERE'S A PLAN TO CREATE THESE
RESTORATIVE CARE VILLAGES ON ALL
OF THE FIVE CAMPUSES WHERE WE
HAVE HOSPITALS SO WE'RE DOING IT
AT MARTIN LUTHER KING WE'RE
GONNA BE DOING IT YOU SEE LA ALL
OF THESE. DIFFERENT FACILITIES
THAT THE THAT THE COUNTY OWNS SO
I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU AND AM
VERY HAPPY TO BE TO BE HERE WITH
YOU AND I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE BOARD BECAUSE-
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF THEM. HAVE
BUILT DIFFERENT FACILITIES AND
ARE LOOKING AT BUILDING OUT MORE
HOME KEY ROOM KEY AS WELL AS A
PARTICULAR HOUSING UNITS
AFFORDABLE IN JUST ABOUT EVERY
DISTRICTS SO THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. I HAVE TO SAY LOOK I
APPRECIATE YOUR CANDID BALANCED
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT THE
COUNTY IS WHAT SPARKED. MY
MASCOT STUCK WITH THE COUNTY
NEED TO DO WITH THE STATE NEED
TO DO WITH THE CITY NEEDS DO
WHAT THE FEDS NEED TO DO. THAT'S
THE KIND OF CONVERSATION WE NEED
BECAUSE WE KNOW WE'RE ALL IN
THIS TOGETHER. I MEAN WILL WE
DON'T FIX IT WE DON'T DON'T.
FIGURE OUT HOW TO WORK TOGETHER.
FIVE PRESET YOUR CANDID- ON
HONEST CONVERSATION ABOUT THE-
CALDERON WOULD YOU. KINDLY JOIN
. CAN BE THERE IN YOU FOR
EVERYBODY WHO'S WHO'S IT OUT
HERE IN THE CALL TO GET A MAN
YOUR WHOLE. THIS IS YOUR LIFE.
COMPLETELY NO. SECTION GREAT
WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HAVING ME TODAY I'M A DEER
ALMOND COUNCIL MEMBER FOR THE
FOURTH DISTRICT HERE IN THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES I WANT TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT. IN THE- IN THE
LESS THAN A YEAR WILL BE A YEAR
NEXT WEEK THAT I'VE BEEN IN
OFFICE. WHAT I'VE SEEN HAS
WORKED. FROM OUR EFFORTS IN OUR
OFFICE AT ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS IN OUR DISTRICT-
AND WHAT HASN'T WORKED- IN TERMS
OF OUR BROUGHT IT BROUGHT A
RESPONSE TO HOMELESSNESS- BOTH
IN MY DISTRICT AND IN THE CITY
AS A WHOLE. SO WHAT'S WORKED.
ONE OF THE BIGGEST CHANGES ABOUT
THIS PERIOD FROM ANY PERIOD THAT
I THINK THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
HAS EVER EXPERIENCED IN ITS IN
PART THANKS TO. STATE FUNDING IS
THE AMOUNT OF RENT RELIEF THAT'S
BEEN AVAILABLE FOR STRUGGLING
TENANTS- THERE HAS BEEN A HUGE
AMOUNT OF MONEY BOTH FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FROM THE
STATE GOVERNMENT. HAS GONE
TOWARDS RENTERS TO HELP THEM
STAY HOUSED DURING THIS
PANDEMIC. WHAT WE HAVE DONE AND
WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN OUR EFFORTS
IN OUR DISTRICT. IS THAT WE'VE
ACTUALLY GONE DOOR TO DOOR IN
APARTMENT BUILDINGS- IN OUR
DISTRICT OUR STAFF HAS IN A
QUORUM VOLUNTEERS. HAS GONE DOOR
TO DOOR AND WHAT WE FOUND IN
THAT WORK. IS THAT. THERE IS
STILL A NEED FOR BETTER PATHWAYS
BETWEEN STRUGGLING TENANTS AND
THE RESOURCES THAT THEY HAVE
AVAILABLE TO THEM. EVEN WHEN
THAT FUNDING IS GIVEN TO US THE
MONEY TO ACTUALLY CREATE THOSE
CONNECTIONS BETWEEN TENANTS. AND
THE KNOWLEDGE ABOUT THE RIGHTS
AND RESOURCES THAT THEY HAVE
AVAILABLE TO THEM IS STILL VERY
MUCH MISSING. FOR EXAMPLE IN MY
OWN DISTRICT WHICH IS A
RELATIVELY HIGH RESOURCE- MOSTLY
ENGLISH SPEAKING DISTRICT- WE'VE
DISTRIBUTED THOUSANDS. OF PIECES
OF LITERATUREAT DOORS WE'VE HAD
OVER SIX HUNDRED CONVERSATIONS
WITH HOUSEHOLDS. AND A HUGE
NUMBER OF THEM WERE BEHIND ON
THEIR RENT AND WERE NOT AWARE.
OF THE KIND OF DOLLARS THAT THEY
WERE ELIGIBLE FOR FROM THE CITY
FROM THE STATE AND FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. WHICH WAS
ASTOUNDING TO US- AND SO MAKING
THOSE OTHER CONNECTIONS TO
WHENEVER YOU FIND RESOURCES FOR
TENANTS. TO HELP THEM STAY HOUSE
TO HELP PEOPLE STAY IN THEIR
HOMES. TO ALSO IN THE SAME
BREATH FUND RESOURCES TO MAKE
SURE THE INFORMATION ABOUT THOSE
RESOURCES. IS GETTING OUT TO THE
PEOPLE WHO MOST DESPERATELY NEED
IT. THAT'S A MISSING PIECE THAT
I THINK THE STATE AND THE CITY
CAN DO MUCH BETTER IN FUNDING
TOGETHER. THE SECOND THING WHICH
IS REALLY WORKED IN OUR
DISTRICT. HAS BEEN FOCUSED PLACE
BASED EFFORTS AT HOUSING FOLKS
SO WHAT'S SO WHAT'S BEEN CALLED
THE IN CAMERA TO HOME. A KIND OF
MODEL AT GETTING PEOPLE OFF THE
STREETS- THAT'S FOCUSED EFFORTS
AT SINGLE ENCAMPMENTS. YOU WORK
WITH THEM OVER TIME AND YOU WORK
WITH THEM TO GET PEOPLE. INDOORS
AND IT'S WORKED BECAUSE OF TWO
REASONS ONE IT'S BECAUSE WHEN
YOU HAVE A GROUP OF PEOPLE. WHO
ARE AT ENCAMPMENTS OFTEN
PARTICULARLY IN THIS PERIOD WHEN
ENCAMPMENTS HAVE BEEN THERE FOR
A LONG TIME PEOPLE IN THOSE
ENCAMPMENTS HAVE ALSO BUILT UP A
SENSE OF COMMUNITY WITH ONE
ANOTHER. AND SO HELPING PEOPLE
TO MOVE INDOORS WITH THAT
COMMUNITY OR IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THAT COMMUNITY HAVING SOMEONE
FROM THAT COMMUNITY GO INDOORS
COME BACK OUT TO THE NGAGEMENT
AND SAY. HEY IT'S GREAT IN THERE
COME WITH ME THAT HAS REALLY
WORKED AT ACTUALLY HELPING US
TO- GET EVERYONE HOUSE AT A
PARTICULAR IN CANTON AND HAVE
THAT ENCAMPMENTS STAY CLEAR GO
ON AN ONGOING BASIS. IT'S REALLY
REALLY REMARKABLE IT'S ALSO
WORKED BECAUSE RESOURCES ARE
SUPER SCARCE FOR OUTRAGE I KNOW
THERE'S A LOT MORE DOLLARS IN
IT. AND IT DOESN'T FEEL LIKE IT
SHOULD BE SCARCE BUT IT IS
SCARCE AND IT'S ALSO FRAGMENTED.
IT'S HIGHLY FRAGMENTED AND SO
WHAT ENCAMPMENTS HOME OPERATION
DOES IS THAT IT HELPS US TO
FOCUS IT BECOMES LIKE A WEEKLY
MEETING THAT YOU CAN HAVE ABOUT
A GROUP OF INDIVIDUALS MONITOR
THEIR PROGRESS AND HELP THEM GO
IN OVERTIME. IT FORCES YOU TO DO
THAT COORDINATION WORK THAT I
THINK SHOULD BE HAPPENING SYSTEM
WIDE ON A REGULAR BASIS BUT IT'S
MUCH EASIER TO DO ON IN CANTON
BY CANTON LEVEL. THE THIRD I
THINK THAT HAS WORKED AND I
THINK- SUPERVISORS LEASE YOU
MENTION THIS AS WELL A ROOM WITH
THE DOOR. THE ABILITY TO HAVE A
ROOM WITH THE DOOR TO OFFER
INDIVIDUALS WHETHER IT'S A TINY
HOME WHETHER IT IS A BIG NO
STYLE FACILITY- WHETHER IT IS UP
PRK ROOM WHETHER IT IS AN
APARTMENT IT KIND OF DOESN'T
MATTER WHAT KIND OF ROOM WITH
THE DOOR IT IS. BUT THAT ROOM
WITH THE DOOR GETS PEOPLE
INDOORS OVER AND OVER AGAIN SAYS
YOU'RE MAKING INVESTMENTS FROM
THE STATE LEVEL I WANT. THAT
HELP TO BUILD MORE ROOMS WITH
DOORS OR BY MORE ROOMS WITH
DOORS THAT WE CAN OFFER TO
PEOPLE WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS BECAUSE THAT GETS
US TO YES. OVER AND OVER AGAIN
WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND FINALLY I JUST
WANTED TO SAY SOMETHING THAT I'M
VERY PROUD OF FROM OUR OFFICE.
BUT WHICH I THINK DOESN'T HAPPEN
A CRAW THE CITY FOR. THAT I CAN
TALK ABOUT WHEN I TALK ABOUT.
WHAT HASN'T WORKED- IS THAT WHEN
WE HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE MOVING
INTO FACILITIES WHETHER IT BE
PRK WHETHER IT BE. OTHER KINDS
OF INTERIM HOUSING FACILITIES
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO GET PEOPLE IN
THOSE HOMES TRANSITION INTO
PERMANENT HOUSING. BECAUSE WE
HAVE THE STAFF TO DO THE FOLLOW
UP. FIVE ABOUT TWENTY EIGHT
PEOPLE I BELIEVE ON MY STAFF I
HAVE A HOMELESSNESS TEAM OF
THREE AND A HALF RIGHT NOW. AND
THAT'S A PRETTY BIG INVESTMENT
IN MAKING SURE THAT WE'RE DOING
THE COORDINATION WORK. AND OUR
COUNCIL DISTRICT LEVEL GIVE TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
ARE COUNCIL DISTRICTS I DON'T
THINK THAT'S A HUGE NUMBER. BUT
IT'S STILL IT'S AN INVESTMENT
THAT I THINK IS MORE THAN MANY
OTHER COUNCIL DISTRICTS ARE
MAKING. AND BECAUSE WE'RE DOING
THE FOLLOW UP WITH PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN HOUSE. TO SAY HEY ARE
YOU MOVING TO THAT NEXT STEP.
WE'RE ABLE TO THEN ASK FOR THE
RESOURCES THAT WE NEED TO GET
PEOPLE OT JUST INTO INTERIM
HOUSING. BUT THEN TO MAKE THE
TRANSITION INTO PERMANENT
HOUSING. AND HEIDI KNOWS BECAUSE
I'VE CALLED HER MANY TIMES TO
BUG ER FOR THOSE RESOURCES-
FINALLY I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
WHAT HASN'T WORKED- FIRST OF ALL
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE GAPS IN
OUR MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES- AND
I THINK FUNDING CAN HELP
ELIMINATE SOME OF THOSE GAPS I
JUST WANNA TALK ABOUT IT. FROM
THE PERSPECTIVE OF SOMEONE WHO'S
TRYING TO GET SOMEONE HELP. SO
THERE ARE PEOPLE IN OUR STREETS
IN MY SCHOOL DISTRICT STREETS.
WHO ARE VERY VERY SICK. AND THEY
ARE STRUGGLING WITH MENTAL
ILLNESS. BUT THEY ARE NOT SICK
ENOUGH FOR OUR DMH- PRIMARY
STREET BASED OUTREACH TEAM WHICH
IS OUR HOME TEAM. TO GO OUT AND
HELP THEM. SO THEY LITERALLY
HAVE TO WAIT. UNTIL THEY ARE
NEAR DEATH. FOR OUR DEPARTMENT
OF MENTAL HEALTH TO BE ABLE TO
GO OUT AND SERVE THEM. THAT IS
OUTRAGEOUS AND IT IS
HUMILIATING. FOR OUR CITY TO BE
IN THAT POSITION. AND I THINK
THE MORE THAT WE CAN FUNDED
SERVICES FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING MENTAL ILLNESS
INCLUDING. STREET BASED MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. FOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE. STRUGGLING BUT- WITH THE
RIGHT RESOURCES CAN NAVIGATE
INTO HOUSING AND CARE. BEFORE
THEY GET SO SICK THA THEY ARE
DYING. WE DESPERATELY NEED THAT
AND WE DON'T HAVE THAT RIGHT
NOW. SIMILARLY I WOULD SAY THE
SAME FOR SUBSTANCE ABUSE
RESOURCES RIGHT NOW WE ARE
SEEING AN EXPLOSION OF MATH ON
OUR STREETS. CHEMICAL
COMPOSITIONS HAVE CHANGED. SUCH
THAT WHAT PEOPLE ARE USING IS
AFFECTING THEM IN WAYS THAT I
HAVEN'T SEEN BEFORE JUST MY
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE. PEOPLE ARE
SICKER. ON THE STREETS AND I
HAVE SEEN THEM BEFORE BECAUSE OF
THE NATURE OF THE DRUGS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE RIGHT NOW. WE NEED
RESOURCES. FOR SUBSTANCE ABUSE
WE NEED THEM DESPERATELY. AND
THERE WAS A VERY EXCITING BILL A
PUT FORWARD BY SENATOR SCOTT
WIENER. ABOUT INCH SAFE
INJECTION SITES WHICH DIDN'T
MOVE FORWARD THROUGH THE STATE.
ANY EVIDENCE BASED RESPONSE TO
SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND RECOVERY
THAT YOU CAN FIND WE DESPERATELY
NEED IT. TO RESPOND TO A CRISIS
THAT IS GROWING- AND NEEDS NEEDS
HELP URGENTLY. FINALLY I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THE THING THAT REALLY
DOESN'T WORK FOR ME. WHICH IS
THAT WE DON'T REALLY HAVE A
COORDINATED STRATEGY AT THE CITY
FOR RESPONDING TO HOMELESSNESS.
EACH COUNCIL DISTRICT GOES ITS
OWN WAY- AND I THINK THAT
HAPPENS IN THE COUNTY WITH ALL
OF OUR CITIES SO I THINK IT'S A
PARALLEL PROBLEM MAYBE IT
HAPPENS AT THE STATE LEVEL. SURE
AND AT THE CITY LEVEL THAT
PROBLEM IS EVEN MORE ACUTE
BECAUSE THE PEOPLE CHARGED WITH
FINDING LAND FOR INTERIM
HOUSING. THE PEOPLE CHARGED WITH
FINDING LAND FOR PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. ARE ALSO THE PEOPLE WHO
WILL SUFFER THE MOST. SEVERE
POLITICAL CONSEQUENCES FOR
FINDING THAT HOUSING AND
BUILDING THAT HOUSING. EVERY
TIME I PUT FORWARD A SITE. FOR
ANY ANY KIND OF CONSTRUCTION.
WHETHER EVEN IF IT'S JUST A DROP
IN CENTER. A ONCE A WEEK I GET A
BUNCH OF CALLS COMPLAINING ABOUT
IT. AND SO IT IS A DISINCENTIVE
FOR ME EVEN THOUGH I. REALLY
WANT TO DO IT I BECAUSE I KNOW
IT'S NEEDED FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS OUR OUR ISSUES. WE KNOW
OVER AND OVER AGAIN THAT WE
CAN'T ARREST OR SWEEP OUR WAY
OUT OF THIS CRISIS THE ONLY WAY
TO SUSTAINABLY ENDING
HOMELESSNESS IS TO GET PEOPLE
INTO HOUSING. IT TAKES TIME IT
TAKES PATIENCE AND YET THE
PERSON WHO IS CHARGED WITH
MAKING SURE THAT THAT PROCESS
HAPPENS SUSTAINABLY HAPPENS
SAFELY HAPPENS COMPASSIONATELY
HAPPENS EFFECTIVELY THAT'S ME.
I'M ALSO THE PERSON WHO GETS THE
MOST PHONE CALLS. ABOUT ASKING
PEOPLE TO BE MOVED IMMEDIATELY
FROM HOUSE RESIDENTS WERE
UNDERSTANDABLY. AND I HAVE A LOT
OF EMPATHY FOR HOUSE AND HOUSE
RESIDENTS IN THIS CASE THEY'RE
UNDERSTANDABLY IMPATIENT. AND
FRUSTRATED WITH OUR ABILITY TO
MAKE PROGRESS ON THESE ISSUES.
WE NEED. CENTRALIZATION WE NEED
DECISION MAKING ABOUT HOUSING
AND WHERE WE'RE GOING TO SITE
HOUSING WE'RE GONNA PUT THIS
HOUSING. THAT IS NOT BEING MADE
AT THE COUNCIL DISTRICT LEVEL I
KNOW THAT'S WEIRD FOR ME TO SAY
I DON'T WANT THAT- BUT I THINK
FOR THE BENEFIT OF OUR CITY TO
BE ABLE TO RESPOND MORE
EFFECTIVELY. IT HAS TO BE DONE
IN A CENTRALIZED WAY AT THE
CITY- IT HAS TO BE DONE AT THE
CENTRALIZED WITH THE COUNTY- AND
IT HAS TO BE SUPERCHARGED- AND I
KNOW THE STATE HAS BEEN DOING A
LOT ON HOUSING CONSTRUCTION- AND
KIND OF EASING. PADS FOR HOUSING
BEING BUILT- IN VARIOUS
JURISDICTIONS. BUT I THINK THE
STRATEGY NEEDS TO BE MORE
THOUGHTFUL. AND IT NEEDS TO BE
MORE COORDINATED TOWARD
ADDRESSING OUR GREATEST NEEDS
WHETHER IT BE GEOGRAPHICALLY
FOCUSED WHETHER IT BE FOCUSED ON
A PARTICULAR KIND OF HOUSING
IT'S PIECE MEAL RIGHT NOW. THEY
WERE ALL GOING TO WORK TOGETHER
TO ADDRESS OUR HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS. WE REALLY
NEED. DIRECTION SO WITH THAT ALL
ALL CLOSER. THANK YOU AGAIN AND
THANK YOU FOR THOUGHTFUL
APPROACH TO. BEING SELF CRITICAL
AND CRITICAL OF ALL- AREAS SO I
MUST GET STUCK ON THE EVERY NOW
AND THEN- THIS PERSON IF YOU
WANT- REDUCE THE OWNER PLEASE.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR HAVING ME HEIDI MARSTON
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF LHASA I WE
ARE THE COORDINATING AGENCY
BETWEEN THE CITY AND THE COUNTY
AND THE CONTINUUM OF CARE AND
HOMELESSNESS. THANK YOU FOR
HAVING US HERE TODAY I JUST A
FEW THINGS THAT I WANT TO SHARE
AND A LOT OF IT IS REALLY
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT YOU'VE
HEARD ALREADY TODAY FROM
PANELISTS BUT- DESPITE WHAT WE
SEE ON OUR STREETS AND THE
TRAGEDY THAT WE SEE IN THE
CRISIS THAT WE SEE. ARE HOMELESS
THREE HOUSING SYSTEM IS STILL
HOUSING MORE AND MORE PEOPLE
EVERY SINGLE YEAR AND WE'VE
HEARD TODAY A NUMBER OF TIMES
OUR LAST HOMELESS COUNT SHOWED
SIXTY SIX THOUSAND PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS. AND
JUST TO PUT THAT INTO
PERSPECTIVE OVER THE LAST THREE
YEARS OUR SYSTEM HAS HOUSED
SIXTY THOUSAND PEOPLE SO IT
REALLY EMPHASIZES FOR US WHAT IS
HAPPENING WITH PEOPLE COMING
INTO HOMELESSNESS AND THE NEED
TO STOP PEOPLE FROM FALLING IN.
WHEN WE BREAK THAT DOWN A LITTLE
FURTHER OUT WITH OUR TWENTY
TWENTY NUMBERS IT LOOKS LIKE TWO
HUNDRED AND FIVE PEOPLE BEING
PLACED INTO PERMANENT HOUSING
EVERY SINGLE DAY ACROSS THE
COUNTY. AND TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE PEOPLE BECOMING HOMELESS
EVERY SINGLE DAY IN L. A. COUNTY
SO WE HAVE TO FIND WAYS TO TURN
OFF THE FAUCET AND AT ALL COSTS
KEEP PEOPLE IN THEIR HOMES. WE
ALSO HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
CONTINUE TO CENTER ON THE TRUTH
THAT I'VE HEARD HERE TODAY
ACROSS THE BOARD IS THAT BEING
ON HOUSE IN AMERICA BEING ON
HOUSE IN LA IS NOT. A CHARACTER
FLAW AND IT'S NOT AN INDIVIDUAL
SHORTCOMINGS. BUT IT'S A DIRECT
ESULT OF THE SYSTEM AND POLICY
FAILURES THAT HAVE LED TO WHERE
WE ARE. AND THE VALLEY BUSINESS
COUNCIL PAUL THAT A LOT OF YOU
HAVE MENTIONED TODAY IT SHOWED
THAT ANGELENOS UNDERSTAND THAT
INTUITIVELY. BUT 94% OF THE
RESIDENTS IDENTIFIED
HOMELESSNESS IS A SERIOUS ISSUE.
AND 86% OF THOSE PEOPLE SAID
THAT HOUSING AFFORDABILITY WAS A
MAJOR CONTRIBUTOR. AND SO ALL OF
THIS IS TO SAY THAT WE CAN
ABSOLUTELY DESIGN SYSTEMS THAT
AND HOMELESSNESS BECAUSE WE
DESIGN THE SYSTEMS THA BECAUSE
HOMELESSNESS. SO WHAT I WANNA DO
BRIEFLY IS TALK TO YOU A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT WHAT'S WORKING AND IT
LOS ANGELES AN ACROSS THE BOARD.
AND REITERATING WHAT YOU'VE
HEARD HERE TODAY AT FULLY IN
SUPPORT THAT WE NEED TO HAVE A
BALANCED SYSTEM WE NEED A WAY
ESPECIALLY REGION OF LIKE LA TO
FAST QUICKLY GET PEOPLE OFF OF
THE STREET AND INTO SHELTER- WE
NEED TO CREATE THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES. AND ON THE OTHER
SIDE WE NEED TO HAVE OPTIONS FOR
THOSE PEOPLE TO MOVE INTO
PERMANENT HOUSING. AND WHILE THE
COVE IN NINETEEN PANDEMIC
BROUGHT US TREMENDOUS STRATEGY
TRAGEDY SUFFERING LOSS OF LIVES
WE DID SEE A GLIMMER OF HOPE AND
IT SPEAKS A LOT OF WHAT YOU'VE
HEARD IS THAT. COVER NINETEEN
DIDN'T ONLY GIVE US THE
RESOURCES THAT WE NEEDED TO
ADDRESS THIS HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
FROM THE FEDERAL AND THE STATE
LEVEL IT GAVE US THE WILL. AND
IT GAVE US THIS EMERGENCY
RESPONSE I THINK A LOT OF US
HAVE BEEN CALLING FOR A REALLY
LONG TIME WITH THIS CRISIS. AND
IT BECAUSE OF SUPPORT FROM THE
STATE IN COORDINATION WITH LASSA
AT THE LA CITIES L. A. COUNTY
OUR COMMUNITY REALLY CAME
TOGETHER AND WE SAT A COLLECTIVE
TARGET AT ALL LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT AND SAID OUR FIRST
PRIORITY IS TO GET PEOPLE
INSIDE. WHO DIDN'T HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF SHELTERING IN PLACE
AT THE BEGINNING OF THE COPA
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. SO IN A
MATTER OF WEEKS OUR COLLECTIVE
EFFORTS BROUGHT THIRTY HOTELS
AND MOTELS ONLINE THROUGH
PROJECT ROOM HE- AND THIS FEMA
BASS COVE IT RESPONSE THAT
REALLY ALLOWED CITIES AND
COUNTIES AND STATES TO BE
REIMBURSED. AND TO HAVE A WAY
FORWARD. AND AT ITS PEAK IN LA
THERE WERE THIRTY SEVEN PROJECT
ROOM KEY SITES WITH ABOUT THIRTY
SIX HUNDRED ROOMS WHICH IS MORE
THAN ANY OTHER REGION IN THE
COUNTRY. AND SO APPEAR K. REALLY
TAUGHT US IS THAT WHEN WE ALL
COME TOGETHER AT ACROSS ALL
LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT ACROSS
DONDE GOVERNMENTAL AGENCIES
ACROSS NONPROFIT. AND WE ALIGNED
WITH A COMMON GOAL AND WE ALIGN
OUR RESOURCES WE CAN MOVE FASTER
THAN WE EVER THOUGHT WE COULD WE
SURPRISED OURSELVES AND HOW
QUICKLY WE ARE ABLE TO BRING
PROJECT ROOM. ONLINE BUT IT
HAPPENED BECAUSE WE ALL LINED ON
A VISION AND I THINK THAT WE CAN
DO THAT AGAIN AND BUILD HAT
MOMENTUM. AND LIKE YOU'VE HEARD
IT PROJECT ROOM HE ALSO
REINFORCE THE THINGS WE KNEW
ABOUT SHELTER AND NEW WAYS THAT
WE NEED TO THINK ABOUT SHELTER.
WHICH IS THIS NON CONGREGATE
DIGNIFIED SPACES THAT HAS A DOOR
THAT LOCKS THAT HAVE A BATHROOM.
AND LET'S PEOPLE COME INSIDE AND
HAVE A PRIVATE PLACE TO STAY
WITH DIGNITY. AND THAT'S WHY
PROJECT ROOM HE HAS REMAINED
FULL- IT'S WHY PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN HESITANT TO COME IN TO
SHELTER BEFORE WERE NOT HAS A
TEN AND WE HAD THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE WAITING TO GET IN THE
PROJECT ROOM KEY. BUT SINCE THE
BEGINNING A PROJECT ROOM KEY AND
THE BEGINNING OF COALBED SO FAR
WE'VE SERVE NINE THOUSAND PEOPLE
AND OUR PROJECT ROOM KEY SITES.
AND THE REAL SUCCESS TO ME IS
NOT ONLY HOW MANY WE BROUGHT
INSIDE. BUT THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
COMING INSIDE ARE NOT RETURNING
TO THE STREETS AT THE RATE WE
SEE IN OUR CONGREGATE SITES SO
LESS THAN 10% OF PEOPLE ARE
GOING BACK TO THE STREET. AND SO
FAR SO FAR IT'S NOT OVER YET BUT
25% OF PEOPLE HAVE GONE RIGHT
FROM PROJECT ROOM KEY INTO
PERMANENT HOUSING BECAUSE WERE
ABLE TO CENTRALIZE OUR HOUSING
RESOURCES. RABAL TO CENTRALIZE
OUR DOCUMENTATION SPECIALIST AND
ALL OF OUR CASE MANAGEMENT ON
SITE. TO GET PEOPLE INDOORS. IF
SO I WANT TO RE EMPHASIZE THAT
THIS IS CERTAINLY NOT A QUESTION
OF WHETHER SHELTER OR HOUSING
WORKS BETTER IT'S NOT EITHER OR
SHELTER WORKS BEST WHEN WE HAVE
HOUSING RESOURCES THAT WE CAN
ATTACH TO IT WE NEED SHELTER TO
GET FOLKS OFF THE STREET BUT
WITHOUT THE PERMANENT HOUSING
RESOURCES ON THE OTHER END
PEOPLE WILL STAY IN SHELTER AND
WE SEE LENGTH OF STAY IN SHELTER
ACTUALLY INCREASING RIGHT NOW
ONE TO TWO YEARS EVEN THE PEOPLE
ARE STAYING WAITING FOR THAT
HOUSING OPTION ON THE BACK AND-
SO IT SHELTERS PREVENT PEOPLE
FROM SUFFERING OUTDOORS. AND
HOUSING WILL MAKE THE SHELTER
SYSTEM MORE EFFICIENT SO IT'S
ABOUT THE END- AND I'LL JUST END
BY SAYING IT THAT WE TALK A LOT
ABOUT PERMANENT HOUSING WE TALK
ABOUT THE COST OF PERMANENT
HOUSING. I THINK IT'S ALSO
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT BUILDING
NEW AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS NOT
THE ONLY PIECE THAT WERE LOOKING
OUT WE'RE ALSO USING RENTAL
SUBSIDIES THAT REPRESENT ABOUT A
THIRD OF OUR HOUSING PLACEMENTS.
WHERE WE HAVE CHALLENGES THERE
IS MAKING THOSE RENTAL SUBSIDIES
COMPETITIVE IN OUR MARKET- THAT
YOU'VE HEARD OVER AND OVER THE
COST OF LIVING IS ASTRONOMICAL.
AND JUST FROM A WESTERN REGION
PERSPECTIVE THIS ISN'T EVEN L.
A. ALONE BUT ACROSS THE ENTIRE
WESTERN SIDE OF THE U. S. THERE
ARE THIRTY AVAILABLE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNITS. FOR EVERY ONE
HUNDRED HOUSEHOLDS THAT NEED
THEM. SO IT'S LIKE A REALLY BAD
GAME OF MUSIC MUSICAL CHAIRS
ACROSS THE WEST COAST I WOULD
SAY PROBABLY EVEN WORSE IN LA-
THAT IS THE WEST COAST BUT A BAD
GAME OF MUSICAL CHAIRS THAT
LEAVES THE MOST VULNERABLE
PEOPLE. OUT ON THE STREET
WITHOUT AN OPTION TO RESOLVE
THEIR HOMELESSNESS. SO WHAT WE
NEED TO SEE FROM THE STATE IF
THE CONTINUING OF BUILDING ON
THESE HISTORIC INVESTMENTS LIKE
YOU DID MAKING THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE BUDGET- AND WE'RE REALLY
GRATEFUL FOR THE INVESTMENTS IN
PROJECT HOME HE- AND THERE ARE
HUGE LEAP FORWARD AND WE WANT TO
BUILD ON THAT. THE BILLION
DOLLAR STATE INVESTMENT AND
HAPPY THIS YEAR- AND IN THE NEXT
BUDGET YEAR IS REALLY CRITICAL
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
RESOURCES TO MOVE PEOPLE OFF THE
STREET WITH RENTAL SUBSIDIES IN
CASE MANAGEMENT- BUT- AS YOU'VE
HEARD CONSISTENCY IS. THE KEY AT
WE REALLY NEED THE LEGISLATURE
TO PRIORITIZE MAKING FUNDING
PERMANENT SO WE CAN ENSURE
SERVICE PROVIDERS HAVE THE
PREDICTABILITY AND THE STABILITY
OF RESOURCE THING THEY NEED TO
SCALE UP. THEIR SERVICES AND
KEEP THEM GOING. THE STATE BEGAN
FUNDING FLEXIBLE FLEXIBLE
FUNDING FOR LOCAL PROVIDERS IN
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
BUDGET YEAR AND THAT. THE
PROGRAM HAS CHANGED EVERY YEAR
SINCE THEN. AND JUST I LIKE TO
THINK ABOUT THIS IN ANOTHER
CONTACT THAT WE WOULD NEVER
EXPECT TO SET A SUCCESS FROM OUR
SCHOOLS ARE K. THROUGH TWELVE
SCHOOL SYSTEM. IF THEY HAD TO GO
TO SACRAMENTO EVERY YEAR TO MAKE
SURE THEY HAVE THE NEEDED
FUNDING TO CONTINUE THEIR
PROGRAMS. AND WE SHOULD TAKE THE
SAME APPROACH AROUND HOMELESS
SERVICES BECAUSE WE CAN'T HAVE
THE RISK OF A CLIFF AT EVERY
YEAR. AGAIN WANT TO THANK YOU
CHAIR SANTIAGO FOR BRINGING THIS
HEARING TOGETHER ADAM AND HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
HAVE. AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FOR YOUR FOR YOUR HONEST
COMMENTS- LET ME JUMP OVER THE
COMMITTEE IF THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONS HERE. I'M SORRY MR
GIPSON AYE HE- I'M SORRY. SO
IT'S IT IS QUITE ALRIGHT- I WANT
TO SAY I APPRECIATE- COMMITTEE-
THAT'S BEFORE US IN THE PREVIOUS
COMMITTEE AND I DID DEFERRED TO-
MOVE THE AGENDA LONG BUT I MUST
WEIGH IN A JUST FOR THE SAKE OF
MY TIMES I HAVE ANOTHER
APPOINTMENT THANK THE ROBUST
CONVERSATION. HOW MUCH MONEY
WOULD YOU SAY WE NEED TO INVEST
TO RADIC KATE THIS ISSUE THAT'S
THE FIRST QUESTION THE SECOND
QUESTION IS WHAT IS YOUR
THOUGHTS AROUND- A STATE Y.
COORDINATES BECAUSE WHAT I HEARD
WAS THAT THERE IS NO REAL
COORDINATION AND- WE NEED TO
BRING EVERYONE AND UMBRELLA WHO
RECEIVED FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL
MONEY. TO COME TOGETHER TO HAVE
A ROBUST CONVERSATION TO CREATE
A BIGGER PLAN SO THAT'S THE
SECOND QUESTION AND THE THIRD
AND FINAL QUESTION I HAVE RONALD
REAGAN REALLY SCREWED UP WHEN
HE- DISMANTLED- MENTAL SERVICES
SO WHAT IS YOUR IDEAL BECAUSE MY
TEAM'S RESEARCH OR RESEARCH HAS
RESEARCHED ON THIS ISSUE AND WE
MAY BE PROVIDING A BILL THAT
WOULD REINSTITUTE MENTAL
INSTITUTION. SO HOW WHAT'S YOUR
THOUGHTS ABOUT DOING SOMETHING
LIKE THAT BECAUSE AGAIN I'VE
BEEN DOING THIS FOR THE PAST SIX
YEARS SPEND I WOULD HOMELESS
PEOPLE AND I SAID THAT BEFORE
SUPERVISOR- YOU GOT HERE I SPEND
THE NIGHT WITH HOMELESS PEOPLE
EVERY YEAR I DIDN'T DO IT IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY BECAUSE OF THIS
PANDEMIC AND THEN I HAVE A GOD
SON WHO'S HOMELESS ON CRYSTAL
METH. BUT MY- SPEND IT I WOULD
HOMELESS PEOPLE HAVE UNCOVERED
THAT ARE PEOPLE WHO DON'T KNOW
RIGHT FROM WRONG WHO CAN'T MAKE
RATIONAL DECISIONS SO THEREFORE
THERE'S A RESPONSIBILITY ON THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO BECOME
CONSERVATIVES OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS HOW MANY PEOPLE DO
YOU THINK ABOUT NORM NUMBER
QUESTIONS THERE HOW MANY PEOPLE
DO YOU THINK ARE HAVE MENTAL
ILLNESS. BECAUSE WE CAN STILL
TALK ABOUT THE ISSUE BUT WE
CANNOT FORCE THEM INTO PERMANENT. OR TEMPORARY HOUSING IF THEY
DON'T WANT TO BECAUSE THESE IN.
ARE DOES I BASS A LOT OF THOUGH
TAKE A STAB AT IT- I JUST WANTED
PUTPROVIDE ONE COMMENT TO THAT
LAST PIECE AROUND MENTAL ILLNESS
AND I CAN'T TAKE THIS OUT AND I
MIGHT JUST JUMP IN AND ASK
EVERYBODY TO JUST STORE OWNER
COMMENTED IT'S MY FAULT OR
LITTLE BIT BEHIND THERE SO. I
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT SOMETIMES
I THINK TH QUESTION AROUND
MENTAL ILLNESS RESPONSES TO
MENTAL ILLNESS GET OVERWHELMED
BY THE QUESTION OF
CONSERVATORSHIP BECAUSE EVEN IF
WE CHANGE LAWS RUN
CONSERVATORSHIP IT WOULD REALLY
ONLY IMPACT A VERY SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF OUR PEOPLE WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING MENTAL ILLNESS OKAY
AND THAT'S THE REALITY OF WHAT
WE'RE DOING WHAT WE NEED IS MORE
RESOURCES TO SERVE THE MAJORITY
OF PEOPLE WHO ARE BOTH
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND
DEALING WITH MENTAL ILLNESS.
PEOPLE WHO ARE DEALING WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS BEFORE THEY
BECOME HOMELESS LIKE THAT'S
WHERE WE NEED TO DOLLARS WE
DON'T WANT PEOPLE TO GET SO SICK
WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT
CONSERVATORSHIP AND WE HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DO THAT AND THAT'S
WHERE I WANT TO FOCUS MY
CONVERSATION AND I IN RESPONSE
TO THAT TO THE TO YOUR QUESTION
AROUND HOW DO WE DESIGN PROGRAMS
THAT WORK- YOU KNOW I WANT TO
LEARN FROM THE OFFICE OF
DIVERSION AND REENTRY. THEY'VE
DONE A LOT OF WORK IN CREATING
COMMUNITY BASED CARE RESPONSES
IN L. A. COUNTY WHAT HAVE THEY
LEARNED LET'S TAKE THAT AND
APPLY IT AT THE STATE LEVEL
EXPAND THAT INVESTMENT AND MAKE
IT BETTER YOU KNOW. IF THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- COUNCILMEMBER UP
MENTAL HEALTH ILLNESS IS CAN BE
A COSTLY ITEM FOR ANY COUNTY OR
OR STATE AND WHAT I WOULD SAY TO
YOU IS THAT THERE'S A LOT OF
STRINGS ATTACHED TO ACUITY SO
YOU HAVE TO BE REALLY DEFELICE
SICK MENTALLY SICK BEFORE WE CAN
ACTUALLY PROVIDE YOU THE SPACE
THE BED AND ALL OF THAT WE HAVE
SO MANY PEOPLE RIGHT NOW THAT
NEED THE PREVENTION AND WE NEED
TO HAVE TWO PARALLELS ONE IS YES
MORE STABILIZED. REFORM AND
ASSISTANCE FOR MENTALLY HELD
THAT ARE EXTREMELY ACUTE AND
THEN YOU NEED THE OTHER MAYBE
TWO OTHER STAGES ONE IS WHERE
YOU CAN HELP DIED GIVE THEM A
DIAGNOSTIC ASSESSMENT BECAUSE
MANY OF THE PEOPLE ON THE STREET
AREN'T ALL MENTALLY ILL THEY
FACE TRAUMA RAPE HARASSMENT
DISCRIMINATION AND THEN A
CARCERAL SYSTEM THAT HAS NOT
BEEN GOOD FOR THEM AND SOMETIMES
OUR OWN INSTITUTIONS MAKE PEOPLE
POOR AND THEY END UP IN THE
STREET IN THAT MANNER SO WE HAVE
TO LOOK AT IT THROUGH DIFFERENT
LENSES AND I DO BELIEVE IT WOULD
BE WORTHWHILE FOR YOU ALL TO
SPEAK WITH OUR DEPARTMENT OF
MENTAL HEALTH DIRECTOR DR JOHN
SHARON. WHO HAS A LENGTHY OF
EXPERIENCE WORKING AT DIFFERENT
LEVELS ON HOW WE ADDRESS THIS
AND I WOULD SAY THAT WE DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH REIMBURSEMENT FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT RIGHT NOW
IF WE COULD SOMEHOW GET MEDICAID
MEDICARE MONEY IN TO HELP
REIMBURSE OUR TREATMENT FOR
MENTAL HEALTH EVEN IF IT'S TEAMS
GOING OUT ON THE STREET THAT
WILL HELP REDUCE COSTS BUT WE'RE
NOT DOING IT SO WE DO HAVE TO
GET THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
ENGAGED HERE THAT'S WHAT I WOULD
SAY TO YOU. AND THEN OVERALL I
THINK MAYBE HEIDI YOU CAN TALK
ABOUT I WOULD JUST SAY THREE
THINGS THAT COULD REALLY HELP
MOVE THE NEEDLE ONE OUT HERE IN
LA EVERY YEAR WE DO A GAP
ANALYSIS THAT LOOKS AT WHAT IS
THE POPULATION OF PEOPLE THAT
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WHAT
ARE THEIR NEEDS AND WHAT ARE THE
RESOURCES WE HAVE AVAILABLE AND
WHAT'S THE DELTA BETWEEN WHAT WE
HAVE AND WHAT WE NEED DOING OUT
OF THE STATE LIGHT WIDE LEVEL IS
SO NEEDED ACROSS THIS THEY TO
TELL. WHAT'S THE FUNDING THAT
WE'RE DOING WHAT IS OUR
POPULATION LOOK LIKE AND LET'S
IDENTIFY THE GAP BETWEEN. THAT
WILL HELP US FIGURE OUT THE COST
AND WHERE TO PUT THE COST. THE
SECOND PIECE THAT I THINK OFTEN
GETS LOST IN ALL THIS IS ALL OF
THE MONEY IN THE WORLD WON'T
RESOLVE THE ISSUE AND LESS WE
LOOK AT THE ADMINISTRATIVE
BARRIERS THAT WE PUT IN PLACE
AND HOW HARD WE MAKE IT FOR
PEOPLE. TO GET INTO HOUSING
ENOUGH NOT TO STATE IF SOCIAL
SECURITY IT DO IT IF ACROSS THE
BOARD. OKAY SO HOW DO WE BREAK
THROUGH TAT RED TAPE WHILE WE
INVEST IN THE RIGHT PROGRAM SO
WE REALLY BUILD THE MOMENTUM.
AND THEN THE THIRD PIECE IS
CONTROLLING THE AFFORDABILITY IN
THE ECONOMICS AT SCALE YOU KNOW
WE'RE IN THE US CAN YOU AFFORD A
TWO BEDROOM APARTMENT ON MINIMUM
WAGE. SO THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ISSUE THAT WE REALLY
NEED TO BE PUSHING ON SO THAT
WERE BRINGING THAT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ONLINE WHILE WE LOOK AT
TACKLING THE EXISTING CRISIS.
AND REMOVING THOSE BARRIERS AND
I'M GOING TO MOVE THE STUFF THE
LONG BEFORE WE START LOSING TO
SPEAKERS THAT WE SPENT. THE NEXT
COUPLE HOURS ON THIS BECAUSE
IT'S ROBUST LIKE. I THINK YOU
HAVE. BUT I WILL BE THE SECOND
PERSON PRIVILEGES WHICH WHICH
IS. ACTUALLY RIGHT IF WE HAD ALL
THE MONEY IN THE WORLD WE STILL.
AT THE RATE WE'RE GOING WE STILL
WANT SALAS WITH TALK ABOUT FROM
VICIOUS YOU WHAT WORKS AND WHAT
WE DID CUT- PI DISAGREE WITH YOU
THERE AT THE STATE LEVEL WE
COULD DO SOMETHING STATEWIDE
BECAUSE THE STAKES ARE SO BIG.
THEY GET THE FOCUS REGIONALLY.
ON ON ON SPOTS HERE. AND SOME OF
IT IS LAND USE DECISIONS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL WHAT IS YOUR LOS
ANGLES MAY MAYBE BETTER. IN
TERMS OF BUILDING HOUSING IS
STILL FAR FAR FAR BEYOND LACKS
ON AFFORDABLE HOUSING PRODUCTION
BUT IT'S ABOUT MODERATE RATE IF
I REMEMBER CORRECTLY AND ANSWER
YOU COULD CORRECT ME. BUT BUT I
THINK IT'S SEVEN FIVE THOUSAND
UNITS BUILT ABOVE MARKET RATE
WELL IT'S ONLY DEVELOP WHEN IT
WHEN IT HAS A DEFICIT OF THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND- UNITS BUILT ON
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THAT FIGHT
IN THE LOW IN. A LOW INCOME SO
THERE'S SOMETHING DETRIMENTALLY
WRONG WITH THAT PIECE TO THAT
BUT THE MORE DEVELOPING OUT OF
THE MORE YOU'RE PUSHING PEOPLE
INTO THE STREETS- BUT PATHETIC
BUT THAT EVEN. BUT EVEN. IS MUCH
BETTER THAN. THAN THE READ IN
TERMS HOUSING OR EVEN THIS. IN
TERMS OF HOUSING YEAH. SO
THERE'S A JOINT- RESPONSIBILITY
BOTH AT THE STATE AND LOCAL. BUT
THE STATE DOESN'T REALLY MAKE
LAND USE DECISIONS. WE LEGISLATE
ON BUT BUT- BUT WE DON'T HAVE
THE AUTHORITY TO NECESSARILY DO
THAT YOURSELF I THINK LOOK I I'D
LOVE TO WORK WITH YOU- I'M
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
RIGHT BALANCE IS TO TRY TO FIX
THAT. CAN BE ALMOST GO BACK THE
ORIGINAL THING THAT I SET- WHICH
IS ROLE. ROLE IN THIS TOGETHER
WITHOUT A FIGURE OUT THE BEST
WAY TO DO IT I REALLY
APPRECIATE. AND I REALLY DO MEAN
THAT THE VERY CANDID
CONVERSATION BACK AND FORTH.
ABOUT THIS. I VIOLATED MY OWN
THING ABOUT US IN THE COMMENTS
SO I'M GONNA GO HERE AND THEN
I'M GONNA MOVE THE NEXT. OKAY
WITH EVERYONE. I JUST GOT. JUST
BECAUSE I WANT TO SHARE A COUPLE
I THINK A QUICK OPTION BUT IT IS
OBVIOUS. IS THERE ANY. IS THERE
THERE'S A LOT OF PALS ARE GOING
AFTER THIS. DO YOU HAVE THE
ABILITY TO LET US GO TO THE
SECOND MORE AND BE HONEST WITH
YOUR- BILL. DO YOU. YEAH I'M
UNLESS I HEAR A THUMBS DOWN.
THIS IS NOT SET I'M GONNA GO
VERY QUICKLY AND IF THERE'S
ANYBODY LIKE TIME CONSTRAINTS ON
MOVE THEM AHEAD RIGHT SO GO
AHEAD BUT A COUPLE OF
OBSERVATIONS I THINK ARE
IMPORTANT FOR THE DISCUSSION
FIRST I JUST WANT TO SAY-
SUPERVISOR YOU CAN ASK MISTER
KRAFT- JUST TO THIS PLACE THE
OTHER DAY WE GIVEN. LAST NUMBER
YEARS MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR
PETS IT'S BEEN A BIG PROGRAM FOR
US IN THE STATE. SECOND ALL OF
THE SNOW. AND WE CAN'T IGNORE
THAT CONFIDENCE IN GOVERNMENT IS
EVERYTHING. PEOPLE WROTE CHECKS
OF THE CITY AND THE COUNTY LEVEL
BECAUSE THEY SOLVE PROBLEMS AND
THEY WANT TO DO TO FIX IT WE ARE
AT INFLECTION POINT FOR THE
PRESIDENT LIKES TO TALK ABOUT.
PEOPLE ARE SO ANGRY. IT'S THE
RATIONAL ISSUE. SO ALL OF THESE
EFFORTS ARE INTERESTING BUT I
THINK YOUR POINT ABOUT
ADMINISTRATIVE BARRIERS THE
POINT THAT YOU MADE IT YOU BUILD
SOMETHING FOR SIX MONTHS
DOWNTOWN FORTY SIX YEARS OF THE
CONTROLLER TALK ABOUT A
HAPPENING PEOPLE WILL NOT HAVE
PATIENCE FOR THAT CAN CRAFT WILL
TALK TO YOU ABOUT WHAT HE'S
DOING IN THE BALLOT TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND ALL IN A COPY BUILDING
STUFF IN NINETY DAYS. YOU KNOW
THESE KINDS OF DECISIONS IN THE
ARCHITECTURE OF OUR PUBLIC
POLICY DEBATE I HAVE TO BE
CRITICAL AND- COUNCILMEMBER
ROBERT LIKE TO KNOW FROM A DATA
PERSPECTIVE TAKING THE GUIDANCE
FROM US SECRETARY ELLEN YOU NOW
HAVE TAKEN THIS OUTREACH EFFORT
YOU'VE TAKEN PEOPLE FROM YOUR
STAFF TO REACH AND DO THIS STUFF
WHAT IS THE OUTCOME OF THAT HAVE
YOU IMPROVED THE IMPACT. YOU
KNOW CAN YOU SHARE IT WITH US
BECAUSE IF THAT'S THE CASE MAYBE
THOSE ARE TOOLS THAT WE COULD
ENGAGE IN TO FURTHER FUND WHAT
IS ACTUALLY BEEN THE IMPACT IF
YOU'VE DONE THE FOLLOW UP SO
THOSE THINGS ARE IMPORTANT.
ADMINISTRATIVE BARRIERS THERE'S
NO EXCUSES WON'T HAPPEN IF
PEOPLE HAVE THE PATIENCE. YOU
KNOW THANK YOU. AND THANK YOU
FOR A WORKING WITH US ON THIS I
KNOW THAT I'M RUNNING A LITTLE
BIT AND I'M AT FAULT BUT THIS IS
PROBABLY ONE OF THE MOST ROBUST
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD ON THIS
ISSUE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
PUTTING THIS TOGETHER. THANK
YOU. AND THANK YOU AND SO- I HAD
MENTIONED EARLIER ABOUT
COORDINATION AND BRINGING THINGS
TOGETHER. AND I'VE SEEN IT WORK.
I'VE SEEN IT WORK. BOB IN MY
DISTRICT ARE USE- SUPERVISOR
LISA MY STAFF. THAT THE S. J. S.
S. THE SO LEAST JONES SAWYER
STAFF. THEY WORK WELL TOGETHER
IN FACT. THE SUPERVISOR AND I
PROBABLY NEVER HAVE TO GET ON A
PHONE CALL. BECAUSE OUR STAFFS.
HANDLE THE PROBLEMS IN THE
DISTRICT. AND THEN. AND MAKE
SURE THAT THINGS GET DONE. THIS
SILO BEING THAT WE HAVE THAT YOU
ALL DOING MARVELOUS THINGS IN
YOUR PREFERRED RESPECTIVE SILOS
THE SUGGESTION I WANNA GIVE IS-
I'LL ALWAYS BELIEVE THAT ONE
PERSON NEEDS TO BE IN CHARGE
THERE IS NO ONE PERSON IN CHARGE
NO DISRESPECT TO LHASA BECAUSE I
REMEMBER WHY WE'RE FOR WRITTEN
WHEN THEY STARTED LASSEN THAT
WAS KIND OF THE IDEA AND WE
NEVER REALLY EMPOWER LHASA TO DO
THAT- AND SO WHETHER OR NOT. WE
HAVE SOME SKIN IN THE GAME
WHETHER OR NOT I KIND OF
DISAGREE WITH SOME OF MY
COLLEAGUES THAT THE STATE MAY
HAVE TO HAVE SOME SKIN IN THE
SKIN IN THE GAME MAY WE HAVE A
STATE HOMELESS CZAR THAT CAN
PULL TOGETHER ALL THE RESOURCES
IN THE INDIVIDUAL- COUNTIES AND
CITIES TO MAKE SURE IT GETS DONE
AND ADD ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES
AND SO IF THAT IS SOMETHING
YOU'RE INTERESTED IN THE ONLY
CAVEAT I WOULD GIVE YOU IS THAT
PERSON THAT WE PUT IN CHARGE
MIGHT LOOK A LOT LIKE BOB
HERTZBERG. SO BE CAREFUL WHAT
YOU WISH FOR. IT ON THE WHEN YOU
PLAY THE SUPER. WITH THE BUT
WHEN I WHEN I. WHEN I MET. DO
NOT IT AT THE STATE WIDE BASIS I
MEAN HAVING A POINT PERSON AS-
BASIS. BUT IT BUT NUMBERS AT A
STATEWIDE BASIS THE TELETHON
JUST MAKING THEM AROUND RIGHT.
YOU KNOW HUNDRED THIS HUNDRED
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE ARE HOMELESS
DOESN'T HELP DOESN'T HELP WITH
THE PAIN POINT TO KIND OF FOCUS
GROUPS YOU NEED. COULD ONLY
SOLVE HOMELESSNESS. ET OR HELP
PEOPLE IN THE IN THE SHELTER IN
AND I'VE WE'VE DONE IT OURSELVES
TO AN R. AND- IN THE OVERLAP
WITH OUR AREA. I DO AGREE WITH
MISS RAMAN THAT THAT YOU HAVE TO
PICK THAT HOT SPOT YOU HAVE TO
KEEP GOING BACK TO THAT HOT SPOT
THAT. CORNER THAT THAT CORNER
OFTEN OFFRAMP AND THEN YOU GET
THAT PROBLEM SOLVED BECAUSE YOUR
YOUR TAKES D. O. T. IT TAKES
CALTRANS IT TAKES. LHASA IT
TAKES THE CITY COORDINATION TEAM
TO TAKE THE STATE TO TAKE ALL
THESE ENTITIES. BUT IT'S ALL
THESE BOOTS ON THE GROUND THAT
THAT GO TO THAT ONE PARTICULAR
HOT SPOT AND THEN PEOPLE
ACTUALLY WILL WILL ACCEPT- THAT
THAT SORT OF HOUSING. WHICH IS A
DIFFERENT TO BE TO HAVE RIGHT
BECAUSE THEN WE SPENT. BUT TO
SAY THAT WE SPEND ALL THIS MONEY
WE HAVE ALL THESE PEOPLE WORKING
ON IT. AND THEN THE ONLY PEOPLE
WHO ARE HAVING RESULT OF THESE
PEOPLE WHO ARE ON THE CORNER
HELPING TO SOMEBODY GET OFF ON
THE FLOOR YOU GOTTA WONDER WHAT
US FOR THE REST OF THE STUFF IS
DOING RIGHT. OR HOW MUCH HAVE
HAS TO BE RE CHANGED TO RE DONE.
WHEN PEOPLE ON. THE BOOTS ON THE
GROUND ARE ACTUALLY HELPING PUT
THIS PERSON. IN THE HOUSING.
THAT WHAT THE REST OF THIS.
DOING THAT WE NEED EXAM
INCLUDING ON OUR SIDE. AND
THAT'S FAIR. THIS ORDER OF
LU<c.cyan>. SORRY AT THE END OF THE</c>
DAY. IT'S NOT LEGISLATION IS
IMPLEMENTATION. THAT'S OUR
PROBLEM. OR CERTAIN MISTER BUT
WHATEVER IT IS IT WHATEVER IT IS
THAT WE WANT TO CALL BUT YET-
ANYONE ELSE. I THOUGHT I SAW
YOUR HAND OKAY SO WE'RE GOING TO
KEEP MOVING FORWARD AND I WANT
TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH. BUT I
REALLY DO APPRECIATE THE ROBUST
CONVERSATION THANK YOU. AND I
APOLOGIZE TO EVERYBODY WHO WERE
RUNNING A LITTLE BIT LATE ON.
I'D ARE WE READY GO THE NEXT MR
HERE I'LL JUST APOLOGISE NOW I
HAVE TO LEAVE PROMPTLY AT TWELVE
THIRTY SO- I DON'T WANT TO
DISRUPT THAT LIBERALS. SURE
ENOUGH NOW WE HAVE A MISTER
SANTANA THE STRUGGLE AS A AND
THIS TURK AND MISTER CAN CRAFT
AND MISTER COULD YOU. ALSO TAKE
THE SECOND ITSELF A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE CENTER. THANK YOU.
AND- OKAY. IF THANK YOU SO MUCH. WHEN IT. AND MR SANTANA YOU
MAY BEGIN WHATEVER YOU EAT-
WHENEVER YOU'D LIKE INSIDE
RUSSIA EVERYBODY I. REPORTER
WELL YEAH WELL THAT'S WHY WE
BROUGHT HIM IN RIGHT I MEAN WE
BROUGHT HIM IN BECAUSE HE TO
REPORT THAT THAT- PROBABLY TO
GET THE ATTENTION IT SHOULD AND
SO THIS IS JUST A SPARK TO TRY
TO BRING THAT BACK UP TO
CONVERSATION I'M ASK YOU TO TAKE
A LOOK AT IT JUST TO SHOW WITH A
LITTLE BIT OF THAT GRAPH THAT
YOU THAT I'VE READ THROUGH ON
THE REPORT THAT YOU DID THAT
SHOWS SOMEWHERE BETWEEN TWELVE
AND- TEN ENTITIES GIVING. GIVING
DIRECTION TO LHASA. JUST HOLD UP
FOR WHEN YOU GO THROUGH THAT- I
ACTUALLY DON'T HAVE A- I HAVE A-
I HAVE A REPORTS BE DISTRIBUTED
TO ALL OF YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS ME GET SOME OF THAT- I'M
THE PRESIDENT AND CEO THE
WEINGART FOUNDATION. I ALSO
SERVED- MOST OF MY CAREER IN THE
PUBLIC SECTOR BOTH AT THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES AND THE COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES- I CHAIRED THE
COMMITTEE FOR GREATER LOS
ANGELES WHICH WAS A COMMITTEE
THAT WAS ESTABLISHED- DURING THE
PANDEMIC. TO LOOK AT OUR
SYSTEMIC ISSUES- IN A VARIETY OF
ISSUES. AND PROPOSE. A SYSTEMIC
SOLUTIONS TO ISSUES. THAT REALLY
BUT WERE EXPOSED DURING THIS
CRISIS. AND OBVIOUSLY THERE'S NO
GREATER ISSUE THAT MANIFESTS.
THAT SYSTEMIC FAILURES OF ALL OF
OUR SYSTEMS AND HOMELESSNESS.
THERE ARE THREE BASIC THINGS
THAT I WANTED TO SHARE TODAY AND
WIDELY IS HIGHLIGHTED IN THE
REPORT THAT ALL OF YOU HAVE AND-
I THOUGHT GUY- THERE WERE SIGNS
UP BUT I WANTED TO GIVE IT TO
YOU SO YOU COULD. ANSWER I.
ISAAC. WITH THE ASSISTANCE MIGHT
THE CARDIO. I THINK A LITTLE.
YOU KNOW I THINK WHAT YOU'RE
HEARING TODAY IS THAT THERE IS
AN UNPRECEDENTED AMOUNT OF
INVESTMENT OF A PASSION OF
COMMITMENT FROM EVERY ELECTED
OFFICIAL EVERY DEPARTMENT
RESPONSIBLE AND EVEN FROM LOCAL
RESIDENTS AND VOLUNTEERS. WE
HAVE NEVER SEEN THIS AMOUNT OF
ATTENTION AROUND THIS CRISIS.
VOTERS HAVE INVESTED BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN LOS ANGELES AND YET
THE QUESTION I GET ASKED ALL THE
TIME AS AS WELL AS YOU IS WHY IS
IT THAT THE PROBLEM LOOKS TO BE
GETTING WORSE. SO TO BE CLEAR
THERE ARE NO VILLAINS HERE.
THERE'S NOT SOMEONE WHO'S NOT
EXERCISING LEADERSHIP IT'S NOT
THAT WE'RE NOT INNOVATING IT'S
NOT THAT WE'RE NOT TRYING HARD.
IT'S THE FACT THAT ALL OF THESE
EFFORTS AS AS AS THE CHAIRMAN
POINTED OUT. ARE BEING DONE IN
ISOLATION. WOULD YOU HEARD TODAY
FROM- COUNCILWOMAN ROBIN ABOUT
HOW SHE- IS PERSONALLY IN CHARGE
OF FOR THE ENCAMPMENTS AND UNDER
DISTRICT. NOW WHEN SHE SIGNED UP
TO BE A COUNCILWOMAN I DON'T
THINK I DON'T THINK THAT THAT'S
WHAT SHE THOUGHT SHE WAS GOING
TO BE DOING. THAT SHE GETS TO
THAT SIDE WITCHING CAP MEN'S GET
GET DEALT WITH HOW THEY GET
DEALT WITH WHO SHE PARTNERS WITH
WHO GETS PRIORITIZED INTO THE
CAMP IT'S LITERALLY WHICH HUMAN
BEINGS GET SELECTED. HER STAFF
ARE PERSONALLY RESPONSIBLE FOR
PROVIDING AND COORDINATING ALL
OF THE SERVICES. AND SO WE HAVE
A SYSTEM THAT IS BEING LED BY
INDIVIDUALS WHO CARE A LOT. BUT
IS NOT BEING LED BY A SYSTEM WHO
THAT'S ACCOUNTABLE AND THAT'S IN
AND VERY IMPORTANT THING TO
EMPHASIZE. IT'S NOT THAT WE HAVE
A WE HAVE A BROKEN SYSTEM IS THE
FACT THAT WE DON'T HAVE A SYSTEM
. WE HAVE MULTIPLE SYSTEMS THAT
WORK IN THEIR OWN EFFORTS. WITH
AND THE RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN
ELECTED OFFICIALS ARE BETWEEN
AGENCIES IT'S WHAT WE GET THINGS
DONE BUT IT'S NOT DONE ON IT
INSTITUTIONAL BASIS. AND SO
DESPITE ALL OF OUR BEST THINKING
DESPITE THISIN ON PRESIDENT.
WE'RE NEVER GONNA BE ABLE TO
TURN THIS AROUND UNLESS THERE IS
SOME COORDINATED ACCOUNTABILITY.
NOT JUST TODAY BUT FOREVER.
HOMELESSNESS IS NOT A TEMPORARY
PROBLEM IT'S A FOR A FOREVER
PROBLEM. AND THEN I THINK ABOUT
THIS ISSUE HAVING WORKED ON IT
FOR MY ENTIRE CAREER. THAT WE
ARE HALFWAY THROUGH ULTIMATELY
WHAT THE SOLUTION IS. TAKE A
STEP BACK AND THINK ABOUT WHAT
IT MUST HAVE BEEN LIKE WHEN
THERE WAS AN IDEA THAT EVERY
PERSON SHOULD HAVE A RIGHT TO A
PUBLIC EDUCATION. ARE THERE WAS
AN IDEA AFTER HAVING A MASS
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM. IMAGINE
IF THOSE EFFORTS WERE DONE IN
SILOS IN THE WAY WE'RE DOING IT
NOW. IT TOOK AN INITIATIVE OF
THOSE VARIAS IDEA TO BRING
TOGETHER NOT ONLY THE RESOURCES
BUT THE COORDINATION THE ABILITY
TO IMPLEMENT EVALUATE AND
REENGAGE OVER AND OVER AND OVER
AGAIN AS WE TRY TO PERFECT A
SYSTEM. AND SO. AT THE CORE OF
WHAT THE COMMITTEE HAS DONE IS
PARTNERED WITH REYES
SONNENSCHEIN WHO OF COURSE RUNS
THE PAT BROWN INSTITUTE AND CAL
STATE LA. TO LOOK SQUARELY AT
THE ISSUE OF WHO'S IN CHARGE THE
QUESTION THAT'S BEEN ASKED BY
ALMOST EVERYONE OF YOU
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS. RAPE IS
NOT A HOMELESS EXPERT AND WE
SPECIFICALLY ASKED THEM TO LOOK
AT THIS BECAUSE HE'S A
GOVERNANCE EXPERT. HE'S
ESTABLISHED THE ALLEY CHARTER HE
WE HE HAS READ BOOKS ABOUT
GOVERNANCE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AND HE SPEAKS ABOUT
IT ON A REGULAR BASIS THERE WILL
COULDN'T BE A BETTER PERSON. AND
WHAT HE PROPOSES AND I AGREE IS
THAT WE NEED TO HAVE A SYSTEM
OUTSIDE OF THE SYSTEMS. HE
ACTUALLY PROPOSED THAT THERE NOT
BE GOVERNMENT. AND THE REASON
WHY HE PROPOSES AND NOT BE
GOVERNMENT IS BECAUSE WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT CREATING ANOTHER
GOVERNMENT BUREAUCRACY. IT'S
ABOUT TAKING AWAY POWER AND AS
EVERYONE KNOWS TAKEN AWAY POWER
IS VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE. WHAT
NEEDS TO HAPPEN IS A COORDINATED
SYSTEM WHERE TOGETHER WE ARE
IDENTIFYING WHAT ARE THE
SYSTEMIC ISSUES AND WORK ON THEM
ON A ON GOING BASIS. FOR EXAMPLE
THE ISSUE OF HOUSING THAT WE
HEARD TODAY FROM THE CONTROLLER
AND FROM ANSEL WHO RUNS THE
HOUSING DEPARTMENT. THE
CONTROLLERS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
THERE'S NOTHING THAT HE SAID
THAT WAS INACCURATE ABOUT THE
COST THE TIME THAT IT TAKES AND
THE EFFORT TO BUILD PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING. BUT IT WAS
DESIGNED THAT WAY IT'S IT WASN'T
LIKE IT WAS A MISTAKE OR THERE'S
A GOTCHA IT WAS ACTUALLY
DESIGNED AND IT'S WORKING
EXACTLY AS IT WAS INTENDED.
HOUSE PERMITTED SUPPORT OF
HOUSING IS A COMPLICATED LAYER
OF THE FUNDING STREAMS EACH WITH
THEIR OWN PRIORITIES THEIR OWN
THE TIME FRAMES THEIR OWN
EXPECTATIONS. AND THE NONPROFIT
DEVELOPERS ARE AT THE WHIM OF
THOSE FUNDING STREAMS AND I HAVE
TO WAIT AND ACCOMMODATE THEM
BASED ON AN OBJECTIVE OF
BUILDING HOUSING. PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING ISN'T PUT IN
THE FRONT OF THE LINE ON
DEVELOPMENT. AND SO THE TIME
IT'S TAKING IT IS EXACTLY WHAT
WE THOUGHT IT WOULD TAKE. THE
QUESTION IS WHETHER THAT'S
ACCEPTABLE AND I THINK ANGELENOS
AND CLEARLY ALL OF YOU ARE
SAYING THAT IT'S NOT. SO IT'S
NOT GOOD ENOUGH JUST TO
CRITICIZE AND SAY WELL IT'S NOT
WORKING THE QUESTION IS HOW ARE
WE GOING TO FIX IT. AND THERE
ISN'T A PLACE OUTSIDE MAYBE
TODAY THERE'S A CONVERSATION BUT
THERE ISN'T A PLACE TODAY IT
ANYWHERE LOS ANGELES WORK
PEOPLE'S JOB IT IS TO FIGURE
THAT QUESTION NOW. HOW DO YOU
ACTUALLY BUILD AT THE SCALE THAT
WE NEED. AT THE TIME FRAME THAT
WE NEED AT THE MAGNITUDE THAT WE
NEED THE QUESTION THAT WAS ASKED
HOW MUCH MONEY DO WE NEED NO ONE
COULD GIVE YOU THE ANSWER TO
THAT. WHAT IS IT ACTUALLY GOING
TO TAKE ANA OUTREACH LEVEL WHAT
KIND OF BED SHOULD THEY BE. ALL
OF THAT IS PART OF IT SO. SO FOR
US. IT'S BEFORE WE THINK ABOUT
YET ONE MORE FUNDING STREAM WHAT
MORE PROGRAM OR INTERVENTION. I
THINK THE ROLE OF THE STATE. IS
TO ASK THE QUESTION WHO'S
ACCOUNTABLE ON A COORDINATED
BASIS. AND I AGREE WITH THE LAST
CONVERSATION THE STATE IS NOT AS
AN OBSERVER. THE STATE HAS TO BE
IN THAT PROCESS AS WELL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THAT IF YOU HAVEN'T
HAD A CHANCE TO REALLY DIG INTO
THE REPORT THAT THAT THAT WAS
DONE TO YOU. I RECOMMENDED IT'S
GOOD READING BECAUSE THERE IS IT
IS INSTRUCTIVE IF YOU PUT THAT
CHART OUT WARMER TIMES BIRTH.
THIS IS WHO INFLUENCES LOS US SO
IF YOU COULD TRY TO FIGURE OUT.
HOW LOSS TO TAKE THE REPORT AND
I'M ACTED ON THAT RIGHT YES SO
YOU HAVE ALL THOSE ENTITIES AND
ALL THOSE DIFFERENT PEOPLE WHO
ARE IN ELECTED OFFICE WHO. GIVE
DIRECTIONAL ALSO. SO WE'RE GONNA
GO TO MISS- LEE ROGERS AND THANK
YOU FOR HAVING US HERE IN YOUR
HEART. OKAY IT'S OKAY I YOU
WANT TO GO A DIFFERENT IN A
DIFFERENT ORDER THAT'S FINE. I'M
COMPLETELY OKAY WITH HOW
EVERYONE YOU YEAH. HELLO
EVERYONE AND THANK YOU. ASSEMBLY
MAN. SANTIAGO FOR THE INVITE AND
FOR ALLOWING THIS FORUM AND ALL
OF YOU TO OPEN A HAVE AN OPEN
DISCUSSION ABOUT WHAT YOU KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON. I DON'T WANT TO
REPEAT ANYTHING THAT'S ALREADY
BEEN DISCUSSED BECAUSE IT'S BEEN
SUCH RICH MATERIAL ON THE
PREVIOUS PANELS- WHAT I DO WANT
TO DO IS. SUPPORT AND OFFER
PERSPECTIVE AS THE ON THE GROUND
DEVELOPER AND AS OF THE ON THE
GROUND- OPERATOR. AND REALLY
JUST BRING HOME THE POINT OF-
SUPPORTING SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT WERE BROUGHT UP BUT ALSO
CALLING ATTENTION TO SOME OF THE
ON GOING RESOURCES THAT THAT WE
MIGHT NEED- VERY MUCH LOOKING
FORWARD I THINK WE ALL ARE
LOOKING FORWARD TO PROBABLY THE
QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE BECAUSE-
WE ARE THE- WE ARE THE BOOTS ON
THE GROUND AND WE HAVE THE DIRT
ON THE BOOTS. SO WE CAN
ABSOLUTELY YOU KNOW MAKE SURE
THAT THAT WE SHARE INFORMATION
WITH YOU- FROM THE SKID ROW
HOUSING TRUST PERSPECTIVE ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I DEFINITELY
WANT TO SAY IS YOU KNOW. WE DO
HAVE ACTUAL PROJECTS THAT WERE
IMPLEMENTED LAST YEAR AND THIS
YEAR SO WE SUCCESSFULLY BUILT.
THREE PROPERTIES AND ONE CLINIC
IN SKID ROW. SO IT'S REAL IT'S
TANGIBLE YOU KNOW IT'S TACTICAL
YOU CAN SEE IT AND WE HAVE
RESIDENTS LIVING THERE AND THERE
ARE CLIENTS THAT ARE BEING
SERVED BY THE JOSH WAREHOUSE- AT
THE CLINIC THAT WAS PART OF OUR
SIX FOUR NINE LAW. PROGRAM I DO
WANT TO ECHO EVERYTHING THAT WAS
SAID BEFORE YOU KNOW THAT WERE
THE RECIPIENTS OF THE LACK OF
THE COORDINATION. SO IF YOU SEE
THE BUBBLES THAT MIGUEL SANTANA
HAD AND YOU HEAR THE PREVIOUS.
PANELS THAT SAID THERE'S SEVEN
DIFFERENT OF ENTITIES IN THE
STACK THERE'S FOURTEEN DIFFERENT
GOVERNING AGENCIES WE ALL SIT
AND HAVE TO ANSWER FOR ALL OF
THEM. SO THERE'S TEN QUESTIONS
TO TEN ENTITIES THERE'S ONE
HUNDRED ITEMS THAT WE REPORT TO
ONE A MONTH OVER MONTH BASIS.
IT'S REALLY OVERWHELMING
PARTICULARLY FROM A NONPROFIT
PERSPECTIVE AND MANY OF US YOU
KNOW- AND THE CROWD HAVE A
BACKGROUND THAT KNOWS HOW TO
MANAGE THAT. BUT ITS FINANCIAL
MANAGEMENT ITS OPERATIONAL
MANAGEMENT AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
IT'S HUMANISTIC MANAGEMENT AND I
THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE REALLY WANT TO FOCUS ON-
THE- ONE OF THE THINGS THAT. I
DO WANT TO CALL ATTENTION TO
THAT WAS THAT WAS MENTIONED
EARLIER WAS THE COORDINATION OF
THE SYSTEM AS IT RELATES TO.
THERE'S A UNIT PRODUCTION. THEIR
SUBSIDY IN VOUCHER PRODUCTION
THERE'S CASE MANAGEMENT
PRODUCTION AND THERE'S MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES REQUIREMENTS AND
SOMETIMES THAT MATH DOESN'T ADD
UP. AND THAT WOULD BE. I THINK
VERY MUCH APPRECIATED OU KNOW
BY OUR ORGANIZATION
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE OURS THAT IF
THERE IS A CENTRALIZED STRUCTURE
OF A CORDON COORDINATED ATTEMPT
AND GUIDANCE WE COULD ALL KIND
OF RALLY TOGETHER. AND MAKE
PROGRESS FASTER SO I DO THINK
THAT- WE WANT TO ECHO THAT IN
AND SHOW SUPPORT FOR THAT. ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE WANTED TO
CALL OUT IS THERE THERE IS AN
INCREASE IN OPERATING COSTS
OVERALL WHETHER IT'S PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING OR SHELTER OR
AFFORDABLE. WHEN YOU HAVE
INDIVIDUALS THAT HAVE BEEN
LIVING ON THE STREET WHETHER
IT'S TWO WEEKS OR TWO YEARS AND
THEY HAVE- EXPERIENCE TRAUMA AND
VERY YOU KNOW DESTITUTE AND IN
HORRIBLE CIRCUMSTANCES. THEY
HAVE TO TRANSITION FROM LIVING
ON THE STREETS TO LIVING IN A
HOME AND THERE'S SOME CARE
THAT'S REQUIRED FOR THAT THEIR
SERVICES THAT ARE REQUIRED FOR
THAT. SO IT WOULD BE GREAT TO
FOCUS ON THOSE OPERATING COSTS
BECAUSE THOSE OPERATING COSTS IF
THEY ARE IMPLEMENTED ON A UNIT
BY UNIT PERSON BY PERSON BASIS
YOU WON'T SEE THESE BACK AN
ASTRONOMICAL COSTS BECAUSE WE
IGNORED PROBLEM AS IT WAS
ESCALATING- SAFETY OVERALL.
DON'T NEED TO POINT TO THAT BUT
YOU KNOW THE SAFETY OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE LIVING IN
ENCAMPMENTS THING THEY NEED TO
BE FOCUSED ON RESIDENTS IN THE
UNITS THEIR SAFETY NEEDS TO BE
FOCUSED ON THE EMPLOYEES THE
LITERAL BOOTS ON THE GROUND THE
CASE MANAGERS THE OUTREACH
WORKERS THEY ARE WORKING UNDER
EXTRAORDINARY CIRCUMSTANCES TO
WHEN THEY NEED TO BE
INCENTIVIZED TO CONTINUE THAT
WORK AND THEY NEED TO BE
PROTECTED AS WELL SO THERE
REALLY NEEDS TO BE A FOCUSED ON
ON THAT. ALSO I DO I DON'T KNOW
HOW WAS ARTICULATED EARLIER BUT
- I'LL I'LL TRANSLATE IT THE WAY
I INTERPRET IT IS YOU KNOW THE
PUBLIC SUPPORT OR PERCEPTION OF
SUPPORT OFTENTIMES AS A
DEVELOPER AND THE OWNER AND THE
OPERATOR MANY YOU KNOW VOTERS
AND INDIVIDUALS AND RIGHTFULLY
SO THEY COME TO US IN THERE SAY
WHY ARE YOU DEVELOPING FASTER WE
HAVE TO TAKE THAT FRONT LINE
QUESTIONING. YOU KNOW IT'S VERY
UNFORGIVING AT TIMES YOU KNOW
THEY DON'T HAVE ANYWHERE ELSE TO
GO SO THEY COME TO ALL OF US AND
THE PRESSURE NOT THAT WE SHY
AWAY FROM IT BUT IT IS ENORMOUS
AND WE WOULD LIKE SUPPORT A
LITTLE BIT ON THAT BECAUSE AS WE
ALL HEARD TODAY IT'S VERY VERY
COMPLICATED. AND SIMPLIFYING IT
AND COMMUNICATING WHICH I
ACTUALLY THINK LOS ANGELES IS A
FABULOUS JOB IN IS THE ATTEMPT
TO COMMUNICATE IN THE ATTEMPT TO
EDUCATE- I DO WANT TO GET
DEFINITELY HIGHLIGHT MIGUEL
SANTIAGO AND MIGUEL SANTANA
BECAUSE NOT DID YOU JUST PUT
YOUR KIND OF YOUR MONEY WHERE
YOUR MOUTH WAS FOR US YOU PUT
YOUR FEET ON OUR FLOORS TWO YOU
KNOW AND THAT AND THAT'S A LOT
YOU KNOW THAT TAKES A LOT OF
TIME AND EFFORT TO DO THAT SO
APPRECIATE THAT- IN MY- SCREEN
WENT BLANK SO SORRY NOW I JUST
HAVE TO- AND- I THINK JUST. HOW
CAN WE ALL FACILITATE THE SLIDE
INTO HOMELESSNESS THERE'S NO
EASY ANSWER BUT- I WILL I THINK
THAT ALL OF US WOULD SAY WE
WOULD LOVE TO PARTICIPATE IN A
STATE COUNTY CITY LOCAL. YOU
KNOW- COMMITTEE STRUCTURE
WHATEVER IT IS TO SAY WHAT WHAT
IS SLIDING INTO HOMELESSNESS AND
HOW CAN WE STOP THAT AS A
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
DEVELOPER. THE MATH DOESN'T WORK
WE CAN'T DEVELOP FAST ENOUGH OUT
OF THIS WE WANT TO KEEP
DEVELOPING THOSE UNITS AS A LONG
TERM SOLUTION. BUT WE REALLY
HAVE TO FOCUS OUR EFFORTS ON
MAKING SURE THAT SLIDE DOESN'T
HAPPEN IN THE FIRST PLACE. THAT
MENTAL WELLNESS IS ABSOLUTELY
PRIORITIZE AND FOCUS ON SO THAT
WE CAN MAKE SURE THERE'S A FULL
SPECTRUM SOLUTION. THOUGHT THAT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND- I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THAT
WE LOOK FORWARD TO THE POLICY
PROPOSALS THAT HELP TO
FACILITATE MOVE THAT QUICKER-
THANK YOU. MISTER FOR HAVING US
HERE TODAY. AT THE DOWNTOWN
WOMEN'S CENTER WE REALLY
APPRECIATED AND- WE'RE HONORED
TO BE HERE THANK YOU THIS IS
ALSO FACILITY THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON TEAR SANTIAGO AN
HONORABLE MEMBERS I HAD MY
NAME'S AMY TURK THE CEO OF
DOWNTOWN WOMEN'S CENTER AND
WE'RE JUST SO HONORED TO BE
HOSTING THIS HEARING TODAY WE'RE
HERE WITH. OUR FABULOUS BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OUR STAFF SEVENTY ONE
RESIDENTS AND THE WOMEN WHO COME
TO OUR ACCESS CENTER- POSTING
YOU HERE TODAY AND THANK YOU FOR
COMING. I LOOK FORWARD TO
SHARING A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
DOWNTOWN WOMEN'S CENTER THE
EXPERIENCES OF HOMELESSNESS
AMONG WOMEN. AND AS YOU ASKED
WHAT DOES NOT WORK IN TERMS OF
ENDING HOMELESSNESS ESPECIALLY
FOR THIS POPULATION. IN OFFERING
TO SOLUTIONS RELATED TO PROGRAMS
AND LEGISLATION THAT OUR SCALE
SCALEABLE WITH ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES. AT DOWNTOWN WOMEN'S
CENTER IS THE ONLY ORGANIZATION
EXCLUSIVELY DEDICATED TO ENDING
HOMELESSNESS FOR WOMEN IN LOS
ANGELES WE'VE BEEN A MEMBER OF
THE SKID ROW COMMUNITY FOR OVER
FORTY THREE YEARS. AND EVERY
YEAR WE SERVE AROUND FIVE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED WOMEN WITH
THE FULL CONTINUUM OF SERVICES.
WE WERE THE NATION'S FIRST
PROVIDER OF PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING WE'VE LONG ADVOCATED
THAT PERMANENT HOUSING SOLUTIONS
COUPLED WITH NECESSARY SUPPORT.
IN THE CYCLE OF HOMELESSNESS AND
WE BACK THAT UP WITH THE SECTOR
LEADING 98% HOUSING RETENTION
RATE. WE OWN AND OPERATE TWO
BUILDINGS ONE THAT YOU'RE AT
TODAY. AT THE HOUSE A HUNDRED IN
NINETEEN WOMEN WE ALSO SUPPORT
SEVEN HUNDRED WOMEN AND FAMILIES
THROUGHOUT LOS ANGELES COUNTY
THROUGH PROGRAMS THAT WORK. LIKE
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
SERVICES HOUSING FOR HEALTH
PROGRAM. RAPID RE HOUSING AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE HOUSING FIRST
PROGRAMS. AS A RESULT OF KOBE
DOWNTOWN WOMEN'S CENTER SERVED
TWO HUNDRED AND TWELVE WOMEN IN
A PROJECT ROOM KEY. ONE OF
WHATEVER AREAS FOR GROWTH IS IN
THE CREATION OF NEW PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING WE WILL BE
THE SERVICE PROVIDER IN SIX NEW
BUILDINGS FROM VAN NUYS TO
MONTEBELLO. TO HOUSE AN
ADDITIONAL TWO HUNDRED FORTY
EIGHT TO MYSTIC VIOLENCE
SURVIVORS A NEW PERMANENT
HOUSING ONE OF THOSE BUILDINGS
WILL BE HERE ON THE PARKING LOT
THE HOPEFULLY YOU GOT A PARKING
SPOT. ON TODAY AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO INVITING YOU TO MANY
GROUND BREAKING THING MANY GRAND
OPENING. UNFORTUNATELY THOUGH
OVER THE LAST DECADE THE NUMBER
OF WOMEN EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS IN LA HAS NEARLY
DOUBLED OUTPACING THE RATE OF
MEN. WOMEN NOW MAKE UP 38% OF ON
HOUSING ANGELENOS. FOR FAR TOO
LONG AND IN PARTICULAR
UNACCOMPANIED WOMEN WHO ARE EX
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
WITHOUT DEPENDENCE AND YOU ARE
IN ELIGIBLE FOR FAMILY DESIGN
PROGRAMS. HAVE BEEN LARGELY
INVISIBLE TO POLICYMAKERS.
UNACCOMPANIED WOMEN WHO MAKE UP
NEARLY TWO THIRDS OF LOS ANGELES
ON HOUSE FEMALE POPULATION FOR
DISPROPORTIONATELY BLACK. WAIT
ON AVERAGE TEN PLUS YEARS TAXES
STABLE HOUSING AT A RATE DOUBLE
THAT AMEND. IT IS NOT MORE
PROFOUND TODAY WITH THE RAIN.
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THAT DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND GENDER BASED
VIOLENCE IS THE MAIN DRIVER INTO
HOMELESSNESS FOR WOMEN HOUSING
ARE UNSHELTERED NEIGHBORS IS A
CRITICAL GENDER EQUITY ISSUE.
YOU'VE ASKED US TO SPEAK ON WHAT
DOES NOT HELP WHAT DOES NOT HELP
IS CRIMINALIZING POVERTY AND
QUOTE SURVIVORS OF SERVICE-
CRIMES OF SURVIVAL SUCH AS SEX
WORK OR EVEN JUST SLEEPING
OUTDOORS. PROVIDING AN ADEQUATE
ACCESS TO EVERYTHING FROM BASIC
HYGIENE TO MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES NOT OFFERING PATHWAYS
TO PERMANENT HOUSING AND
CONTINUING TO UNDER INVEST
PARTICULARLY IN SERVICES FOR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE SURVIVORS. I
BELIEVE HERE THAT WHAT WE DO A
DOWNTOWN WOMEN'S CENTER OFFERS A
CLEAR AND REPLICABLE MODEL OF
WHAT DOES WORK. ONE MAJOR RECENT
EXAMPLE THIS PAST SUMMER
DOWNTOWN WOMEN'S CENTER DEVELOP
TO THE EVERYWOMAN HOUSE ACTION
PLAN. THIS IS TO END
HOMELESSNESS TO THE SIX HUNDRED
UNSHELTERED WOMEN WHO RESIDE IN
THE SKID ROW COMMUNITY. AND
THANKS TO OUR LEADERSHIP OF
SUPERVISORS POLICE IN MITCHELL
IN COLLABORATION WITH COUNTY
DEPARTMENTS LHASA IN PARTNERS
LIKE SKID ROW HOUSING TRUST. WE
ARE BEGINNING TO IMPLEMENT THIS
PLAN. KEY INGREDIENTS ARE THE
USE OF HOTELS FOR INTERIM
HOUSING AND A NEW COUNTY PROGRAM
RUN BY LHASA AND PATH. CALLED
THE RESIDENT AND PROPERTY
SUPPORT SERVICES. THIS HEALTH
MASTER LEASE BUILDINGS WHERE WE
CAN QUICKLY MOVE IN LARGE
AMOUNTS OF PEOPLE. ADDITIONALLY
WHILE THE DOWNTOWN WOMEN'S
CENTER AUTHORED STATE BILL SIX
SEVEN EIGHT UNACCOMPANIED WOMEN
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS ACTIVE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WAS HELD IN A
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS. I AM
PLEASED TO ANNOUNCE THE DOWNTOWN
WOMEN'S CENTER HAS CO AUTHORED
LEGISLATION WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNERSHIP TO END DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE WHICH WE HOPE TO
INTRODUCE IN JANUARY TO INCREASE
SUPPORT FOR DOMESTIC DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SURVIVORS. AND WOMEN.
AS YOU KNOW WITH THE SUSTAINED
COMMITMENT TO ATTACKING THE ROOT
CAUSES OF HOMELESSNESS
PARTICULARLY RACIAL AND GENDER
INEQUITIES. ENHANCING REGIONAL
COLLABORATION INVESTING IN BEST
PRACTICES INTER MAGICALLY
EXPANDING THE SUPPLY OF HOUSING
WE CAN'T ENVISION A LOS ANGELES
COUNTY WITH EVERYONE IN HOUSE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
PRESENTATION AND I KNOW YOU HAVE
YOUR BOARD CHAIR HERE TO YOU
WANTED TO DO SIR YES WE HAVE
LISTED FOR- HERE TO SHARE WITH
VICKI CURRY AND WE HAVE JUST
CAMANCHE CREA. HERE'S WHAT OKAY
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY.
THE AMAZING WORK THAT YOU DO.
ALL YOUR SIR OKAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH ASSEMBLY MEN AND COULD BE
HERE MONIES CAN CRAFT. I'M THE
FOUNDER AND CEO AT HOPE OF THE
VALLEY RESCUE MISSION. IS A Q.
WEEKS AGO ACTUALLY COUPLE MONTHS
AGO NOW THAT JEFFREY KATZENBERG
FROM DREAMWORKS CAME AND WANTED
TO OUR ONE OF OUR TINY HOME
FACILITIES. AT THE END OF IT HE
SAID. BUT YOU WANNA KNOW WHY I'M
HERE I SAID YEAH I REALLY DO. HE
SAID. BECAUSE I THINK THE VOTERS
ARE FED UP. HE SAID WE'VE PASSED
THESE BOND MEASURES AND YET WE
STILL SEE SO MANY CANNONS
INCREASE OF PEOPLE ON THE
STREETS HE SAYS I'M AFRAID FOR
YOU. I SO WHAT DO YOU MEAN. IS
I'M AFRAID YOU'RE GONNA NEED
MORE MONEY. AND THE VOTERS ARE
GOING TO GIVE IT TO YOU. AND HE
SAID WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
GETTING PEOPLE OFF THE STREETS
WHILE WE CONTINUE TO BUILD
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT THAT I
FIRMLY BELIEVE IN. WE KNOW THAT
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. IS WHERE
WE'RE GOING WHERE IT HAS TO END
WE HAVE TO GET PEOPLE THERE BUT
IN THE MEANTIME IN THE MEANTIME
THE STREETS CANNOT BE THE
WAITING ROOM FOR PERMANENT
HOUSING AS IS VINCE ALREADY SAID
MUCH MORE ELOQUENT THAN I COULD
SAY IT'S YES AND- WE NEED BOTH.
AND THE ABILITY TO BRING PEOPLE
INSIDE QUICKLY. I OFTEN THINK
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN GOD FORBID IF
THERE WAS AN EARTHQUAKE TONIGHT
. AND WE WOKE UP THE NEXT
MORNING IN ALL THESE BUILDINGS
WERE RED TAGGED IN AND WE HAD
SIXTY THOUSAND PEOPLE THAT WERE
HOMELESS IN OUR GREAT CITY. THE
NATIONAL GUARD WOULD BE HERE IN
MINUTES THE RED CROSS TO BE
MOBILIZED WE WOULD MAKE SURE
THAT OUR BROTHERS AND SISTERS
DID NOT HAVE TO LIVE
UNSHELTERED. ONE NIGHT. AND YET
HOW MANY YEARS HAVE WE SAID
WHILE THIS IS A REAL CRISIS
WE'RE FACING. HOMELESSNESS WHILE
IT'S TERRIBLE AND YET WE HAVE
NOT HAD A FEMA LIKE RESPONSE. IN
TWENTY TWENTY WE HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF OPENING TO LARGE
CONGREGANT SHELTERS ONE IN NORTH
HOLLYWOOD AND ONE IN VAN NUYS
ONE EIGHTY FIVE BEDS ONE HUNDRED
BEDS. THE NEXT YEAR WE HAD THE
PRIVILEGE IN THIS IS ALL WORKING
WITH LASSA WORKING WITH LOCAL
COUNCIL MEMBERS IN ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS AND SENATE. MEMBERS AND
WE WERE ABLE TO OPEN UP. SIX
TINY HOME COMMUNITIES. THE VERY
FIRST TINY HOME COMMUNITY LOS
ANGELES WAS ON CHANDLER
BOULEVARD IN NORTH HOLLYWOOD. IN
THE LAST ONE WHICH IS OPENED
HERE IN COUNCIL DISTRICT
FOURTEEN COUNCILMAN KIM DAILY ON
AND I KNOW WE HAD THE PRIVILEGE
OF A NUMBER OF US ACTUALLY
SPENDING THE NIGHT IN THOSE TINY
HOMES WHAT IS IT LIKE. AND IT
THE INITIAL COSTS WERE QUITE
HIGH BECAUSE THE FIRST PROJECT
WAS ACTUALLY THE DEVELOPMENT OF
RAW DIRT WHERE THERE IS NO SEWER
LINES NO WATER LINES NO GAS
LINES AND THEY POURED CONCRETE
PADS AND IT WAS QUITE EXPENSIVE
BUT I'M PROUD TO SAY THE LAST
ONE THAT WAS JUST OPEN AND
COUNCILS TO FOURTEEN THE AVERAGE
COST PER UNIT WAS AROUND FORTY
TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS. AND THOSE
TINY HOME UNITS AND I'M I'M NOT
HERE TO ADVOCATE FOR PALLET
SHELTER OR ANY OTHER TIME YOU I
DON'T CARE WHAT THEY LOOK LIKE.
WHAT I DO CARE ABOUT IS WE GET
PEOPLE INDOORS BECAUSE THE
LONGER PEOPLE STAY OUTSIDE THE
MORE THEY DETERIORATE MENTALLY
PHYSICALLY EMOTIONALLY AND SO
WE'VE GOT TO BRING PEOPLE
INSIDE. I MEAN TELLING PEOPLE TO
STAY ON THE STREETS TO WE CAN
BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING MAKES
AS MUCH SENSE AS ME HAVING
HYPOTHERMIA AND SAYING CAN WAIT
IN THE SNOW INTO THE DOCTOR CAN
SEE YOU. WE WOULDN'T DO THAT.
AND SO WE HAVE TO BE HUMANE WE
HAVE TO ACT WITH A SENSE OF
URGENCY. AND SO. ONE OF THE
THINGS I'VE REALIZED AND AS A
SERVICE PROVIDER WE'RE VERY
LIMITED IN WHAT WE CAN AND CAN'T
DO. BUT GOVERNMENT YOU'VE GOT A
LOT OF LEVERS YOU CAN PULL. I
MEAN THERE'S WAYS TO INCREASE
REVENUE THERE'S WAYS TO CUT
EXPENSES THERE'S WAYS TO MAKE
THINGS HAPPEN AND SO I GOTTA
TELL YA. I'M VERY OPTIMISTIC WHY
. BECAUSE AT THE OPENING OF THE
LAST. TINY HOME COMMUNITY AT
LEAST IN COUNCIL PARKER KOREANS
DISTRICT I WAS THERE WHEN HE-
AND THE MAYOR OF LOS ANGELES
ERIC GARCETTI. WHEN PAUL
KRIKORIAN PROBABLY PROCLAIM HE
SAID I NOW HAVE BEDS FOR EVERY
BODY THAT IS ST HOMELESS IN MY
COUNCIL DISTRICT. WOW HOW MANY
COUNCIL MEMBERS COULD SAY THAT
AT LEAST OR WANT TO SAY THAT BUT
I ALSO KNOW HE WAS A VERY
AGGRESSIVE IN MAKING SURE
FINDING WHAT LANDS AVAILABLE
WHAT CAN WHAT CAN YOU DO. AND I
WE ALL NEED TO HAVE THAT SENSE
OF URGENCY AND I KNOW THERE'S
CAL AYE WE WORK WITH COUNT ALL
THE COUNCIL MEMBERS YOU KNOW IN
IN THE IN THAT AREA AND I'M SO
THANKFUL FOR EACH ONE AND THAT.
SOMETIMES IT'S DARKEST BEFORE
THE DAWN. BUT WE CAN'T GIVE UP
AND ON THE STATE LEVEL AND IS SO
MUCH THAT CAN BE DONE ON A CITY
LEVEL AND COUNTY LEVEL ON A
FEDERAL LEVEL AND- YOU KNOW
WHO'S THIS JUSTICE JUST FOR
PERSPECTIVE. IN TWENTY TWENTY
HOPE OF THE VALLEY WE FINISHED
WITH SEVEN SHELTERS FIVE HUNDRED
SEVEN BEDS ONCE WE GET THE
TREBEK'S CENTER OPEN WHICH WOULD
BE A NUMBER OF MONTHS WE WILL
HAVE SIXTEEN HOMELESS SHELTERS
ONE THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY
TWO BEDS. THAT NEVER COULD
HAPPEN IF IT WASN'T FOR THE
SUPPORT OF OUR CITY OUR COUNTY
AND OUR STATE AND OUR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS ALL OF US WORKING
TOGETHER AND SO I'M ENCOURAGED
LET'S KEEP WORKING TOGETHER. AND
WITH LET'S A LET'S MAKE A
DIFFERENCE. THANK YOU MISTER
KRAFT VERY MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR
AND- YOU BEING HERE AND-
GRATEFUL THAT YOU GAVE ME THE
OPPORTUNITY. THIS SLEEPER TITLE.
THANKS FOR THE MEASURE
EXPERIENCE AND- I THOUGHT
SOMEBODY HASN'T HAD THE CHANCE
TO DO IT I RECOMMEND THAT YOU
DO- BECAUSE IT IS AN
ALTERNATIVE- THAT ALSO WORKS A
VERY COST EFFECTIVE RATE. AND
NINETY DAYS TO SET UP IS WHAT
YOU TOLD ME- AND- LEFT TO BREAK
. IF YOU NEED PROPERTY FR
SOMETHING DIFFERENT. NINETY DAYS
FOR THE WHOLE PROJECT BEGINNING
TO END. IT TAKES ONE HOUR TO
ASSEMBLE THE TINY HOMES THAT'S
HOW QUICK THEY GO UP. AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE DAY WHEN WE CAN
BE COMMISSION THOSE TINY HOME
SITES OF THEM SOMEPLACE ELSE IN
THE WORLD- THAT NEEDS THEM. AND
WE CAN HAVE ENOUGH AFFORDABLE
AND SUPPORTIVE HOUSING IN LOS
ANGELES THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- I'M ALLOW ANY QUICK
QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
OF. THE YES. THE FORMER CITY YES
I. I WANT TO THANK OF- MISTER
KRAFT FOR YOUR YOUR CALM SOME
AND COMPLETELY IN LINE WITH YOU
THAT THAT WE NEED TO GET PEOPLE
OFF THE STREETS WE NEED TO
PRIORITIZE GETTING PEOPLE OFF
THE STREETS BECAUSE THEY'RE
THEY'RE THEY'RE DYING AND WE
NEED TO HAVE THAT SENSE OF
URGENCY I WANT TO SAY THOUGH
THAT. WHEN I. TRY TO IT. TO
ADDRESS THAT- SENSE OF URGENCY.
WITH WITH THE BILL THAT I
INTRODUCED- IN THE STATE
ASSEMBLY TO TRY TO PRIORITIZE.
STATE SPENDING. A TO FIRST BUILD
SHELTERS I COULDN'T EVEN GET A
HEARING FOR THE BILL BECAUSE-
YOU KNOW THE- HI MIKE MY
BROTHER- AND SEE MEN ON THE
FLOOR ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAVID CHIU
WHO CHAIRS THE ASSEMBLY HOUSING
COMMITTEE. YOU KNOW. HE IS A
FORMER CHAIR- WAY WAS INDICATING
THAT- YOU KNOW WE DON'T WANT TO
WE DON'T WANT TO FOLLOW THE NEW
YORK CITY MODEL THAT WE DON'T
WANT ALL THE MONEY TO BE SUCKED
UP INTO THE INTO THE SHELTERS
AND I. I COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND
THAT THAT THAT- YOU KNOW IT
SHOULDN'T BE EITHER OR BUT BOTH
BUT- I JUST TO GIVE YOU A SENSE
OF. OF YOU KNOW THE DEBATE-
HAPPENING AGAIN IN THE STATE
CAPITAL I WANTED TO WHAT
TOURNAMENT SESSEGNON. AMEEN YOUR
YOUR YOUR OF- HIGHLIGHTING YOU
KNOW THE BIG THIS THEME THAT
WE'RE HEARING IN TERMS OF THE
LACK OF COORDINATION AND IN IN
TERMS OF THE DIFFERENT SILOS
TRYING TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEM.
AND YET YOU KNOW LIKE- FOR ME I
REPRESENT MOSTLY SUBURBAN CITIES
WHERE WE HAVE LIKE A STRONG CITY
MANAGER MODEL WHERE YOU KNOW I
MEAN THERE THERE IS THERE THERE.
IT'S CLEAR THAT THE CITIES HAVE
A CITY WIDE COORDINATED EFFORT
AND SO I'M I'M YOU KNOW OF THE A
BABE IN THE WOODS IN TERMS OF
THE ROUGH AND TUMBLE OF
REALITIES OF THE CITY OF LOS
ANGELES- I MEAN BUT HEARING FROM
YOU AND FROM COUNCILWOMAN. A
RAMAN OF ABOUT YOU KNOW HOW
THERE IS NO COORDINATED STRATEGY
WHAT THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES YOU
KNOW WITH ESPECIALLY IF- YOU AS
THE FORMER C. A. O. OF BOTH THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES AND LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. YOU KNOW I MEAN
I KNOW YOU WERE YOU'RE POINTING
TO US IT TO THE STATE SAYING YOU
NEED TO DO IT TO YOU KNOW- THE
TO COORDINATE STATE EFFORTS AND
I'M LIKE WONDERING. YOU KNOW WHY
SHOULD WE BE GIVING MORE MONEY
TO THE CITY AND COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES WHEN YOU CAN COORDINATE
YOU KNOW- YOU KNOW YOU'RE YOU'RE
PROGRAMS HERE SO- CAN I ASK FOR
YOUR RESPONSE TO THAT. I THINK
THE- MUCH. MY FIRST COMES FROM
BEING IN BOTH PLACES AND KNOWING
THAT DESPITE THE BEST EFFORTS OF
BOTH THE CITY AND THE COUNTY
YOU'RE HEARD THAT TODAY THAT
THERE IS NO PLACE WHERE THE CITY
AND THE COUNTY LET ALONE THE
OTHER EIGHTY SEVEN CITIES ARE
TRYING TO SORT OUT NOT ONLY BE
IMMEDIATE ISSUES LIKE THE ONE
YOU REYES OF PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AND-
IMMEDIATE SHELTER. BUT REALLY
PLAN OUT FOR THE FUTURE AS TO
WHERE WE'RE GOING AND SO I'LL
GIVE THE EXAMPLE OF L. A. METRO
RIGHT. LA METRO IS A REGIONAL-
GOVERNING SYSTEM THAT OVERSEES
NOT TEST THE EXISTING BRICKS AND
MORTAR OF A SYSTEM THAT IS RAIL.
AND A BUS SYSTEM BUT IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THINKING ABOUT
THE FUTURE. AND WHILE IN PERFECT
AND CERTAINLY HAS ITS SHARE OF
CHALLENGES. A COUPLE TIMES A
MONTH EACH MEMBER OF THE BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS THE MAYOR AND HIS
DESIGNATE AND REPRESENTATIVES OF
THE REGION OF THE COUNTY SHOW UP
AT A MEETING LIKE THIS AND HAVE
TO SORT OUT THE COMPLICATED
ISSUES OF WRITING IN THE SYSTEM
. THE POWER OF THAT IS THAT THEY
HAVE CONVINCED NOT ONLY
ANGELENOS COUNTY WIDE TO TAX
THEMSELVES FOR A FUTURE SYSTEM.
BUT HAVE BEEN VERY AGGRESSIVE
AND EFFECTIVE IN CONVINCING YOU
THE STATE AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO SUPPORT A REGIONAL
SYSTEM BASED ON A LONG TERM
VISION. AS WELL AS TRYING TO
SORT OUT THE REAL CHALLENGES OF.
HOW DO YOU INCREASE RIDERSHIP
HOW DO YOU HAVE DIFFERENT BILL
LADD MODALITIES OF SYSTEM SO THE
MERE FACT THAT THERE IS A PLACE.
THAT FRANKLY WAS CREATED BY THE
STATE IT WASN'T IT DIDN'T IT
WASN'T IT DIDN'T COME FROM US.
THAT THE ISSUE OF TRANSPORTATION
IS LOOKED OUT REGIONALLY WHEN
YOU SHOW UP TO THAT MEETING
YOU'RE NOT JUST REPRESENTING THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES IF YOU'RE
THE MAYOR YOU'RE REPRESENTING
THE REGION. GIVES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK ON THAT
ISSUE ON A ON GOING BASIS. AND
SO THE WHAT WE SUGGEST IS THAT
THERE NEEDS TO BE A PLACE LIKE
THAT. WHETHER IT'S A FORMAL J.
P. A. IN A FORTY THAT HAS
BINDING AUTHORITY AND ABILITY TO
TAX ALL OF US. THAT BUILDS AS
WELL AS MANAGES OR IT'S SIMPLY A
PLACE OF CORD NATION. LHASA IT
IS SUBJECT IS THE IS THE VICTIM
OF THE LACK OF COORDINATION IT'S
NOT BECAUSE EVERYONE ASSUMES
THERE THE IN CHARGE BUT THEY'RE
NOT THEY'LL BE THE FIRST ONE TO
TELL YOU THEY'RE NOT. AND SO.
THAT'S WHAT IF THAT'S WHERE
WE'RE REALLY COMING AT THIS
PROBLEM IS UNDERSTANDING THAT
ALL OF THESE EFFORTS ARE
HAPPENING. AND THERE'S
COORDINATION THAT HAPPENS ON A
VERY EPISODIC BASIS EVERY SINGLE
DAY WITH A LOT OF CARING PEOPLE
A LOT OF INDIVIDUALS WORKING
VERY HARD. BUT IT'S NOT
HAPPENING ON A SYSTEMIC BASIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I'M
GONNA. HI IF I COULD JUST ASK A
MISTER SANTANA- FOLLOW UP
QUESTION- I READ THAT REPORT
SEVERAL MONTHS AGO WITH- WITH
GREAT INTEREST AND YOU KNOW
SOME- FANTASTIC IDEAS- BUT- WHAT
POWER IS ACTUALLY INTENDED TO BE
CONFERRED UPON THIS BODY- YOU
STARTED YOUR REMARKS I RECALL BY
SAYING TAKING POWER IS EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT AND- PROBABLY- A
NONSTARTER SELF HOW DO WE
CONFIRM POWER. OF COORDINATION
OF DECISION MAKING- METRO IS A
GOOD EXAMPLE BUT METRO HAS A LOT
OF POWER- TO COORDINATE AND TO
SPEND MONEY. SO WE I STARTED OFF
WHEN WE DID THIS WORK WITH A
VERY BY A CLEAR BIAS THAT UNLESS
IT HAS THE AUTHORITY TO. CONTROL
LAND BUILD MANAGE TAX BOND THEN
IT WOULD BE A WASTE OF TIME. BUT
THIS IS WHERE HIGHER HIRING AN
OUTSIDE EXPERT ON GOVERNANCE
ACTUALLY IS HELPFUL AND RAY
FIFTY KNOW HIM IS VERY
INDEPENDENT THINKING HE
UNDERSTANDS L. A. FROM A
GOVERNANCE PERSPECTIVE BETTER
THAN ANYONE. AND HE BASICALLY
ARGUED THAT IF YOU START THERE
BY TAKING AWAY POWER FROM
EVERYONE ELSE THAT YOU'RE NEVER
GOING TO MAKE ANY PROGRESS. WHAT
NEEDS TO HAPPEN IS THERE HAS TO
BE A SEPARATE ENTITY WHOSE JOB
IT IS TO ANSWER THESE BIG
QUESTIONS LIKE WHAT IS OUR TEN
YEAR PROJECTION. WHAT ROLES TO
EACH JURISDICTION HAVE WHAT WHAT
IS THE QUESTION THAT WAS ASKED
EARLIER WHAT PERCENTAGE OF THE
FOLKS WHO ARE SUFFERING FROM
HOMELESSNESS ARE ALSO SUFFERING
FROM ADDICTION AND THE MENTAL
ILLNESS THERE ISN'T AN ANSWER
FOR YOU TODAY. WHAT IS IT GONNA
TAKE. AND REALLY BUILDING A
CONSENSUS AROUND THOSE ISSUES
AND HAVING EACH ENTITY DO THEIR
PART. NOW ULTIMATELY I STILL
THINK YOU NEED AN AUTHORITY THAT
HAS THE POWER TO ACTUALLY
IMPLEMENT. BUT IF WE START OFF
WITH THAT PREMISE THAT IN ORDER
TO MAKE THIS WORK PEOPLE HAVE TO
GIVE UP POWER. IT'S GONNA DIE
THERE UNLESS IT'S OPPOSED BY ALL
OF YOU FRANKLY IT WOULD REQUIRE
AN EXTERNAL INTERVENTION EITHER
BY THE VOTERS OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. OR THE STATE OR THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO MANDATE
THAT IN A- IN A IN A CLEAR WAY.
BUT IF IT'S DONE IT'S NOT GONNA
HAPPEN INTERNALLY. THANK YOU-
I'M GONNA GO AHEAD AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION
OF BIG ROB AUTHORITIES HANGING
OUT HERE IN THE COLD- IT ONLY
EMPHASIZES. THE SENSE OF URGENCY
FOR THOSE WHO ARE LIVING IN
TENTS ON THE STREETS OF THE LA
REGION. AMBASSADOR EXPELLER COME
UP MISS LAW FROM CENTER CITY FOR
THE FUSION. DHIMMIS IN THE MIDST
. MR ROSENBLOOM FROM THE- LA
BUSINESS COUNCIL- AND MISS-
COLQUITT FROM- DOWNTOWN WOMEN'S
CENTER PLEASE. YEAH WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON AND OFF ON JULY
FOURTH WE- YEAH. THANKS FOR.
UHHUH THE BILL WOULD BE A THE-
LATER ON THE JEFF. AFTER MISS
LAW- WOULD YOU CAN KICK A SAUCE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE TODAY OKAY THANK YOU SOME.
IT'S WONDER TO BE- IN JOINT
SESSION IS PANEL A GROUP OF. I'M
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO DON'T KNOW
ME MY NAME IS JESSICA LAL I
SERVE AS PRESIDENT AND CEO OF
THE CENTRAL CITY ASSOCIATION
PROBABLY REPRESENT OVER THREE
HUNDRED MEMBERS ACROSS LA AS
SMALL AND LARGE BUSINESSES MANY
OF WHOM ARE REAL ESTATE
DEVELOPERS ARCHITECTS DO A LOT
OF WORK IN HOMELESSNESS AS WELL
AS- SERVICE PROVIDERS AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPERS- OUR POLICY
AGENDA FOCUSES ON MAKING
DOWNTOWN. THE PLACE FOR HOUSING
AT ALL INCOME LEVELS AND
ADVANCING COMPREHENSIVE
SOLUTIONS TO HOMELESSNESS SKID
ROW WE KNOW IS AT THE CENTER OF
THE CRISIS AND WE BELIEVE THAT
SKID ROW SHOULD BE USED AS THE
BAROMETER FOR MEASURING OUR
PROGRESS- WE BELIEVE THAT WE
HAVE MADE PROGRESS IN SETTING
REALISTIC GOALS IN TERMS OF WHAT
OUR HOUSING NEEDS ARE. BUT THAT
WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT THE
HOUSING UNITS ARE ABLE TO BE
KILLED AND I WAS WAS HIGHLIGHTED
IN ORDER TO DO SO WE BELIEVE WE
NEED STRONG ACCOUNTABILITY AND
COORDINATION AND THE CONTINUED
SENSE OF URGENCY. WE KNOW THAT
HISTORIC UNDER PRODUCTION OF
HOUSING CONTRIBUTES TO
HOMELESSNESS LOS ANGELES HAS
BEEN HAS UNDER PRODUCE NEW
HOUSING AND HAS NOT KEPT UP WITH
DEMAND. DOWNTOWN IS ACTUALLY
PRODUCE THE MOST NEW HOUSING
UNITS OF ANYWHERE IN THE NATION
THIS YEAR AND ALSO ACCOUNTS FOR
ONE THIRD OF ALL NEW APARTMENTS
BUILT IN THE CITY OVER THE LAST
DECADE BUT THE CITY AS WE KNOW
IT AS A WHOLE IS NOT BUILDING
ENOUGH UNITS. THE CITY HAS
ACTUALLY ONLY BUILT ABOUT ONE
THIRD OF THE HOUSING THAT WE DID
DURING ITS PEAK PRODUCTION YEARS
WHICH WAS SEVENTY SEVEN HUNDRED
UNITS PER YEAR NOW COMPARED TO
THE TWENTY TWO THOUSAND UNITS
BUILT BETWEEN NINETEEN SIXTY IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE. WE NEED
TO BUILD MORE HOUSING ACROSS THE
CITY TO MEET PASSED EXISTING AND
FUTURE DEMANDS AND WE MUST MAKE
IT MORE COST AND TIME EFFECTIVE
TO DO SO OUR MEMBERS ADVOCATED
FOR THE CITY TO HAVE A HOUSING
PRODUCTION REQUIREMENT. I'VE
NEARLY HALF A MILLION UNTS
WHICH NEEDS TO BE MET BY TWENTY
TWENTY NINE. AND ABOUT HALF OF
THOSE UNITS NEED TO BE
AFFORDABLE. THE CITY'S RECENTLY
ADOPTED HOUSING ELEMENT
ESTABLISHES A FRAMEWORK TO BUILD
THIS HOUSING EQUITABLY. NEAR
RESOURCE AND TRANSIT RICH AREAS.
OVER THE NEXT THREE YEARS THE
CITY WILL NEED TO UPDATE ZONING
TO ACCOMMODATE THE AMOUNT OF
HOUSING NEEDS TO BE BUILT. WE
ALSO MUST CONTINUE TO BE MORE
WELCOMING ACROSS THE SPECTRUM OF
INNOVATIVE HOUSING TYPOLOGIES
LIKE MICRO UNITS ADOPTED YOU RE
USE AND MASS TIMBER WHICH IS A
PRE FABRICATED ALTERNATIVE THAT
CAN BE BUILT TAUGHT TO. TALL
WOOD BUILDINGS. WE'VE SEEN WHAT
CAN BE ACCOMPLISHED WHEN
GOVERNMENT IMPROVES APPROVAL
PROCESS I WANT TO RECOGNIZE
CHAIR SANTIAGO FOR AB ELEVEN
NINETY SEVEN WHICH STREAMLINED
APPROVAL PROCESS FOR PERMANENT
SUPPORTING AN INTERIM HOUSING.
SAVING TIME AND REDUCING UNDUE
INFLUENCE WE ALSO SAW AN INTERIM
NON CONGREGATE SHELTER STOOD UP
IN RECORD TIME WITH THE SOLEUS
CARE FIRST VILLAGE THAT USE
MODULAR CONSTRUCTION AND STRONG
CITY AND COUNTY DEPARTMENTAL
COORDINATION. IN ORDER TO MEET
THE MOMENT WE MUST CONTINUE TO
HAVE ACTION COORDINATION
STRATEGICALLY AT ALL LEVELS OF
GOVERNMENT THE STATE OBVIOUSLY
HAS AN IMPORTANT ROLE TO PLAY.
AND I WANT TO OFFER UP THAT THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY AND PRIVATE
SECTOR WANT TO BE A PART OF THE
SOLUTION. LEVERAGE THEIR
EXPERTISE THEIR RESOURCES TO BE
A PART OF AS A CONSIDERED
PARTNER I'M WITH THAT I YIELD MY
TIME I KNOW WERE WERE LATE BUT
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR- FOR HAVING
ME AND GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK TODAY. THANK YOU MISS
ALL I APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE
TODAY AND I THINK YOU GUYS ALSO
PRODUCED A REPORT THAT WE WILL
ALSO LOOK THROUGH. THE PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENT YES THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
WHICHEVER ONE OF YOU TO WANT TO
GO I'M OKAY WITH WHATEVER ORDER
YOU CHOOSE. GOOD AFTERNOON-
CHAIR AND UNDER GET A MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE HI MY NAME IS
HERIS ROSENBLOOM I AM THE
ROSALINDE AND ARTHUR GILBERT-
FOUNDATION FELLOW FOR THE LOS
ANGELES BUSINESS COUNCIL
INSTITUTE- WHERE I FOCUS ON
GUIDING THE INSTITUTE'S HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS POLICY
INITIATIVES. OF THE L. A. B. C.
INSTITUTE IS THE RESEARCH ARM OF
THE LOS ANGELES BUSINESS COUNCIL
IT WAS CREATED IN TWENTY TEN AND
HAS DONE RESEARCH EXTENSIVE
RESEARCH ON HOMELESSNESS AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND IT
SUPPORTS THE WORK OF THE L. A.
B. C. WHICH REPRESENTS OVER FIVE
HUNDRED BUSINESS GOVERNMENT
PHILANTHROPIC AND ACADEMIC
MEMBERS. JUST LAST WEEK- THE L.
A. B. C. INSTITUTE RELEASED A
HOMELESSNESS SURVEY THAT HAS
BEEN MENTIONED THROUGHOUT THE
AFTERNOON- AT THE HOMES THE
SURVEY WAS CONDUCTED BY HART
RESEARCH ASSOCIATES IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE L. A.
TIMES- AND UC BERKELEY'S
INSTITUTE OF GOVERNMENTAL
STUDIES- THIS IS A FOLLOW UP TO
OUR TWENTY NINETEEN SURVEY. THAT
FOR THE FIRST TIME REALLY
HIGHLIGHTED THE OVERWHELMING
ATTITUDE OF VOTERS THAT
HOMELESSNESS IS FAR AND AWAY THE
NUMBER ONE ISSUE IN LA. THIS NEW
STUDY AIMED TO HIGHLIGHT THE
CHANGES IN PUBLIC PERCEPTION ON
HOMELESSNESS OVER THE LAST TWO
YEARS- AND- ALSO WHICH WHICH
KINDS OF SOLUTIONS OF VOTER
SUPPORT TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEM.
SO I'D LIKE TO SHARE SOME OF THE
FINDINGS FROM THE POLL AND
SOLUTIONS THAT PULLED BEST TO
GIVE YOU ALL A BETTER SENSE OF
WHERE- YOUR CONSTITUENTS ARE ON
THE ISSUE. OVERALL HOMELESSNESS
REMAINS JUST AS URGENT IN THE
MINDS OF L. A. COUNTY VOTERS IS
BEEN MENTIONED ALREADY BUT- 94%
HAVE CALLED IT A SERIOUS OR VERY
SERIOUS PROBLEM. A 79% OF
RESPONDENTS SAY THE ISSUE HAS
WORSENED IN THE COUNTY AT LARGE-
INTO THIRD SAY IT HAS WORSENED
IN THEIR OWN NEIGHBORHOODS. AND
THIS NUMBER STOOD OUT A 39%
REPORTED THAT THEY HAVE
CONSIDERED MOVING AWAY- FROM. LA
BECAUSE OF HOMELESSNESS WITH
SPECIFICALLY. IT ALSO
HIGHLIGHTED SIGNIFICANT
ATTITUDINAL CHANGES AMONG VOTERS
THERE'S THE SHIFT. FROM
COMPASSION TO FRUSTRATION AND
EXASPERATION AND IT'S- LARGELY
DIRECTED AT GOVERNMENT AND WHAT
VTERS VIEW AS ON A VACUUM OF
LEADERSHIP. ON THIS ISSUE. AND
STILL NOT NEARLY TWO IN THREE
VOTERS FEEL THAT HOMELESSNESS IS
CAUSED LARGELY BY SOCIETAL
FACTORS- AND THE VAST MAJORITY
ABOUT 76% BELIEVE THAT
CALIFORNIA SHOULD GUARANTEE
ACCESS TO SHELTER AS A BASIC
HUMAN RIGHT- A CLEAR MAJORITY OF
VOTERS. FEEL THAT THIS IS THE
TIME FOR ACTION WHICH HAS BEEN
SAID AGAIN THROUGHOUT THE DAY-
57257% TO THIRTY PERCENT- SO IT
TWO TO ONE MARGIN- THEY WANT
SHORT TERM SOLUTIONS OVER LONG
TERM. OF THAT OBVIOUSLY THE
VOTERS FEEL THAT BOTH ARE
NECESSARY BUT- THEY- THERE IS AN
URGENCY IN THE AND THEIR
FEELINGS RIGHT NOW AND THEY THEY
WANT SOLUTIONS THAT ADDRESS THE
PROBLEM NOW- WE PROVIDED SIX.
SPECIFIC POLICIES THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE USED IN RECENT
YEARS TO REDUCE HOMELESSNESS.
AND ALL ALL OF THE PTIONS
RECEIVE SUPPORT FROM A MAJORITY
OF VOTERS WITH A COUPLE STRONGLY
SUPPORTED- BY ALL BY MORE THAN
HALF. OF VOTERS THE TWO POLICIES
THAT. VOTERS SUPPORTED MOST WERE
HOUSING HOMELESS PEOPLE IN
EXISTING BUILDINGS SO ADAPTIVE
REUSE POLICY IS 81% SUPPORTED
THAT- AND THE BUILDING
COMMUNITIES OF TINY HOMES IT HAS
ALSO BEEN TALKED ABOUT TODAY 80%
SUPPORTED TINY HOME CONSTRUCTION
- 70% SUPPORTED SAFE PARKING
SITES FOR VEHICLES AND RVS TO
SERVICE CAMPSITES. FOR PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS AND
ABOUT TWO THIRDS SUPPORTED THE
ACQUISITION AND CONVERSION OF
HOTELS AS WELL AS THE
TEMPORARILY RENTING HOTELS AND
MOTELS. TO HOUSE HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS TO VOTER IS YOU KNOW
HAVE CLEARLY SHOWN. THAT THEY
SUPPORT THESE INNOVATIVE AND
COST EFFECTIVE PROGRAMS- THAT
THE STATE HAS ALREADY CREATED
AND SUPPORT THEIR EXPANSION BUT
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT.
THESE RESULTS SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED AS ATTITUDINAL IT'S
A- SURVEY THAT- ACCOUNTS FOR A
POINT IN TIME OF HOW VOTERS ARE
FEELING- SO THE IMPORTANT
LESSON. IN THIS IS NOT
NECESSARILY THE SPECIFIC
POLICIES THAT WE MENTIONED BUT
THAT THERE'S A STRONG SUPPORT
FOR FAST ACTIONABLE SOLUTIONS
AND THEN LASTLY. OF VOTERS ARE
LESS WILLING TO TAX THEMSELVES
DESPITE THIS- A BARE MAJORITY
51% OF VOTERS SUPPORTED TAX
INCREASE TO CREATE INITIATIVES
TO REDUCE HOMELESSNESS. HOWEVER
THAT SUPPORT INTENSIFIES- WITH
THE PROMISE OF A PLAN THAT
ENSURES ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY. I'M SO BUT ALSO
VOTERS ARE MORE SUPPORTIVE OF
THE GOVERNMENT USING SOME
FUNDING TO WORK WITH THE PRIVATE
SECTOR- ON SOLUTIONS TO
HOMELESSNESS THAT ARE INNOVATIVE
LOW COST AND CAN BE QUICKLY
DEVELOPED. AT THE L. A. B. C.
HAS SUPPORTED LOCAL ENTITIES-
DRIVING THIS TYPE OF INNOVATION
- FOR EXAMPLE LEHRER ARCHITECTS
WHICH HAS WORKED WITH THE CITY
OF LA TO. DEVELOP A FIRST OF ITS
KIND TINY HOME FACILITY-
TRAMMELL CROW COMPANY WHICH HAS
BEEN A LEADER AND- AFFORDABLE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT AS PART OF
THE CITY'S TOC. PROGRAM GREAT
MODULAR WHICH CONVERTS SHIPPING
CONTAINERS INTO HOUSING UNITS
AND SCS CAPITAL- GROUP WITH HIS
SUPPORT OF HOUSING FUND DELIVERS
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
USING PRIVATE EQUITY- THE
HOUSING ARE HUNG OUT ON HOUSE
NEIGHBORS IS THE TOP PRIORITY
CLEARLY FOR ANGELENOS AND AS
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE L. A. BIT
BUSINESS COMMUNITY- WE
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME- AND THE
INVITATION TO PARTICIPATE ON
THIS- HEARING. AND HOPE WE CAN
CONTINUE TO BE A RESOURCE FOR
YOU ALL AND YOUR OFFICES- IN THE
FUTURE AS WE CONTINUE TO. TO
FIGHT TO END HOMELESSNESS THANK
YOU THE ADDRESS MY- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE I TOOK I
DID TAKE A LOOK AT THE WHOLE AND
THEN IN THE SUMMER SO IF YOU
COULD TAKE A LOOK AT A PORT
PRETTY INSTRUCTIVE- CERTAINLY
STILL THE MOST IMPORTANT ISSUE.
BUT THE URGENCY IS SO MUCH
GREATER AND DEMANDING IMMEDIATE
SOLUTIONS. TO THE PROBLEM WE
DEFEAT AND THAT OF. THE POINTED
TO THINGS. WHICH WHICH ARE IN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IF YOU DO
WITH THE HONOR- SUSAN- YOU
SPOKEN TO US IN THE PAST AND
WERE EXTREMELY GRATEFUL FOR
THAT. THANK YOU FOR COMING BACK
AGAIN- THANK YOU M. I HOPE IT'S
OKAY IF I CONTINUE TO WEAR MY
MASK I'D- FEEL EVENTER LINE
HEALTH CONDITIONS I JUST FEEL
SAFER TO ME HOWEVER YOU PREFER
TO DO IT IS HOW WE'RE DOING.
OKAY THINK. SO I JUST WANT TO
SAY GOOD AFTERNOON TO. CHAIR AND
THE AT. OTHERS FAMILY MEMBERS-
AND I WANTED TO JUST SHARES-
JUST SOME THOUGHTS ABOUT- WHERE
WE FIND OURSELVES AT THIS POINT-
I MYSELF- LIKE MANY WOMEN-
ENTERED HOMELESSNESS BECAUSE OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. AND OF. YOU
KNOW AFTER THREE YEARS OF WHICH
I OF COURSE WAS FROM IT WAS
DEEPLY TRAUMATIZED SAY WAS NOT
AWARE OF IT SO MUCH I WAS JUST
BUSY TRYING TO SURVIVE. AND I
FOUND MYSELF- NOT KNOWING WHAT
TO DO I GREW UP ON THE WEST SIDE
I. WORKED ALL MY LIFE THEY HAD
YOU KNOW A GOOD CAREER IN IT AND
I NEVER THOUGHT I WOULD FIND
MYSELF EITHER A DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SITUATION OR
HOMELESSNESS. AND IT'S- YOU KNOW
I DIDN'T I MY ONLY EXPERIENCE
WITH THE SAFETY NET WAS
UNEMPLOYMENT. ONE TIME. SO
DIVIDE MYSELF WITH NOTHING I I'D
HAD THE FORESIGHT AS WELL AS I
WATCHED YOU KNOW MY SAVINGS AND
ALL MY MONEY DISAPPEAR- YOU HAD
ENOUGH TO MOVE WHAT FEW
BELONGINGS WERE LEFT INTO. THE
STORAGE UNIT THAT WAS WHERE I. I
JUST THOUGHT SOMETHING WOULD
RESCUE ME FROM THE INEVITABLE
HOMELESSNESS OF COURSE NOTHING
DID. AND I WAS THERE. AND WHAT I
WANT TO SHARE IS THAT THE SAFETY
NET WORK. OKAY IT MAY NOT BE
PERFECT. AND THERE ARE SOME
SERIOUS ISSUES I LOOK AT THINGS
I'M CONCERNED WITH OUR THAT YOU
KNOW THEY DE PRIORITIZATION OF
WOMEN IN SO MANY OF THE
STRATEGIES THAT WE THAT WE SEE
PUT TOGETHER- WE HEAR YOU WOULD
THINK IT WOULD NOT BE LIKE THAT.
BUT THE COUNTY PLANNED THE AD
THE CITY CAN'T THE HOMELESS
INITIATIVE THERE WAS NOT ONE
INITIALLY THERE WAS NOT ONE LINE
ITEM FOR WOMEN EXPERIENCING
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. AT ENTERING
HOMELESSNESS. AND YOU HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND THIS IS A RARE THAT
MAY NOT RIVER THAT IS A UNIQUE
CASE THAT. YOU KNOW SOLID DRAMA.
AND THEN ANOTHER LEVEL OF TRAUMA
ONCE WERE HOMELESS. AND. THE I
DON'T KNOW HOW I CAN EXPRESS
WHAT IT'S LIKE TO SUDDENLY FIND
YOURSELF NINE O'CLOCK. AT NIGHT
AND YOU HAVE NO WHERE TO GO NO
FRIEND TO CALL COULD YOU RT
COUCH SURFED RIGHT- AND- YOU
ALREADY HAVE SERVED YOUR WAY
THROUGH YOUR FRIENDS AND FAMILY
AND YOU'RE ALONE AND YOU'RE
OUTSIDE. IT IS TRULY AN AWFUL
EXPERIENCE AND. I AM I RESERVE
SOLUTION WAS TO RIDE BUSES. WITH
RIDE BUSES ALL NIGHT AND MAYBE
IS A TEN THAT YOU KNOW OF IT GO
TO THE OCCASIONAL OVERNIGHT
LAUNDROMAT. AND. THOSE THAT IN
THE BILL LINKAGE REALLY BETWEEN
THE EXPERIENCE OF THE MYSTIC
VIOLENCE AND HOMELESSNESS IS THE
STIGMA AND THE SHAME. INTENSA
VERIS MEANT OF FEELINGS OF AND
IT'S KIND OF MIRRORED BACK AT
YOU WHICH IS UNFORTUNATE. WHILE
I WAS EXPERIENCING THE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE POLICE WOULD WOULD COME
TO THE HOUSE THE FOCUS WAS NOT
ON ME THE FOCUS WAS ON THE
PERPETRATOR. SAME THING WHEN THE
COURT SYSTEM THE FOCUS WAS NOT
ON ME EXCEPT WAS I GOING TO BE A
WITNESS TO STRENGTHEN THEIR CASE
THE FOCUS GIVE ME WAS ON THE
PERPETRATOR- WHEN I FINALLY WAS
BELIEVE IT OR NOT IT WAS DPSS
WITH THE INSTITUTION A
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES THAT GAVE ME THE FIRST
FOCUS ON MYSELF. AND ASK ME THE
QUESTIONS THAT ALLOWED ME TO
START THE PATH OF RETURNING TO
MY LIFE AS GETTING MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES GETTING A CASE MANAGER.
AND OF BEING AND I. WENT TO A
SHELTER. AS FIRST WAS THE
FOURTEEN DAY A VIRGIN SEE BAD.
AND THEN I WAS RETURNED TO
LIVING OUTSIDE WHAT WHAT I FOUND
OUT AT THAT SHELTER THAT THE
ONLY WAY TO GET THAT I WOULD
HAVE TO WAIT THREE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY FIVE DAYS MINIMUM TO GET
HOUSING SERVICES. WAS REALLY.
DEVASTATING. AND THAT'S THE
THING THAT- I MEAN YOU HAVE TO
BE CONSIDERED CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS IN ORDER TO BECAUSE OF
THE NEED IS SO GREAT I
UNDERSTAND THAT WE ALL DO THAT
THERE'S JUST SO MUCH NEED AND WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH HOUSING. AND I
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT TEMPORARY
SOLUTIONS ARE GREAT. BECAUSE
THEY GET SOMEONE INSIDE OUT OF
THIS WHICH I SPENT TIME UNDER.
BUT WE CAN'T KEEP KICKING THE
CAN DOWN THE ROAD WE HAVE TO AT
SOME POINT AND BRACE THE NEED
FOR PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING. BECAUSE WHEN SOMEONE IS
DEEPLY TRAUMATIZED AND PEOPLE
ARE FROM BEING HOMELESS FROM
EXPERIENCING THAT ESPECIALLY THE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE PERHAPS PRIOR
TO THAT OVER 50% OF WOMEN. AT
YOU KNOW ENTER HOMELESSNESS
THROUGH DEVELOPER ISLAND.
STAYING IN THE A TEMPORARY
HOUSING IS VERY HOW DIFFICULT
YOU NEVER YOU'RE ALWAYS
WONDERING OKAY IS IT I MIGHT GET
A BIG KICK TO IT TODAY MY LAST
DAY IS TODAY MY LAST DAY. HAD
DID I FILL THIS OUT THAT IS
HERE'S THE FORM WHAT'S NEXT OKAY
I'M GONNA TELL MY STORY FOR THE
EIGHT HUNDRED TIME. THAT'S
WHATEVER HOUSING IS LIKE. IT'S
ONLY THROUGH PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING THAT ACTUALLY
. THAT YOU YOU HAVE A FINALLY A
FEELING OF SAFETY AND YOU DON'T
HAVE TO CONSTANTLY WAKE UP EVERY
DAY AND WONDER IS TODAY YOU KNOW
MY GONNA BREAK SOME RULE IS THE
FUNDING FOR IT DID THAT. IT
MIGHT MAKE TO YOUR LIMIT
WHATEVER IT IS AND I JUST WANTED
CURRENT THAT WE DO NEED A LOT OF
TEMPORARY OR TRANSITORY. HOUSING
AND SOLUTIONS. BUT NONE OF THEM
ARE PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE NONE OF
THEM ARE HOUSING. I DID IT DID I
DON'T KNOW THE I PERSONALLY
DON'T THINK I WOULD LOOK AT A
TINY HOME AND THINK OKAY THAT'S
MY FUTURE. THAT'S GOING TO BE
WHERE I'M GONNA RETIRE. ENDED SO
MANY OF THESE TEMPER THESE-
TEMPORARY SOLUTION YOU CANNOT
HAVE GUESTS. YOU CANNOT HAVE
OVERNIGHT GUESTS AND IF YOU DO
IT'S FOR A CERTAIN AMOUNT OF
TIME THAT'S NOT HOW A PEOPLE
LIVE BUT THOSE OF US WHO GO
THROUGH THIS YOU KNOW GONE
THROUGH TERRIBLE THINGS END UP
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS THAT
IS WHAT OUR EXPERT THAT'S HOW WE
HAVE TO. YOU KNOW WE'RE GRATEFUL
TO BE INSIDE DEFINITELY. BUT WE
CAN'T LOSE SIGHT OF DIGNITY. AND
WE CAN'T LOSE SIGHT OF. THESE
ARE OUR NEIGHBORS AND THAT COULD
BE ME THAT COULD BE MY NEPHEW
THAT ONE OF THE- OF PEOPLE SPOKE
AND SAID THAT I BELIEVE. THAT
ONE OF THAT THAT ONE OF THEIR
KIDS. OR GOD SENT WAS GOING
THROUGH. OF HOMELESSNESS AND-
METH ADDICTION. AND I'M SURE ALL
OF US MUST KNOW SOMEONE GOING
THROUGH THIS AND IF WE DON'T
IT'S JUST BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
SHARING IT. AND WE DON'T KNOW.
SO IF ANYTHING I WOULD JUST WANT
TO SAY THAT THE MANY THAT THIS
IS NOT A PROBLEM THAT IS GOING
TO GO AWAY FAST AND I KNOW
THERE'S URGENCY. BUT PERMITS
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING IS WHAT SAVED
ME. WITH THE LEVEL OF TRAUMA
THAT I WAS THAT. I IT TOOK SIX
MONTHS. FOR ME TAKE. A BEING IN
A DEEP DEPRESSION ONCE I
WITHOUT. I'VE ALMOST AND I'M SO
SORRY- AT. TO FINALLY START
LIVING THAT AND WEEK. AND
ANYWAYS I'M JUSTGONNA SAY THAT
WE NEED TO SUPPORT BECAUSE OF
THE TRAUMA. WE NEED TO HAVE
SOLUTIONS LIKE PERMITS PART OF
HOUSING THAT IS THE ONLY WAY.
WHERE SOMEONE CAN ACTUALLY START
RECOVERING AND REJOIN SOCIETY.
BEING PRODUCTIVE SO THANKS FOR
BEING HERE. HELLO THANK YOU FOR
COMING COMING TODAY AND- GIVING
YOUR TESTIMONY AND STATEMENTS
THEY'RE VERY POWERFUL. AND I
CERTAINLY HEAR YOU VERY LOUD I
THINK IT'S A COMBINATION OF A
CONVERSATION THE SET ALL THINGS
ON THE TABLE BECAUSE YOU NEED
MORE. BUT I THINK THAT'S WHAT
THE CONVERSATION WAS POSSIBLY
ONE OF THE OTHER BUT BUT- AND
WITH THE POLL REFLECTS. BUT BUT
BUT THANK YOU VERY VERY MUCH OF
LIKE TO CONTINUE THIS
CONVERSATION WITH YOU BECAUSE I
THINK WHAT YOU HAVE TO SAY IS
VERY POWERFUL INSTRUCTIVE TO THE
WHAT WORKS. AND WHAT DOESN'T
WORK- WHEN PROVIDING- AND
HELPING PEOPLE TO BE HEALTH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL THE
SOLUTIONS ARE IMPORTANT AS PART
OF THIS YOU KNOW WE NEED
TEMPORARY LEVEL WAITING FOR THE
PERMIT I DON'T WANT TO DISCOUNT
THAT YEAH. YEAH BUT I WOULD LIKE
TO COME. DOWN LANDING A ENGAGE
IN A CONVERSATION WITH YOU ABOUT
WHAT WORKS APPROACH AND WHAT
DOESN'T WORK IN APPROACH- FROM A
USER PERSPECTIVE BUT I THINK
THAT. THAT. PIECE CAN'T GET LOST
. I THE- THING YOU. THANK YOU
AND I ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM- COMMITTEE MEMBERS. YES. I
JUST HAD TO- ONE QUESTION TO
HIGHLIGHT WHAT I SUSPECTED WHICH
IS THAT- THE- THE STATISTIC OR
THE SURVEY RESULT THAT- ON ON
FROM THE BUSINESS COUNCIL THAT
THAT YOU FOUND THAT FIFTY ONE
PERCENT- THIS WOULD SUPPORT
EIGHT ANOTHER. TAX INCREASE- IT
IF I RECALL CORRECTLY THAT
NUMBER IS MUCH LOWER THAN THE
PERCENTAGE OF VOTERS THAT
SUPPORTED MEASURES HM MEASURES
HHH DO YOU DO YOU SEE A TREND IN
TERMS OF- YEAH I THINK OVERALL-
THE SURVEY HIGHLIGHTED THERE'S.
THERE'S GROWING FRUSTRATION AND
THAT AND IT'S REFLECTED IN.
VOTERS WILLINGNESS TO TAX
THEMSELVES WITHOUT A PLAN AND
IT'S EVEN. WITH THE COPY OUT
THAT THERE IS. THAT YOU PUT
FORWARD A PLAN THAT'S CLEAR
THAT'S ACCOUNTABLE THAT HAS
TRANSPARENCY IT'S STILL A LITTLE
LOW. MAJORITY 63% IS A MAJORITY
BUT IT'S NOT. IT'S NOT
CONSIDERED- WHAT I GUESS A SLAM
DUNK WHEN YOU'RE TRYING TO ENACT
SOME SORT OF NEW TAX MEASURE- SO
I DO BELIEVE THERE IS. THIS
FRUSTRATION HAS HAS CREATED
AMONG VOTERS. A LITTLE BIT MORE
WARINESS IN TERMS OF SPENDING
MORE MONEY EVEN THOUGH THEY WANT
TO SEE THE PROBLEM SOLVED NOW.
WHICH I GUESS YOU COULD SEE AS
BEING SOMEWHAT COUNTER
INTUITIVE- BUT I DO THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE. THEY ARE
STILL WILLING IT'S JUST. THERE
HAS TO BE A CLEAR PLAN CLEAR
ACCOUNTABILITY CLEAR
TRANSPARENCY SO THEY KNOW THAT
WHEN THEY'RE WHEN WE'RE SPENDING
THE MONEY IT'S GOING TO THINGS
THAT THEY THEY SEE OR FEEL ARE
GOING TO MAKE AN IMPACT. IN A
SENSE. THANK YOU N. DON'T KNOW
FOR THE QUESTIONS WE HAVE TO-
PEOPLE SIGNED UP FOR PUBLIC
COMMENTS I BELIEVE- AND YOU'RE
AT THE POINT TO ME MARYLAND
WHERE THE PUBLIC COMMENT MIKE IS
HOW MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH BY
THE WAY THEY. OKAY WHAT THE
PANELISTS ARE I'VE BEEN
INSTRUCTED THANK YOU ALL FOR
COMING I REALLY APPRECIATE IT
CAREFUL THAT YOU DON'T SLIP- I
ALMOST DID ON THE WAY TO THE
RESTROOM. AND AGAIN FOR BEARING
OUT HERE BEING COLD BUT IT'S-
BUT I THINK IT JUST NECESSARLY
A IT HIGHLIGHTS HOW TOUGH LIFE
IS. FOR PEOPLE WHO ON HEALTH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I'M A
LIMIT OF PUBLIC COMMENTS TO TWO
MINUTES IF THAT'S COOL WITH
EVERYBODY IT'S USUALLY WE DO IN
THE BUILDING- PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELF TO PLEASE THANK YOU FOR
COMING. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
ALICIA ROAD IN. I AM A- VACCINE
AMBASSADOR FOR THE DEPARTMENT
FOR THE- DOWNTOWN WOMEN'S
CENTER. WHICH MEANS THAT I'M
ALSO A COMMUNITY SERVICE WORKER.
I WANT TO LET YOU KNOW THAT IT
IS IMPORTANT THAT WOMEN GET
SERVICES. EVERY COMMUNITY
SERVICE WORKER I SEE WOMEN
LIVING IN TENTS. I SEE WOMEN
WITH CHILDREN. THAT IS TRAUMA.
THERE NEEDS TO BE MORE FUNDING.
WHY DO I SAY THAT I'VE BEEN
HOMELESS. I DIDN'T KNOW HOW TO
MAKE IT WITH KIDS. IT IS SO
IMPORTANT WHAT I SEE. OUR THREE
SENIORS EVERY DAY. HER NAME SOME
CAN'T GET MEDICAL CARE WE HAVE
TO BE ABOUT GIVING PEOPLE
HOUSING. AND THE WAY THAT PEOPLE
GET IS SCARY I SEE SOME PEOPLE
WHEN I GO INTO THE ROOM KEYS OF
PLACES OR THE DIFFERENT SHELTERS
SAY I WOULD RATHER GO BACK AND
LIVE IN THE TENT IF I HAVE TO
WAIT A LONG TIME. THAT IS NOT
FAIR. I DIDN'T LIKE IT BUT I WAS
HELPED. THIS CENTER HERE HAS
HELPED MANY PEOPLE IT HELPS ME
I'M SIXTY ONE YEARS AGO I GET TO
GO OUT EVERY DAY HELP PEOPLE
HELP THEM GET RESOURCES HELP
THEM ALSO LEARN ABOUT CODING. I
ACCESS THAT PEOPLE HELP WOMEN
ARE FEARFUL MANNER FEARFUL AND
THEN YOU LOOK AT THE BABIES
EVERYDAY WHEN I COME TO WORK
SOMETIMES I SEE WOMEN WITH FIVE
OR SIX BABIES. THAT'S A HEARING
. I SEE WOMEN IN KIDS WHO ARE
WHO ARE NAKED. THERE NEEDS TO BE
MET MORE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
GO TO THOSE STUDENTS. YES
THERE'S BEEN SOME GOOD. BUT
THERE NEEDS TO BE MORE. BECAUSE
WE SHOULDN'T HAVE THIS EVERY DAY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MA'AM FOR
YOUR PUBLIC COMMENTS WE VERY
MUCH APPRECIATED. I BELIEVE WE
HAD ANOTHER DIGITAL. THERE YOU
GO MAN THANK YOU. EARLY IN MY
BAG I JUST WANT. EVERYBODY WITH
GREAT. SO THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE WITH US TODAY SO. THERE'S A
LOT OF THINGS ABOUT BUDGETING.
AND HI FOLKS WHO LIKE PEOPLE
THAT WERE SITTING HERE BEFORE
ABOUT BUDGETING. AND. I WAS KERN
OFFENDED WHEN THEY SAID THAT. IT
WASN'T A PLAN. TO HAVE A
STRUCTURE IN THIS WAY RIGHT MY
NAME IS CHRIS THORNBERG AS- AND-
OUR APPROACH THEM BECAUSE
SOMEONE HAD. INITIALLY TOLD ME
TO COME DOWN TO THE WOMEN'S
CENTER FOR HOUSING. I WAS HERE
SINCE TWO THOUSAND AND TEN I WAS
ONLY ACCOUNTABLE FOR TWO
THOUSAND AND TWELVE AMBIENCE I
STAYED OUTSIDE. UNTIL BY SAY TWO
YEARS I WAS TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN. N. EIGHTEEN THEN I
WAS AT ALL THESE DIFFERENT
SHELTERS THAT THEY PUT YOU IN A
BUS AND THEY RUN YEAR ROUND RAIN
. NO HELP NO BUDGET JUST SHELTER
DEATH IT JUST LIKE A CAUGHT. N.
SO THEY FOUND OUT THAT I WAS
EDUCATED BECAUSE I HAVE TO
RETEST HERE AT THE LEARNING
CENTER SO THEY HAVE A LEARNING
CENTER HERE WHERE THERE'S
COMPUTER THIS THOUGH BUT THE
COMPUTERS THEY HAD WAS IN REALLY
A LEGIT THING SO I HAVE TO GO TO
BMW. AND INVEST IN SOME MORE
COMPUTERS WHICH THEY HAVE BRAND
NEW COMPUTERS AND LEARNING
CENTER NOW. SO THEN ONCE THAT
BECAME ESTABLISH THE COMPUTERS
THAT THE THINGS THAT THE
SOFTWARES AND ALL THAT STUFF
BECAME MORE COMPATIBLE FOR
PEOPLE TO DO A CONSTRUCTION OR A
STRETCHING WAY HERE BECAUSE IF
YOU DON'T HAVE ANY TYPE OF
TECHNOLOGY TO INVEST IN TO HELP
PEOPLE WITH THOSE THINGS THEN
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE ANY
PIPELINE. SO MUCH THAT WAS
CREATED. PEOPLE START TO BE YOU
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS WHICH IS
LEGAL JOBS A LITTLE BIT OVER TWO
MINUTES JUST TO PASS SO
BASICALLY OKAY BASICALLY WHAT
I'M SAYING TO YOU IS. THERE IS
THERE IS A BUDGET THAT NEEDS TO
BE ADDRESSED. SO IF YOU DON'T
HAVE ANY TYPE OF BUDGET THEN
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
PLACE THOSE MEASURES. AND IF YOU
IF YOU DO HAVE A BUDGET THEN
WHAT IS IT YOU KNOW TO ME WHAT
IS THE PLAN. I WISH I SHOW THEM
A BUDGET THEY MAKE THINGS HAPPEN
YOU KNOW TO ME SO IT'S LIKE. OUR
APPROACH PEOPLE THEY LIKE ALL WE
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS WE SUPPOSED
TO BE WORKING HERE. I'M LIKE
HE'S WILL BE WORKING HERE THEY
LIKE YEAH. SO WHAT I DID WAS I
DID LIKE THIS. THEY START
WORKING THATFAST. NO PROBLEM NO
NO INFORMATION NO NOTHING I MEAN
LIKE HE SAID NO PLAN. I DON'T
GIVE THEM NO MY NAME HE CAN GIVE
ME HIS NAME HE JUST ARE WORKING.
SO IT'S NOT REALLY WHAT'S GOING
TO HAPPEN OR WHAT'S GOING TO
HAVE TO HAVE BEEN. ABLE TO JUST
HAPPEN YOU KNOW I MEAN AND I
THINK YOU VERY MUCH FOR CALLING
AS ONE OF THE FAIR TO EVERYBODY
BECAUSE WE SAID EVERYBODY TWO
MINUTES AND I DON'T WANT TO. GO
TOO FAR. GOT MYSELF OFF THANK
YOU SO MUCH. FOR YOUR COMMENT I
REALLY DO APPRECIATE THEM. AND
I'M NOT GONNA. DO ANY LONG
SPEECHES TO CLOSE OUT OTHER THAN
BOOK THAT WE'VE LEARNED. WHAT WE
TALKED ABOUT WHAT WE ALREADY
KNOW IS THAT IF. THIS IS GONNA
TAKE A PARTNERSHIP WHATEVER
LEVEL GOVERNOR THERE'S NO ONE.
ENTITY THE FINGER POINTS THERE'S
NO- ONE PERSON OR- ENTITY WHO
IS. ENTIRELY RESPONSIBLE ITSELF
ALL HANDS ON DECK. OUR MERGING
SEA. APPROACH THAT WE'VE GOT TO
TAKE. A TO SOLVE HOMELESSNESS
AND- THERE SHOULD BE NO
OBSTACLES IN OUR WAY AND IF
THERE IS. WE HAVE TO BREAK THEM
DOWN. BECAUSE WHAT THE
CONSEQUENCE. IS PEOPLE SUFFERING
WITHOUT THE APPROPRIATE
WRAPAROUND SUPPORT SERVICES AND
STE AND ROOF OVER THEIR HEADS-
THAT'S THE CONSEQUENCE OF US NOT
GETTING THIS RIGHT SO WE'VE GOT
TO GET IT RIGHT. A FOR THE SAKE
OF THOSE PEOPLE WHO WHO. WHO
NEED THE HELP AND FOR THIS M. A.
N. D. TO GENERATIONS WITH THE
MESSAGE I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
WANNA CLOSE THIS OUT. I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR GREAT
HEARING THAT CLEARLY WE HAVE A
LOT OF WORK TO DO THANK YOU. AND
I PROMISE NOT TO LONG SPEECH AT
THE END BECAUSE FOLKS HAVE BEEN
VERY. KIND TO KEEP US OUT HERE-
AND IF WE TAKE AWAY. ANYTHING
OUTSIDE OF THE CONVERSATIONS
THAT WE'VE JUST HAD. IT'S A
SENSE OF URGENCY WE SPENT ONLY.
A COUPLE HOURS OUT HERE SEVERAL
HOURS A MORNING- IN THE WET.
COLD- UNDERNEATH SOME TENSE BUT
COULD YOU IMAGINE FOR THOSE
PEOPLE WHO HAVE TO BE OUT THERE
DAY IN DAY OUT IT IS
UNACCEPTABLE. FOR GOVERNMENT
TODAY IN THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY. IN THE WORLD TO ALLOW A
PERSON. TO SUFFER- THE OUTSIDE
BLISTERING COLD OR THE HEAT- I
JUST DON'T KNOW HOW TO SAY OTHER
THAN THAT. AND I THINK THE QUOTE
THAT MISSILE LEASE.
APPROPRIATELY HAD SAID- WHICH IS
IF WE COULD SEND SOMEBODY THE
MOVIE CAN'T FIGURE OUT HOW TO
PUT A SHELL SHELTER OVER THEM-
ACT. I DON'T KNOW HOW IT MORE
CLEARLY WE COULD SAY. THAT THERE
IS A SENSE OF URGENCY AND WE'VE
GOTTA PUT. THAT SORT OF GOD LIKE
SPEED TO IT. BECAUSE PEOPLE
CANNOT WAIT ANY LONGER. THANK
YOU.